And we're live the.off 5,000 fan club boy,
first big meeting,
cowboy Cerrone,
fight another cowboy,
cowboy Oliveira,
all the Vietnam we are live.
This is a fight companion.
If you've never heard one of
these before and you're like,
well,
I'm hoping a podcast are going to talk
about space or maybe perhaps birth
control.
No.
Uh,
this podcast is mostly
mostly bullshitting.
Like we kind of talk about
the fights that are happening,
but maybe not.
Uh,
edgy is here.
Aka Eddie Bravo,
Aka master of 10th planet.
You should choose you sue.
Hello.
This is a,
it's an honor to be here.
Ian motherfucking McCall.
Creepy in the house.
Hollow that bitches.
Holla.
I'm covered in fucking hand.
Grace.
I love it.
This stuff's good.
Doctor Chris Ryan.
It is nice.
It's really good for you too.
So wild.
The Ham that the,
uh,
cure it.
And then of course the blend is Shaw.
He's here.
Big Daddy.
That's his new name.
Fat Daddy as a few hours
ago from the hospital.
Yeah.
So whereas for some fights,
Derek Brunson,
he would go,
who's he fighting tonight
is fighting a homeboy.
The the presumably cat.
Oh,
that guy.
the one where the nose of the face
there you go on and go narrow.
Oh,
he's got Gucci.
It's really good Jujitsu and
he's been around for a long time.
Yeah.
It took a long time off the UFC.
Right?
You got cut?
Yeah,
I was going to do second step.
Yeah.
He fought Mark Munoz in his last outing.
Him really choke it.
Like Mark Munoz just does
not want to do it anymore.
What are you retired?
Yeah,
I'm glad he did.
Me Too man.
Like I took some horrible beatings.
Cut Machita one.
Really?
The Weidman line.
The Cheetah one?
Yeah.
Mark's issue was,
you know,
mark was the captain of our team.
Mark issue was
blue.
I mean,
Nicky beat blew the
fuck up between fights.
He said Pilipino,
I mean we're talking,
he was just,
I mean he fought at one 85 db two 42
50 but not like cool to 40 to 50 years.
Like butter bean.
What was he eating?
Everything.
Just feelings as feelings was,
did he have a,
he had depression issues,
right?
It was like,
yeah,
like after,
after the Weidman fight,
yet super depression issues and the loss.
Yeah.
I mean the nicest guy in earth.
The last question,
and there's also the Kao Depression.
That's true.
Physical depression and there,
the more they're looking into that shit.
You didn't know that dude.
Dave Mirror just committed suicide.
That BMX guy,
legend.
Sad to kids.
Cause those BMX was get
a ton of concussions,
right.
Slamming their head against
the concrete and shareable,
horrible.
And they fall from 30 feet up in the
sky and all that momentum just lap.
Hmm.
I've had some friends that
I've watched people or had friends in
all those sports and hurt themselves.
It's,
yeah,
they hurt themselves and then
they become a different person.
Totally like they,
their brain gets so scrambled,
they're just not the same again.
They get super depressed.
Yeah.
That's a big part of a head trauma is
depression or those guys born without
fear.
What is it like that does do to do
crazy BMX stuff and motocross tricks and
flips and jumps?
You've got,
you can't have any fear.
They think we're fucking crazy.
That's the fucked up part.
I've,
I've spent my whole life knowing
a lot of these kids and uh,
one of my buddies,
you know,
same as me,
has a couple,
you know,
does it a couple of kids,
his wife and one,
a couple of axioms gold
medals and he's like,
well how do you do that?
It's like such a nice guy.
He's this tiny,
frail kind of,
not frail,
but he's whips and bike around,
but he's just smaller and he's like,
how do you do that?
You know,
hurt somebody.
I'm gonna fucking hurt yourself man.
You've got kids.
And I'm like a year.
I saw you this morning.
50 feet above the ground.
Upside down with the fucking
motorcycle it though.
Fuck you talking about.
Those dudes are nuts.
What do you mean everybody's
got their own idea of like,
what's scary though?
It's weird for some people,
the scariest thing in the
world is public speaking.
Now,
true in this doing this
would be terrifying,
but to us this is,
was this like a hangout?
Love it.
We have to remind ourselves,
what do we have your headphones
on and that we're on?
No,
see often,
but like to me,
the idea of jumping,
flipping through the air and a motorcycle.
Fuck all that.
Skydiving is fun though.
Don't fucking fuck.
See,
I would never date.
I did a lot of stupid sports.
I put myself in the hospital snowboarding.
Like I was tiny.
But I've been good at just
about everything I've done.
And uh,
yeah,
I think I'm done skiing,
man.
I haven't done it in awhile.
I went skiing last week and did
you really fucking one wipe whore?
She wants no boom,
no skiing.
I like scan,
but um,
it's not,
it's not the problem.
The problem is just,
there's a lot of people
on the fucking mountain.
You're coming down to an hour.
Where'd you get all these people?
Um,
Park City,
Utah.
I love it there.
I love it.
It's so when you're coming down,
oh God does.
When you get the wrong as fuck,
but you coming down the
mountain and you like,
don't get hurt.
Don't get hurt,
Don't get hurt.
Oh,
I didn't get hurt.
Let's try it again.
Don't get hurt.
So there's always people
that are zipping and zagging.
There's people way better than you and
the people that suck more worse than you.
And you know you're managing all
this stuff as you're going down.
There's so many people
on the mountain man,
because it was I guess
president's Day weekend.
What was the last weekend
that the president's space,
so it was super crowded.
Do you fall multiple times every run?
No,
I felt three times in two days,
but that's one good one was hard.
I grew up doing it,
man.
Fuck that noise.
I'm going it with valves to man scheme,
skiing,
snowboarding,
snowboarding.
I want to,
I want to go before the snow melts.
I couldn't pay me enough to do it,
dude.
I'm an asshole.
Well I try.
I try and do things I used to
do when I was in high school.
Like,
Oh,
I'm like,
I can rodeo that or I can frontside five
that or do something over this jump and
then I end up under
these terms you're using,
doing and spins and you
do a Rodeo.
You flip in the air.
I've been a fucking smile.
I am.
I can flip over anything cause
you flipped to in snowboarding.
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
Hit your face.
You're one of those guys.
But I was never that good.
I would just try that.
So my brother on the other
hand was really good and then,
but of course he blew out his
knee twice to collar bone breaks.
Call the bronze,
always gone when you,
when you landed wrong and
you'd landed face down.
That's how I brought mine
with guys friends that are,
that are crazy like that.
I would just slide down the mountain.
I have no Carbone is one of those moves
that assholes think they could end a
fight with.
Like Jesse James was on Howard Stern.
He was talking about street
fighting and he was like,
dude,
I just hit people in the collarbone.
Ah Fuck you.
Fuck you
come here.
You get close with my collar on it.
You have to do.
Is this
working?
Maybe it's,
what's your first seven
get close enough and you're
like crap in your hand.
Believe like you don't want
to fight and you're like,
dude,
let's just talk this out,
but you're not a straight punch.
The collarbone ain't doing Jack
Shit is not doing Jack Shit.
The sternum
so big.
Let's say his big ass
guy punches like a bitch.
Garen Sternum from downtown.
If you're standing there waiting for
stop saying you're talking to a girl and
he's like,
hey boom.
His buddies,
his tracks,
what comes up and he called talk.
Tough guy stuff.
When they say like,
I'll hate a guy in the
sternum or I'll hit the guy,
the guy in the collar bone like just
stop talking about Steven Seagal.
One old one.
That's what you're talking about something
generally people say his life with
Eddie Bravo and I had the worst guy ever.
There was a guy who told us he
would grabbed your thumbnail.
He would pinch down.
You're thrown out.
Do you remember that?
Remember that guy,
Vinny from the comedy store number,
the,
the fake Jujitsu or however,
remember that guy?
Yeah.
He would grab your thumb and
press down your thumbnail.
He was convinced that he,
I'll just grab you.
I'll grab you like this and I'll,
there's a pressure point in the
tip of your tongue and your tip,
your thumb.
It's intolerable.
Pain is intolerable and I'm like,
this motherfucker like you
just want to hit him with it.
He grabbed,
he grabbed my thumb up my deck.
Let me show you,
but it doesn't hurt me.
It hurts.
It doesn't feel good,
but it doesn't even make you scream.
It doesn't even make sense.
It doesn't make any sense.
First of all,
good luck holding it onto it.
It's just a tip of your thumb.
And if I'm that guy and
I'm selling that lie,
whatever,
to chicks or wherever to get
laid and Joe Rogan comes around,
I'm not saying shit.
Meanwhile,
suck your thumbs before you fight.
Slippery lube up your thumbs.
Just stop.
Is this James Kraus?
Oh yeah,
he's good.
I liked that guy.
Okay.
Fun fights tonight.
Who's he's fighting?
Shane Campbell.
Is that who was fine?
Yeah.
The final one to see
most with that was that,
uh,
what's his name?
Cody and a that linker.
Oh,
Linacre yes.
That was the clinic or pulled out yet?
Sick Brazilian.
What's it called?
Oh,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
We got to cross the line.
You got Zika?
No,
no,
not Zika.
What is it?
Nope,
not Miliary something like aids.
Nope.
Gonorrhea man.
That would be cool.
Uh,
leprosy now allow you to fight
with herpes and believe me.
Okay,
Jess Kid wink.
Um,
yeah,
he got it.
It was gone.
You get it from mosquitoes out there,
but you know what?
He's fucking the guy who
stepped up in his place,
his tank,
a Gusto Mendez.
Tackiness that guy beat half a
Mendez to win the world championship.
So the Guy Tacchini I was
fighting fucking tonight.
Cody hits like a tank.
Dot.
Yeah.
And He's first team.
All cute guy would know Jujitsu and all
of a sudden he's got a guy who's one of
the best Jujitsu
big John Tacchino is a fucking tank space.
He's not like a regular Jiu Jitsu guy.
This guy is,
he's known for his ultimate
balance and base like you,
he's going to be on top of your head.
That sucks.
Or Cody,
this is hard,
but by son,
I don't know anything
about promising career.
Check your shit about his strength.
His striking could be carbon.
I don't know.
I had no idea.
But man,
when you can wrestle to
wrestled d one or no,
no,
just a,
I hate saying this shit cause I played
basketball in high school so I never
called myself a basketball player,
but he wrestled in high school.
He's really good.
And they took a,
he had all these PR boxing fights and
kickbox and amateur MMA and Casey suck.
He's good man.
How are you hands?
Extra little factor.
Keanio used to date Mackenzie dern.
So I'm not mad at her at all during
Mackenzie that she's a Jujitsu girl,
right?
Yeah,
she's the best Jujitsu girl on the planet
and she shot by far the hottest girl
to ever.
Grace of GE.
Uh,
I dunno Kira.
Gracie.
It's pretty good.
Then I take,
she's really hot.
I take my kid from bodies.
Then you got to do all the Gracies.
If you date her,
that's even better.
It's tough man.
It's a lot of pressure functions.
Emily,
Brenda do the Gracie Diet
and shit all the time.
Only Waterman and by a sale.
Speaking of the Gracies been
a mad props to hoists Gracie,
even though there was some crazy thing,
you know with Ken shamrock hoist went out
there and did what he does and he does
need guys to the balls.
Come on.
That was it.
That was,
was that really what you can say?
Did what he does?
I told him down and beat
the shit out of camera.
Just wears six straight
strikes to the face.
Six solid saying that
cause he doesn't like
trying to win them back.
Please love me.
Yeah.
Maybe
he showed some series k
one or k three striking
stay for maybe a k five k
you're saying is working.
His was all right.
I thought Ken was like really hesitant.
Stand on the outside.
I thought Kevin Hall light him up.
But I'm saying Ken compared to voices,
what were horse wasn't doing much.
There's no threat to his striking.
So I was like super surprised that Ken
wasn't lighten them up because if you go
back to like Ken that fought Fujita,
Ken had some fucking legit leg go.
Good power.
Yeah.
He 25 years ago,
he's not cripple.
I mean w were,
where did the body go?
He's got to have that power.
He's got to have that
ability at the same joints.
My man maybe,
I mean I don't know what's
going on with his body,
but I would've thought Ken would have
fucked his legs up if I was in Cannes
corner.
I would say you're going to
kick the shit out of this.
Greg's,
you're going to,
he's not,
he's no threat with punches.
It's not like he's going to drop
you with one straight right hand.
Right.
So what you do is you like Paul with the
hands and you come in and you throw a
bomb leg kicks,
Dang gates and gay fever.
That's no joke.
Not Fun.
That kills motherfuckers.
Yeah.
I really thought I would have thought
Ken would have just let those legs on
fire.
But at the same time he had voices,
voices,
chance was on the ground.
He didn't want to get taken care of.
It didn't get were too,
right.
You got that too.
He might've got everything.
Justin Brown,
what was his number one guy down
that would make you hesitant?
Throwing leg kicks,
right.
One.
Not if you're Ken shamrock with his
wrestling background and his striking fuck
it take down from holy space.
He's not like a d one wrestler.
Coaches up and trips.
He clenches up and trips.
If he knows how to do that.
Oh look at this James Crouse.
I see a bright man buddy.
Snug is fun.
Ooh,
that's a taboo.
Does it?
A tap words?
Nope.
Was it around?
Yep.
It was a man.
Um,
has there ever been a bigger
shit show than up bell towards,
but I think it put our
sport back seven years in.
Nah,
just put bell tour back the end of
the three agents now and go belt door.
Fuck man.
Fuck that.
How about data went to the hospital?
Yeah.
His heart stopped.
It was filled with cheeseburgers
and fried chicken and orange soda.
Is there any way you could
have trained for that pipe?
They're trying anyway.
There's no way.
Train.
No,
no way.
He thought he was just hugging me
and my train for a couple of days.
They said he lost 40 pounds.
Well that sound good.
You should have lost 40 pounds before.
They do not like you didn't know.
You don't know the backyards.
Well how about Kimbo?
What the fuck was going on with him?
Yeah,
that was,
that wasn't even an amateur
hours cause you really,
if it's an amateur fight,
like you'd be like chomping at
the bit to get at those guys.
But I hope they're in my bracket.
All you have to do is dance
around for a few minutes.
These guys are toast.
A low level college wrestler.
What a fuck those dudes.
Well,
how about this von Exchange Exchange?
How the one exchange where Donna just
sort of laid down and Kimble just rolled
over on top of him.
He just laid down.
It hurt my soul.
They just hurt my soul.
No take down.
It was like just take
district of ground like,
oh I wonder if they're
talking to each other.
We won't take you to the ground home cause
it's a chill dogs is officially do we
call it the children children.
How about Kimbo in mountain dew?
I felt like
I got done.
I was like,
Oh ours early in the first round though.
It didn't look so bad.
I was like,
legs Kimbos got some ground skills,
you know.
I'm like,
I thought,
okay this guy's getting get fucked up.
Kim is going to pound them out.
But zero gas.
Have you seen the documentary?
That data comes from dot.
Corbin's Billy Corgan.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
He's the best you had him on.
You probably have my bucks.
Billy's Craig Bill.
He's great.
Cocaine cowboys and D.
Yep.
Yes,
yes.
He's great.
Billy's awesome.
That's where I was like,
damn,
Donna has some hands,
man.
This guy is kind of cool.
Kind of cool.
He's got some hands.
Yeah.
I mean he was fighting,
but that's the thing about can crushers.
You look awesome.
If you're fighting,
nobody would,
you know.
But he's two and note.
Then he said he come from fighting
on the back streets of Miami.
Right,
and then you're fucking launched and
Dibella don't know he that he's two and,
oh,
and I think his last opponent,
whoever was talking about it
on the pod on the broadcast,
was talking about the
record of his last opponent.
It was like,
you know,
Oh and sick.
I was like a midget fight.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know what that
showed that showed maybe,
maybe Bella torque just was a little too
eager to try to do things that the UFC
wasn't willing to do.
Well,
no,
but it's the pride thing.
You know what I mean?
And you come out,
ah,
you have Tyson commentating
and he's drunk.
All the stuff,
all the stuff the UFC wouldn't do
belters like we're going to do it.
You do that.
You think Tyson was drunk?
He was on something.
He was on some pills
and he was on some shit.
I think he might've been on a whole
career of getting punched in the head.
You think up to,
hopefully when I have brain trauma,
like that catches up.
I hope.
I'm like that.
He was funny.
Mike Tyson commentating is hilarious.
It was funny.
Yeah,
totally for that.
When Melvin Gallard got knocked out,
he was like,
which radiated ego is ruthless,
ruthless mock Hindus getting teed off on.
He's like,
look where you're going to be eventually.
Look at me,
Justin.
The grand scheme of
things like Bella tore it.
They signed Ben Henderson,
who's a fucking monster that's,
can you want to get all
these other guys come over?
Yeah,
I'm Phil Davis,
so they're making momentum.
Then you put that product out.
If I'm a free agent,
I'm like,
fuck man,
I don't want to play him.
I think they eventually got
to let all that stuff go.
They can't keep doing those.
I couldn't stop.
This is the last one.
It stopped the sale chat
because if they keep doing it,
they're going to really lose credibility.
There's a lot of things they need to do.
That name,
they're sticking with that stupid
fucking name and they're calling it Bella
toward kickboxing to,
hey man,
let's not do that.
Bell Tours,
a dumb name.
Who's this?
Nobody understands it.
Well,
you,
you're rest assured you're,
you're absolutely only going to get
people that are fans of tour already.
They're going to take it
seriously and look for it.
Like people that are flipping through
the channels when they see Bella tour
live,
what does that mean?
What does that mean?
That doesn't mean anything.
But if you have MMA like
old crowd Skout it again.
Damn.
This dude knows how to
turn away from chokes.
He's Nastic,
you know,
but um,
crosses all over him
surviving.
But I'm just thinking if they just,
if they just turn talked
it turned it into MMA.
Uli has cross hits,
a armbar crosses fucking
ferocious on the ground.
And I saw this dude's got his back.
Now if they just turned it into MMA,
everybody knows what MMA is,
man.
Yeah,
but it's valid towards a dumb name.
It's like matters.
I disagree.
Pride.
Yeah.
Rise and didn't mean shit.
Use tools.
Rising tide doing Eddie how's rising?
Implied because of their name.
They failed.
It has nothing to do
with these details by man
damn name.
I thought it was cause of the Yakuza.
But do you pay attention to sneaky shit
that the fucking athletic commission
did?
Manderlay sneaky ass shit they gave,
they randomly signs of fight
with fade or the UFC let some go.
Okay,
so Vandelay finally can make some money.
The dude hasn't been
able to make any money.
So I was in over a year,
I think it's like 17 months.
He hadn't been able to make a dime.
Right.
So He's struggling and um,
the,
the athletic commission
totally did them dirty.
They suspend him for his entire career.
The judge overrules it says that,
that you can't do that.
You can't just suspend the guy forever.
Okay.
You can't just deny him
a right to make a living.
So Vandelay gets released
when the EOC signs to fight,
fade or in rising.
It's a big payday for watch that
finally he's going to get some money.
You know what the
Athletic Commission does,
they fucking suspend them for three years.
So they,
they,
they say,
okay,
we are going to change your suspension
from a lifetime band three years.
So it's retroactive.
So he still has a year and a half to go.
So he can't take this flight,
but rising thing where Japan,
it doesn't matter why it goes
over there and takes that fight.
They'll view it as a violation.
He won't be able to fight
in the United States.
Fuck it,
but doesn't stay.
He'll never be able to
fight in the United States.
So he stockholders and fuck.
But he just said,
here's why you shouldn't Beltour tour.
Probably pay him some
serious fucking money.
Serious fuck will be in a year and a half.
Yeah,
but he's not yelling at national then,
but what's going on?
Yeah,
but rising ain't going to be around
sun rise and doesn't have much time.
And what is he going to do?
He's going to fight for one FC.
No one watches that.
You Know Ben aspirins
been whooping Chinese.
Dude's ass was over there for a year and
a half and one see shit and can't get a
fucking right up on it.
When he talks about it is amazing.
Ragdoll and beating the fuck out of dudes.
And I liked the,
they allow him to use
his knees on the ground,
knees on the ground rising.
He's fighting rising to
his last fight was rising,
but for that was what?
FC Right.
Aoki.
He's fighting chrome fund one FC too.
I think it's first fight was one of safe.
I'm pretty sure I was in Asia.
Maybe.
Maybe it first fight was his
last fight was rising but if I'm,
I'm a wanderly 100 bro.
What are you going to wait around?
I don't know.
The fight in the states thing gets dirty
with the athletic commission did that
they,
they fucked up.
Suspended him right before,
right after he takes his fight.
So by violating it,
essentially they're playing little
games cause by him violating that they,
they're really like,
they get what they want.
They get what they want.
The waterlase Baker over there?
Yeah.
But he all they had to do like how,
how many months away is that fight?
Like it's in August,
right?
Correct.
So march,
April,
May,
June,
July,
August.
If they just gave him two years,
they gave him two years,
he would have been out.
He would have been done
at the end of July.
He would have been able to fight and
they given an extra year so he's fucked.
You know what man?
Two years is what you're supposed to get
because that's what you would've got if
he tested positive.
Correct.
That's what any relation did.
He ran,
let's pretend he was positive.
Pretend he was positive.
Then he's two years.
He's the spine them.
You find them for whatever and you let
the guy have a God damn fucking career.
This is a,
this is a game that I think
it's a game of three years.
Pr.
First of all,
why is it three years when
he didn't test positive?
If it's two years,
if he did test positive,
that doesn't make any sense.
No two years is the right amount.
If a guy runs from a test,
assume he's positive,
he's definitely shooting around.
He definitely should be panelized.
Every fighter who runs from a test
should be penalized as if they tested
positive.
So if that's the case,
why three years,
why not to did over him from a test?
No,
he does know.
He tested positive
horsemeat horseman and all.
I did a German voice but some
mustache to back the Belko.
How about your boy?
Justin wren wants to fight Kimbo slice.
Kimbo slice to go night
night cause Justin Wren,
you can hit that dude
in the head with a rock.
I think he's,
I think a real,
I don't think Justin knocked him out.
I think Justin takes them down
and beats the shit out here.
Then you piece of shit out of him.
He takes him down if he wants to.
But if you standing with them,
all he has to do is keep moving.
But you know Justin,
the reason Justin wants to,
cause it's such a big fight so he
can build wells and fucking Africa.
That's why he was such a mainstream fight.
He's dancing another dude.
He's like,
it's why he deserves it too.
He's just it.
He's awesome and he felt,
or smart.
They should do it to get short,
especially Kimball's last fight.
Let's figure this out.
And you know,
not be as long as fine.
Well No,
I'm just saying it
should be his last fight.
It's whatever.
You know Justin and Kimbo or Swiss fine
on the ultimate fighter 10 it was lined
up and then the suits came in.
They were supposed to fight the week up.
The fight,
the suits came in like,
uh hey Justin.
They sat Justin down like for ratings,
we got to do this.
And then they put in,
then they put in Roy Nelson.
Well that's even dumber because Roy
Nelson is very fucking skill to know they
want to pay them.
I mean it's really Nelson.
Yeah,
but nobody know who Roy was back 10.
Oh Man.
Roy's,
I mean,
he's pretty big.
I think they,
I don't think they
wanted Kimbo to do wells.
What I'm trying to tell him,
oh,
like the UFC did was they knew he was
going to lose because to be honest,
anyone with a good set of skills during
the beat Kimbo so whoever got that first
crack at him,
he was probably gonna get fucked up.
So he fought Justin.
Justin,
you'd be and become a star Roy,
you know?
Yeah.
So it's a big fight.
They didn't want him to do well.
Roy was by far the worst matchup.
Justin was supposed to find him.
The coach had all matched up.
They Yanked Justin,
insert fucking Roy Nelson
with 30 fights.
Enjoy joy that Kimbo.
Yeah,
enjoy getting crucifix.
So now just say squash family.
So now Jostens like,
Yo,
we're supposed to fight.
Let's do it.
I'm trying to build some fucking wells.
Yeah,
he's definitely got a different
motivation than everybody else.
Yeah,
man.
What a great guy.
He is.
Got Such a better guy than me
because I would say my
watches and cars and shit.
There's no,
well,
there's no sense of bad news.
I can't get the well equipment.
What happened?
Some rams around with your Instagram page.
She said watch car.
Exactly the same amount as a,
well,
it's weird,
dude.
I'm not my,
it was a gift.
I bought myself a gift for having a baby.
I guess you get them on.
What about me?
But my snowball rolling.
So
I showed up.
My Dad was like,
what's that?
I'm like,
oh,
I gotta push gift and
a push gift.
Yeah.
Girls get pushed.
Pushkin Oh shit.
There's two dads Krause's back deep.
Two Hooks in.
Oh Shit.
Flattened out.
Nope.
Crouse escape back to his back.
He can escape and Tom
Triangle right there.
Soon as he turns,
he's too smart for that son and he just
one or the other and it's going to have
it as a back taken still dude.
That Mcgregor dos Anjos
makes my dick hard.
Even that flyer right?
It makes it,
it makes other people's dicks hard.
I'm going to say something crazy,
Joe.
You ready for this?
Okay.
I think the toughest matchup possible
in the UFC for Mcgregor is dos Anjos.
I think the easier fight
is Robbie Lawler form.
Wow.
Suck on that.
Yeah,
and I've been thinking about lately
and it's Kinda hit everyone's fucking
talking about this right now and I
was just putting two and two together.
I'm like,
well,
if he does knock out to us telling us,
I was like,
wow,
he's going on 17 rob,
you're going to fucking throw down.
I just know they're not rob.
He's not going to touch them.
You don't think so?
Not a chance.
Wow.
You think he's just going to move around?
It's Robbie up and I love rock
style wise fucks Robbie up.
Where does Connor stop
at?
One 70 why wouldn't he go one 85 he's
already stated publicly that he's not
afraid of any weight class.
Here's what I get that.
But then every visit come into play.
Stay the fuck away from Wonderboy.
Yeah.
That dude's got the
fucking glow right now.
I agree.
He's got the Bruce Lee [inaudible].
What he did to Johnny Hendricks
should be against the law.
They should have shut the lights off.
They should have separated them and go,
Whoa,
whoa.
Not Tonight.
We need to stop this.
Hendrix came in shape,
had all his shots.
Fucking shit figured out.
Biggest karate right now.
Johnny got is strong fuck life for years.
That sport karate has this one element
that no one knows how to fuck with these
blitz guys.
He's Raymond Daniels,
guys that jump in and attack and then
jump out before you can do anything about
it.
And if you don't have like some
serious Nikki holds can style or Joseph
[inaudible] style Moitai skills.
Well you can hands up
high and chop those legs.
Has that right now,
no one has no one in the UFC has it
rebel Raymond Daniels does to everybody
except Niki holds skin and and
Joseph Valtellina in in glory.
Valtellina was the first guy
exposed at chop those legs down,
hands up high,
good guard,
attack,
attack the legs and eventually chop
him down and he had kicked him.
Who stops him?
And the same thing we'd Nikki hold
skin is that super solid Moitai base.
But everybody else gets three
60 wheel kicked in the head.
You,
he hits you that this memo jumping
sidekick touches you with a side kick and
then spins the backache to the city.
So I think one Wonderboy right now beats
everyone said every worst matchup for
him.
Roy McDonald,
he's too smart.
I think you guys always fight
next fuck off Roy MacDonald.
That's what I'm hearing.
I could see Roy thrown a real heavy,
I got form system.
Let's let Wonderboy do his thing.
Why would you give him the
worst matchup possible?
Why wouldn't you give Rory and opportunity
to stop the hype train if that's
what's going to happen.
There you go.
Okay.
What do you think Roy?
He's gonna be able to do to him.
He just wants to wear his skin.
That's all
you know,
came into the world to
smarter than Americans.
I don't,
I don't know if it's
100% it's a rumor I saw.
I saw it was a room.
That's why I mentioned
might've done a little fuck.
It's a room.
I might where a hyped it up
already that it hasn't aired yet.
It might have happened.
I mean I don't remember.
I'd be breaking news fingers.
Right.
That one can sing 15% growing McDonald's
too smart to fall into his traps and
the case.
So what does he do?
He's got to kickbox with them when they're
on the outside and that's where your
stab is fucking nasty.
And then as soon as Roy gets comfortable,
but he fucks everybody.
What does that,
that was a giant one,
dude.
That's the biggest battery I've ever seen.
Anyone of those things.
That thing is like a
paper towel roll anymore.
How long has that battery last?
Let me see.
The last thing.
I Dunno.
You go fucking hiking in the Alps with
that battery and a lot of those like
[inaudible] or you smoked pot.
I was like,
I smoke a lot.
Smoke a lot.
No one.
I knew that about you.
I knew that.
But you knew that.
Yeah.
Maybe I knew and I forgot.
Have you been,
I figured you did.
Is the shit.
I have this thing.
I think it would
say something.
Um,
it's good dude.
That's good.
Roy Wonderboy head tension man may happen.
I may not.
Who knows?
We'll find out.
Connor,
Wonderboy shit.
Connor Wonderboy.
Here's the thing,
Matt,
you got to kick with Wonderboy and
Connor's kicks are just nowhere near the
level of wonder boys.
It's just not even in the same.
He'd be sure about this hands on 100%
his hands are better than wonder boys,
I think.
And wonder boy,
he's got some fucking vicious hands.
That's what knockout power.
What Connor has in that
left hand is what for us,
a hobby.
He likes to call it the touch of death.
I liked the one 45 55 and 75 you're
talking about big boy was knocking
motherfuckers dead at
one 55 with one punch.
He was doing it all throughout England.
I mean,
I don't know if he could do that in
the UFC at one 55 different level.
Mother,
you,
I'm
tea.
You are right though.
Sandra's is a beast.
But I believe the kind
of power that Connor has,
you just has that undeniable.
It's undeniable.
I just don't know if he's going to be
able to do it because here's the thing
about those.
Angela's still Sangiovese is a gap closer
and then mother fucker closes gaps on
you before you even
realized he's on top of you.
He did it the doubt to Donald
and he did it to pedis.
Two guys who were pretty
fucking skillful strikers.
He closes that distance on you in a
surprising way and there's no hesitation.
No hesitation is grappling is outstanding
and there's no hesitation in his game.
And with that,
nick curse on do training him,
man,
he's got 15 gas tanks and they're already,
they're already a movement coach though.
He's the movement coach.
They,
they're doing all these crazy
plyometric jails was a prime interest.
And then you've got,
you know,
you,
you got um,
uh,
fucking he's get king's MMA right.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll feel court Darrell's
one of the greatest striking
instructors in the world.
He's got Fabrizio over doom there.
You've got a shitload of
animals to train with.
He's a complete animal.
Honestly,
as far as natural buys,
you bake the fight down.
I can't think of it.
Worst matchup for Connor.
He beats him.
They're both in their prime.
If he beats him,
he goes right to Robbie Lawler for
UFC 200 and the world exploded.
If he beats him.
Aliens land a fighter of all time.
Yes.
All right.
Here's,
here's an argument that I
was having with somebody.
This is a discussion.
This is a legit question.
Mighty mouse right now degrees the best
pound for pound guy to Saint John John's
Ursula
daring
because the risk,
the risk to reward.
He can make mistakes.
He's destroying the competition,
but he couldn't make mistakes with Dotson.
Dotson dead with one shot different,
different than Jon Jones.
Gustin rumble.
Rumble.
I disagree with Gustafson.
I don't think guts dead with one
punch and easier than Dotson does it?
Matter of fact,
I think Dodson offers
more danger on the feet.
I disagree.
Okay.
But we're allowed to,
um,
you know what?
One 20 zero,
that's fine.
Okay,
so at the very least,
he's number two pound for pound.
Best in the world.
I agree.
Okay.
All right.
I think he's number one.
A lot of other people's thinking is
done want including boss route and,
but what the fuck she now,
right.
Joe Rogan buzzers.
It makes sense.
So if,
if so Hutto beats him.
He's an Olympic gold
medalists and wrestling.
So he becomes the first Olympic gold
medalist and wrestling that wins a
flyweight title.
Okay.
And he beats arguably the best guy ever.
If Demetrius Mighty Mouse Johnson is the
best guy right now and you fought him
before,
yes.
I know.
You look at them like today and you look
at what he's been able to do over his
last few fights.
It's hard to argue more dominant champion.
He doesn't get hit.
Yeah.
It doesn't get hit by the best guys.
Cruise beat them.
Yes.
A long time ago at one 35
he's a different fighter then.
Just say Ian,
arguably one as well.
I'll tell you that.
It's not my pound for pound number.
Why?
But that's a long time ago.
So it,
they'll sign.
I Click Guido,
who's John Jones lost too.
It's true.
He lost the rule.
He lost her shitty even
lose to mark them up.
He lost to a shitty rule.
The rule
separate his clavicle or setting up
that fucking dumpy did him and animal.
Um,
I don't know.
He separated his fucking elbow.
Driving into the ward was brutal.
That was brutal.
Fucking a total dominant performance.
You can never call that a loss.
And I don't give a fuck what
planet you're on the job.
We haven't seen John
Lewis never lost a DJ.
We had seen John get there,
was so close,
like a fight with Ian Mccall.
That's why you're not my number one.
That's good.
That's a good argument.
Not really.
It's a good argument.
I think John's the best,
but Dj's definitely have
their djs a fucking machines.
So djs three here's my question.
If so,
Hutto beats him.
Is he like the best
combat sport athlete ever?
Who the fuck to do our
work to do for sure,
but if you have to defend it,
if he can beat the best guy ever.
Is it a styles?
I mean like arguably if you're looking
at someone who's an Olympic gold medalist
and then becomes a world
champion in the UFC,
that's one of the great,
that's a,
that's a massive resume.
Like as far as like
accomplishments on paper,
the only thing that comes close is
Allister winning the k one Grand Prix.
If he won the UFC title,
if asked,
or one that k one Grand Prix,
he won strike for us.
He was the Strikeforce
heavyweight champion.
He was a dream every way champion and
like arguably in MMA Allister's one of,
if not the most,
one of the most decorated guys in all
sports by four k one Grand Prix is the
pinnacle,
the pinnacle of men heavyweight
kickbox is so if so,
Hutto wins a gold fucking medal in the
Olympic Games and then goes on to when
UFC goal.
He's right up there with one of the
most accomplished mixed martial arts.
Happy.
Definitely could be.
And they should be marketing
the fucking to him.
To Mexico.
Oh yeah.
Cause I know fucking better
be to second all the money.
It's fucking stop it.
It's hard.
Why is it hard to sell the flyweights
and why is it hard to sell your weight
class?
I don't know.
People are like Ron does.
She's one 35 small isn't,
it's bigger than that.
When she makes more money,
he's one 25 one 2030 pieces smaller.
The problem didn't even
know what weight you fight.
That's why me and Rhonda will never
fight this cause she weighs more than me.
This is a,
it's a strange,
it's a strange phenomenon because in
boxing it's the same thing in boxing.
You get plucked a chuck Alito.
Nobody.
Yeah,
chocolate Taco.
The fuckers.
He's not bitches
don't,
it never really caught,
he was just a little too small.
They're too small.
Bad motherfucker.
He not just don't buy into it.
Some stang man and he was in his prime.
No needle Donaire can crack.
Is it because you,
you want that.
When you think of fighters,
think of like heroes.
You know what I'm saying?
You want to got to be able
to be one of the APPS.
You want to get to be big.
Yeah,
because people look at
you and they're like,
Ian Mccall,
he will rip your Dick off.
Yeah,
you you've ripped her fucking face stuff.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
in the real world,
but the problem is when
people are watching this shit,
everybody thinks that they can kick
ass when they watch this stuff.
It's one of Chris' Kamozi Cho rigs.
She'll raise those up.
Just need to and the damn thing.
Forgive author doesn't give a fuck.
I'll tell you,
you want to talk about a world
beater in the gym.
I've heard stories about Joe rigs back
when rich Franklin was a champion of,
people were saying if Joe rigs
could fight in the octagon,
the way he spar sometimes,
like he catches these rhythms where you
mean he got it back then especially he's
had rough career.
You know,
he's been a lot of fights
and he's had a long,
long time up inside the octagon
and other organizations,
he's been around.
Joe Rugs is a fucking real veteran.
Be 300 pounds.
Yes.
Yeah.
But when he was on fire,
like when he was at his best,
there were saying he was like
hell on wheels in the gym.
Yeah,
I've heard though like if he
could just get it together,
he's a fucking world champion.
Do Chris Kamozi he's a motherfucker
tough as shit in the Denver scene.
He was like the guy coming up,
he was like the man like the journeyman
and I never trained with them and he was
a south bone.
We couldn't find any south falls when
I was getting ready to fight cro cop.
So they bring Kamozi
in the nicest guy ever.
And his coach goes,
hey listen man,
you're a lot picking and Chris.
But he moves and you need a south pole.
So your coach college remember him down.
But he has a fight his
first UFC fight and he,
I think he's fighting Australia on like
a two week notice and they go make sure
you don't hurt him.
I've never heard anyone really in my life.
I'm like,
yeah,
no problem man.
For whatever reason
we're 30 seconds into it.
I go to throw a hook and
he like charges into it.
Break his nose literally.
So his first UFC fight had broken nose.
I don't know if he won but he
went through I think a decision.
He's a tough mother fucker man.
He's very tough.
That's a hard thing in camp,
right?
How hard is it for guys like you where
you have to work with lighter guys or
guys like you who have to
work with heavier guys?
Like we always say that the Jujitsu
guys that have the best technique or the
guys who are the smaller guys,
it's
Eddie.
Eddie style is your style was based a
lot on when you didn't lift weights?
Yes.
Based on weakness.
But you're thinking about
guys like Barrett Yoshida.
You think about heuler like the smaller
guys are known to have like this razor
razors,
the Mendez brothers razor sharp technique.
Right.
And you know,
those guys have to,
if you're a trained for an MMA fight,
how often did you have to spar
guys are like way heavier than you.
Oh,
we've been,
I've been manicured for so long that it's,
it's uh,
it's been a while to get
anything out of it though.
You don't when you're going to,
whether it was a big guy,
you're so smart.
When you're saying by manicured me,
like they,
they take care of your camp
much more efficiently than that.
We have so many because it's me and Carla.
Right.
As far as under one roof,
calling her dramas,
you know,
he was Tito's coach and
around forever and forever.
We are respected.
Yeah.
And then Jason House,
my agent always has guys in the gym.
There's just tons of small guys,
small guys.
We have 50 people that,
that,
you know,
can fight amateur level,
the pro and they're all under one 50.
That's the advantage of just
the advantage that we have.
You know what the in his camp,
it's an advantage.
Everyone's camp.
The small guys are everywhere.
I hate,
you know,
small guys,
right guys?
It's filled.
It's willing to fight MMA,
MMA,
boxing we were talking
about earlier but you know,
we want to watch bigger guys.
I think maybe we want to watch bigger
guys cause it's bigger guys hit harder and
bigger guys get knocked out easier and
little guys just hard to knock out little
guys because in Jujitsu we'd rather watch
the little guys because it's literally
gotten wore.
The little guys can choke out.
They could uh,
they're,
they're generally more technical and
you see more submissions with the little
guys or big guys.
You see a bunch of dudes just holding
and shit cause you don't really ask will
that like,
okay look,
how about when Demetrius mighty mouse
Johnson knocked out Benevidez with one
punch?
I think if we saw that more often,
I think it little guys,
I don't think it still works.
I think of little guys got knocked out
easier than big guys are more than big
guys.
We would like to learn.
I don't think so.
It's just not fair to him.
It's the pure mass like even when's
the last time you saw a small gun?
A porno even in everything.
Think about it.
Even in Pornos,
they're fucking big dude's got it.
This is what I'm thinking smaller with
regular Dick so that they lick the dick
look bigger than the
guy with the big boys.
Psychologically,
if you watch someone and even if he
beats up someone who's smaller than you,
if you can say in your head,
even if you're wrong,
couldn't do that to me,
then you're not as impressed.
Yes.
It's like when you watch rumble,
put someone in orbit.
It's nothing.
Can you see rumble hit people and
put them in orbit and you just go,
oh fuck,
I got to get out of this room.
It's a totally different straight
appeal because he's so fucking powerful.
Two Oh five that you like,
well that would definitely work on me.
They go one 25 I weighs less
than my girlfriend and say,
hey little guy.
Is there a one 25 or that
it has had econ or hands.
Is there anybody like crop Linacre.
Dot.
Oh my God.
And liquors a murder.
He drops the best five guys card if he
finds like that fall below the division
of,
cause I've been boxing,
uh,
Chiquita Gonzalez.
Remember Remembering Chiquita against
Mike Michael Carb Hall back in the day.
Who matches?
Those guys were 115 pounds.
Yeah,
but you know,
we're throwing bombs.
That was,
that was also like on TV.
They put them on like regular TV,
like ABC Wide World of sports.
It was paper,
but to build them up,
didn't carbo fight on all that stuff.
Did he find on TV?
They used to do a lot more
of that back then for sure.
They're going back to the hall.
Also had a huge following.
You know,
he was a Phoenix Guy,
right?
Didn't he have a gigantic
following and Phoenix.
Phoenix.
It's weird.
I Wa Kamala was a Chicano.
Well,
think about a man named Macchio
Manny back through big fights,
man.
That's true.
Manny pack.
Y'all fights at 47 yeah.
Right.
But he started his career
eight weight classes,
lower 18 he was like a fly with,
you're not going to seep out something.
I want to see what your way we just need,
dude,
we need to come in.
You know Haute Josie,
all those small guy.
I mean considering he'd
knocked the fuck out of people.
That's what people want to see.
You still don't get respect though.
I'm
a fucking,
I lose it nine years
and I have to sell him.
That's just the way the world in America.
The memorial,
the wacky dude.
It don't make any sense.
Well there's a lot more
to being a star then.
Just just knocking people
out and just winning.
Connor's got it all.
He's not,
he's winning.
He's knocking everybody out with
one punch and he wears suits.
He's got the fucking crazy hippy shit.
Crunk for Donna cause it's
found out crack Joe rigs.
Oh,
nobody can take that.
Oh my God,
she's good jam.
Kamozi with the crushing dude.
He questioned and out of the UFC too.
Damn.
That was a brutal does that.
That was like,
who did Ben Saunders do
that to remember that back?
God that was was either,
Ben's was even more brutal because it was
all blocked it all with this phase and
have yet,
and it had an actual Thai clinch.
Yeah.
I just wasn't just covering up.
He was just getting the,
Julian was a real tough marine.
I remember I think,
I think he was in the military,
but do it was tough as fuck and just
ate those shots that like yesterday that
dude,
it was fucking tough.
And that was one of the
things I was going to say,
man,
if it wasn't for like in
your last fight with uh,
um,
what's his name?
Uh,
liquor when Blair could
didn't make weight.
Dude,
you took some fucking shots in that fight
that the guys that are not as tough as
you.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like as a friend,
that was a hard one to watch because like
in the second round I think is when he
hit you with some fucking
vicious body shots.
He hit you with some really hard bombs.
What does the second or the third have?
I don't know.
There was a moment in that
fight where I was like,
oh Jesus,
how long ago was getting and he ray
rock me in the third because it was the
third third.
How hard is that mother
fucker hit really hard.
Like creepy hard,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know if it's,
my coach has its cause you know,
it's cause I died.
Um,
but same as like me and like my other
training partner and coach Oromia Dante,
he died getting shot.
So we both kind of weird tolerance
to pain and not get knocked out.
And uh hmm.
Wait a minute.
I just remember going like,
Holy Shit Man.
Like everything that wall
don't come after me,
please.
I'm Francisco.
Avera does society stand God Bang with
him and he's another dude I really like.
That's my good friend.
He's a friend.
I loved that dude and I think he
got a raw deal in the arrive here.
The referee should stop
that when the IPO cap.
And it was obvious I poke,
you know,
but he,
I'd never thought he would do that.
I thought he would move and use
his skills and light him up.
I don't know,
man.
Maybe he just got hit and he
just wanted to hit him back.
Who knows when you train us,
just go in the gym.
All of a sudden he starts
kicking and you're like,
what the fuck?
He has a sick,
diverse,
super technical open,
beautiful hip rotation and everything
on all kinds of expand kicks,
jump,
kicks.
Wow.
And then all of a sudden you crack them.
He's just fucking plants there.
And once you get punched in the face like,
Oh man,
I love watching that do fight.
But I felt like,
man,
he got a raw deal in the favor
fight,
you know?
Uh,
and then they to stand
right in front of Leonard,
go like that and just
throw down his next fight.
Like this is crazy.
I wonder if he just thought
that he could get him.
I think he did.
Yeah.
I,
I think that that's what it came down to.
Kind of spooky.
He Spooky.
Spooky.
That was my favorite fight on this card.
Yeah.
Cody verse Linda Curt.
That's a fucking,
Dan gave that shit away from us.
Fuck.
That mosquito said not on
my watch and he do shit.
He seems to be just as heavy handed at
one 35 which made this fight so far.
Great match though.
Oh yeah.
Illinois.
This guy beat half a Mendez.
Yeah.
Although like fine advantage
or something like that,
but still just to even tie half monster,
half amended from tapping you.
It's cute.
Like you survived.
It's cool.
But I don't see someone
get punched in the face,
but that was in the g and he's,
you know,
so I don't know if all is Jiu
Jitsu is going to translate to MMA.
We're going to see,
you know,
but a fucking poor Joe rigs,
man.
I hate seeing that.
Well man,
you know what?
Kamasi did what he wanted to do and
rigs didn't get a chance to do it.
Like he's,
his arm is fucked up,
man.
He's holding his arm.
Think about how many needs he
took that he blocked on that arm.
What are the odds that arm is broken?
Pretty High,
right?
I would say 85%.
26 guys hit with some bombs there.
Yeah,
there was some bombs.
I hate seeing those,
that it's a rough sport.
My man is definitely not.
I'll just tell you to ask you.
How's your shoulder brother?
That's fucked up.
Is it?
Uh,
I probably shouldn't say anything
but arm pop it again this week.
How long were you out for you?
What does that mean?
I had my bet I had
surgery eight months ago.
I had a fully torn bicep tendon to labral
tears and a fully torn rotator cuff.
So they redid the whole thing.
Um,
Carla actually had her lay room done a
week before me and the doctor's like,
Oh yeah,
we'll have it done.
Just like her same shit.
And after,
uh,
I remember I'm sitting there and he
called me a couple of days later.
He's like,
so how are you doing?
I'm like,
well dude,
did you fucking tap dance on my shoulder?
Like what the fuck?
And he didn't,
he told me everything
he had to do and then,
uh,
I had stem cell put in it.
Thank you.
Thank you doctor.
Thermo's and,
uh,
it's,
it's really fucking strong.
My arm is strong,
but all the sudden I'll be moving
and I'll throw it and it'll just,
just boom.
I'm like fucking,
that'll hurt and you know,
it won't feel good and I'll
kind of just keep shadowboxing.
Well it's been eight months.
You know,
I throw a punch there the day doing like
a movement drills around this ball and
it just pop and I just fell
to the ground holding it pops.
Like get it like came out of socket.
Like none of that.
I just,
I felt the pop somewhere in,
in my bicep to middle of my arm region.
Did you get it checked out yet?
Yeah.
And they're there.
They can't feel it.
It has no form,
no bruising,
no MRI.
I mean,
not yet.
They're going to,
they're going to wait and see.
But I fractured and dislocated
this elbow wrestling.
I've had three surgeries
on this hand to breaks.
I've had a bad infection in his arm.
Uh,
I got two bulging discs.
Well,
so this time
of volume two bulging disks.
Yeah.
This side of my body is kind of
fucked up so that they did that.
Totally.
Probably related the bulging
disc in your neck then?
Yeah.
Three,
four,
four or five.
Yeah,
that's right where the ULNA
nerve was it like for me,
my issues with my neck went
all the way down to my fingers.
Do you get any numbing in your fingers?
Yeah.
Hey Tom.
I see doctors.
I see.
Gotcha.
But uh,
yeah,
not now.
Like I told my mom a fucking month ago,
she's like,
are you going to keep doing this?
I'm like,
no,
I,
yes,
I'm back eating.
Well,
is that his girl?
I don't know.
That might be his mom.
His sister,
his sister.
Not to,
he's young as fuck.
That's his mom.
He could be,
what a handsome fella.
He needs a new haircut.
He really need,
why does that,
does that?
It's a white young dawn.
If he's really a male model,
he,
he would have a different haircut.
That community is so connected,
like everybody into MMA knows,
okay,
say sage loss and everyone's
making fun of them now.
You know what I mean?
That's like the general
consensus consensus.
Fuck.
You know,
it's crazy.
They can never
make fun of anyone anyways.
I didn't make fun of them.
I thought I signed him up.
I didn't think he tab quick.
I thought that guy put
a good choke on them.
I tell people with their
arm like that all the time,
it's like,
I don't think it was a quick tap.
It was legit.
That guy had a good squeeze
on his hate comes from,
he got so much hype man,
you got paid so much more than other vets.
So other fighters kinda
like what the fuck man,
but think if you're him,
if you're him you're like,
dude,
I didn't ask her this.
Dana was like,
here's your contract.
It's like fun again.
People were really concerned.
So hands on.
People really concerned that the
other fighters or or like jealous.
I don't think people are,
the fighters are fighters put that out.
Like you're a boy,
Tony Ferguson,
right?
Like when the fires put
out then the fans go,
yeah,
fuck that guy.
Yeah.
It's a natural reaction when
someone's that beautiful.
They have so many advantages.
Nice.
A guy who's got,
I mean nine to respect,
but Brian Barbarina his body
on look nothing like that.
Regular Athlete's body.
So with a regular guy,
regular athletes,
Ferguson
whooped his ass,
he whipped his ass and you know,
they were all telling me after the fight,
I said,
does he,
does he top guys like that all the time?
They're like,
yeah,
he squeezes ridiculous.
They say here's a six squeeze.
Yeah you could tab.
And I was telling me he gets guys in
that position and just taps everybody.
He apparently has this
insane head and arm closure.
You know some guys get that and
some guys just have that nasty,
he wasn't trying to pass or like
improve his body position on that choke.
When you see that and you
stay in like sub a positions,
you don't get the ultimate squeeze
but you do control their body.
That's when you know a
guy knows what he's doing.
If he's got to get all the way side
control and lay on his stomach and start
with you,
you,
you gotta,
you gotta do all that to,
to squeeze that in,
to get a tap out of that.
To me,
that's amateur.
What he did that was pro.
Yeah,
he stayed on the mount.
He's like,
and he stayed in half guard.
He didn't even try to pass it.
I'm gonna stay right here
in Tampa and the sage kid,
he really did legitimately 100% have strep
throat and he was in the hospital two
days before that fight.
So just imagine antibiotic
and the antibiotic,
but just imagine having strep throat and
having someone clamp down in your neck.
I mean,
you're already inflamed and a quick tap.
100% yeah.
And you know what man?
He's a kid.
He's 19 years old.
He's 19 years old and he's,
he's in there kicking ass.
And how much policies coming his way,
even measurable jazz
off to the Bible though.
He doesn't touch
10 years.
Fucking laugh.
Come on.
Come on out,
brother.
Yeah,
I really can't think of that.
Tony Ferguson versus mega Madoff.
That's fucking monster straight.
What I said when I did the countdown show,
I said this easily could be
a world championship fight.
Easy one of these guys easily either.
Either guy can be the champion,
either graph can be the challenger.
This is a legit world championship.
Caliber fighter factors,
uh,
help,
the beeps body,
whether it's healthy,
how's that?
How's he going to perform?
Taking all this time off and
Tony's a motherfucker to fight.
Tony.
Tony's hard to manhandle like mega
men office used to manhandle them
and Tony Striking has
gotten so goddamn good.
All your met off.
But if he gets a hold of Tony,
Tony's going for a ride,
but that's not going to face.
Tony wrestled in college.
I train,
he's all,
he's all fuck.
When it comes to wrestling,
you have a,
uh,
a perfect symmetrical wrestler who does
everything correct over and over and
over and over again.
All the guns.
All of a sudden you have Tony
who has great fucking basics,
but he's also hitting that wild ass
Granby roll from every position.
I wrestled like that guy
and it was fucking boom,
boom,
boom.
So you know what wheels
can catch on faster.
I think it's going to be,
cause they all filed
cards number come out.
I would love to do is control.
He gets you on top of,
he beats the fuck out of
you and holds you in place.
But toys so dynamic.
I don't know if he's gonna be able to
hold him down the way he's be able to hold
other people down and I'd be in trouble.
And you can see guys,
when they fight Habib where they break,
you can see where they're just like,
this motherfucker's still chose.
Yes.
Able to lead the fight to see
him when he beat those angles.
I'll beat the fuck out
all the rabid dog though.
A,
granted it was a few years,
he gets a hold of you.
You're going for a ride.
He's got the best
grappling in the division.
Do you know about his dad?
Yeah,
I heard that serious fucking sambo
cause long article about how awesome his
fucking dad isn't.
Samely isn't just,
I was like,
I fucking knew.
I knew I liked these guys.
Technical is fuck everything's perfect.
All his position.
But he's had so many injuries.
Yeah,
horrible injuries too.
It's horrible.
Like ACL,
MCL,
he's
blown his knees.
He blew his back out.
That changes everything
when he got back from that.
Like your shot,
especially when you fight a guy like Tony.
Right?
Because in football,
you know when you come
back from one knee surgery,
you may never be the same if you're
a running back or a quarterback that
scrambles.
That's what happens to all the
quarterbacks that scramble.
They're doing great in
college and they survive.
But as soon as they get
hurt in the pro game,
man,
now they got to stay in the pocket there.
Their knees are shot and that's
where they fucked [inaudible].
Way more demanding than that.
Especially when you're avoiding things.
So we're throwing head
kicks your way or treat,
you're trying to stuff it take down
your sprawling and trying to turn while
someone's driving towards you.
That's why a few of the
body that's prone to injury,
especially we've had,
you know,
if you've wrestled your whole life and
it starts to build up like it came,
man,
the motherfucking stay healthy for not,
that's exactly what was going to say,
but I think number Grumet off,
it's not a coincidence.
They're all in the same camp,
you know,
and it's also not a coincidence.
They have at least the three champions
out of that fucking gym and to current,
I mean the j Aka is a monster house.
It's a monster house,
but they're also getting guys with
a lot of miles on like dcs miles.
Kane has some motherfucking miles.
Naga Madoff has crazy miles.
[inaudible] got a nice
sweet odometer though,
Baby.
We'll take him off.
He's the new,
Tessa is a Tesla and Prius,
but he's not a,
he's like,
he's the newest thing.
He's like a dope mach one
Mustang and he came back on top.
Well,
I think that a guy like him is the future,
you know,
especially like he's in that division.
He's so unusual because he's a wrestler.
He's got really good Jujitsu,
his top games,
insane.
He's tall,
he kicks Harvey.
He's got a good balance between
being strong and being long.
Like some long guys.
They just not as strong.
Anderson was always a long guy,
but not a strong guy.
You know what I mean?
Like Anderson's never man held the handle
anybody the way Rockhold can manhandle
you will see what he did to Yaddo the,
even when he gets them on the ground,
those long guys are strong like that.
Jon Jones is.
People say how long he is.
You get in the clinch with him
and I've wrestled with John.
It's like,
what the flip plan is this from
the fuck you could totally see.
You could totally say you're saying when
when DC was fighting him and he took DC
down that first round,
DC was like,
oh,
these faces like,
oh fuck.
So I'm like,
Huh?
He's like,
fuck,
he's strong as fuck.
He threw me across the room on time.
She's the one that I've hung out with.
John.
Hey,
I haven't hung out with John since
John threw me across the face.
You know me.
I'm the number one fan of John by love.
How everyone's like,
no,
he's changed.
Why?
Because on Instagram he's posting videos
of working out and shit splits by the
narrative Mr Shop and he's the baddest
motherfucker on the planet and he's swole
now.
Good.
Like beating that dude.
Fuck me.
That's all I'm buying.
Yeah.
What was that seven men he was taking?
I really want that.
I don't know.
It's good stuff.
Many magazine coming.
No,
no,
no Bermudez versus Caligiuri.
Ooh,
I see a very good fight.
Caligiuri was a motherfucker in Japan,
man.
A legend.
Yeah.
Remember Bermudez was on
I think a similar fight.
Win Streak.
Well,
Caligiuri has had some tough
fights in MMA period because the,
the first big one he had was with
Melendez and it was back when Zuka had
purchased Strikeforce and
they reinstated elbows.
You remember that?
Oh,
you got fucked up.
Gilbert took it down and it was
the first time that Gilbert there.
Strikeforce career.
Yeah.
I was there.
Ringside.
Was that where it was?
San Diego.
It was the first time,
I think in strike force where they
allowed elbows on the ground because when
Gilbert had been fighting before,
even though he's a wrestler,
he couldn't use elbows on the ground.
They had like a pride,
a similar rule set before the UFC.
Was that San Diego?
San Jose?
I Dunno.
I don't remember.
I watched it on TV.
I'm pretty sure it was awesome.
I mean,
San Diego was it,
do you realize how important
elbows are on the game changer?
And we guys fought their whole career
without elbows and then all of a sudden
they use elbows.
They get more for like a guy like Gilbert,
it's a huge weapon for him
because his wrestling so good.
He's so strong.
He's on toppy smashing it with elbows.
It's way better than punching you.
Right.
And so like it goes from that to,
um,
you know,
he had a,
a couple tough fights
after that and it just,
when you have a,
a beat down like that
Gilbert Melendez fight,
look at junior dos Santos.
Yeah.
Well it's never the same.
Did the,
oh,
he's fighting.
Rothwell did the heavyweight.
Tufts.
I'm fucking fights.
We haven't talked on our last ski
Overeem's train the same camp.
These motherfuckers said now
neither of us are going anywhere.
We're going to treat it the
same camp and fight each other.
Wow.
Hey,
terrible idea of fellas,
but I guess she was
coming at different times.
How do they work that?
How do you gain planet?
How's Greg Jackson and game plan
that you got a game plan to draw?
Yeah.
What do you do?
Do you like each car?
Does each guy have like
one member of the crew?
He takes us as corner guy partners.
How's it work?
Training partners,
especially heavyweights at Jackson.
Oh Shit.
You're all kind of a,
what if they sparred like
every day leading up to it,
whether they sparred to
help each other get sharp,
to fight each other.
It'd be brilliant.
The nerves wouldn't be there as much.
Right,
but who would,
who would say yes to that?
Who would say no to them?
Who would say no to that?
It's over.
He would probably say no
to that over him for sure.
He's a serial killer.
Yeah.
But do you think,
do you think are Lawsky
would say no to that?
Yeah,
he's that Russian fucking assassin.
They're both,
you know,
so prideful.
That's crazy fight.
I thought our last few hating me
forever when we came together.
But no,
he's just kind of client.
He's a great guy.
When they,
if they,
if they trained together like how long
do you think they've trained together?
How many years now?
Shit,
fet put three,
three years.
So they had to have done a lot,
but if anyone's going to leave it's can
be over and cause their Alaska has been
there way longer.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause over and came from the black
zillions or Alaska was there four years
before that.
Lots of user when I was there.
That's right.
And our last back when
they first started working with them,
everybody thought he was done.
I remember this mother fucker was about
to fight for a title before he crazy.
So crazy.
And then what else?
Oh,
and then they're doing a Verdomme
steep bay in Brazil is what I heard.
This fucking show looks so bad.
It looks like it's fake blonde.
A spot.
It really,
really looks like it's fake.
Or you watching better call Saul?
No.
Is it also shit?
What's that on?
It's a,
it's a prequel of breaking bad.
It's breaking bad,
but the story of,
of the lawyer,
I can't get into breaking man.
What was that?
I don't like tweakers.
Weekers meth heads.
Math,
math.
People who do fucking math.
Oh yeah.
That's what the show's about.
Did you meet?
Did you watch breaking bad?
Did you watch all that?
Did you?
No,
I didn't watch the whole
thing and then watch the end.
I didn't want him to breaking bad.
No last couple of seasons and they
want to shit and I can't get into,
I watch one of the first thing for me,
I want the first one and didn't start
watching it for another five years.
I need to show to watch,
but nobody,
it's good.
It's really fucking good.
You're going to get addicted.
I did the same thing.
Watch first esoteric
teachers,
sells trucks,
all upset.
Nothing for me,
man.
Oh Man.
All documentaries.
You know what's a great
documentary that I just passed up.
There was a new release on
Netflix called cartel land,
and I thought,
oh,
that sounds,
come on son.
That's been out forever,
dude.
Have you seen it?
Yes.
Pfuff quite,
oh Lord,
shut down American.
I almost didn't watch it because of
the cartel and that sounded like some B
movie about some frozen.
This isn't a spoiler.
There's a one guy who,
he represents the people.
He's like,
we're not letting these cards.
We're not letting these
cartel people come in,
take our fucking bill.
Just so he all the civilians,
he joins him and he's like,
this dude a mustache.
They leave this mother fucker miked up
and he's going to like give a speech.
He's a guy,
you gotta make a stop.
He goes to the side
piece house and he was,
yeah.
Bueno.
And this bitch,
just such a mouth to second his case,
he comes out,
he's like,
all right,
ready to go.
And they've been shown his wife and kids,
let's edit that shit out.
Hey.
But,
but he's like,
it's the best part of the movie.
Bueno.
Oh boy.
What is he doing?
He's not doing Gandhi Shit.
He's telling everybody.
Everybody,
we all need machine guns.
We're going to drive the
cartel out of our city.
So they decided to all fucking,
they got strapped all the cowboy.
Is this a spoiler alert?
No,
no,
no.
This is the beginning.
It's a long dude.
There's a lot of shit that happened
to bind to get all,
you know
he's fighting cartels.
I'm just saying.
He had a side piece they show his
wife would get the whole time.
I watched this thing.
I want to watch this.
The basis of it shit happens.
Did you see it?
Yes,
it did.
You did.
I just,
I don't want to ruin
it for him completely.
This is the,
when you're just,
I'm,
it's about a guy.
It's about a guy.
Somebody in the middle for me who gets
his tax free joke at the beginning,
the end,
the hero hooks up with this site
piece hit the edge of the seats.
Mike Stars by Eddie Bravo.
How many stars?
Oh Shit.
One of the greatest documentaries.
That's all
I give it a four out of five.
Got,
damn.
You're crunk right now.
The guy that loved the hoist.
Great.
Yeah.
Let's pick it.
That was just about
the
data and Kimbo.
What was that?
Oh,
that was a,
that was like they should have called
it a special street match or something.
That's a strong no for me.
You said,
okay,
we're going to show this for
pure entertainment value.
Everyone last night,
MMA,
it's just two dudes.
Just Bro.
I say you do.
I think you put Datta and Kimbo and let
Justin wren fight both at the same time.
If they're going to do shit shows,
let's get real.
I don't think they thought that
was going to be as bad as it was.
No,
they thought Kim was get
knocked down on the first round.
I don't think anybody
anticipated those guys.
Would gas like that,
like that was the worst
gassing and the history of gas.
If you train some adjustments,
pygmies they can be pretty bad in Denver.
A little bit of a excuse because they
were fighting and they have better
technique at least.
Yeah.
There were there to really high level.
These were all over the place,
swung some bombs,
but he just had a real hero in the early
parts of the round before Kimbo took
him down.
He just doesn't have enough
gas Bermudez guys back here.
He just doesn't have any gas,
you know?
I mean,
who knows how he's really training.
let's be honest that he might like it.
He's just not very good.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
that's never been what he's doing,
right?
He's been doing these street fights.
That's what he's been doing,
man.
Get your paper,
Doug.
I mean,
I kind of get that he wants to fight and
fight legitimate and I kind of get that
he's got to take that paycheck,
but I just wish he had like a real
strength and conditioning coach or a real
trainer come down to 5,000 by hiring
this real strength conditioning coach.
She didn't get that haircut.
You don't get that warrior
here talking about him.
He got that.
He made some money.
I'm sure he made some money.
That's all he cares about.
I think if you could find the backyard
just same amount of amount of money.
He's doing it.
I just wonder,
you know,
you take a guy like that and
you bring them to a legit place.
How much did you make?
I don't know.
I kind of think you made
some good money though.
But if you took a guy like that and you
brought him to a Greg Jackson is not
going to be a fun story.
Mark Henry,
you don't think so?
No.
It's fucking wrecked.
Maybe just changes his attitude.
He gets ate up plates,
Car Yashi.
That motherfucker gets toward the fuck.
Yeah,
but maybe he learns,
maybe learns how to fight.
We're not talking about him going in
there and sparring with an in Prime Shane
Carwyn and getting fucking night.
I paid good money for that.
Are you talking about the
Brenden's shop program ready?
Shock course.
Like this dude,
he'll,
he'll do a series.
Got Him in a cradle.
Cm punk has done and he'll,
he'll finally realize that this
isn't a fucking good idea.
This is fucking cow
serious.
He's on top here.
Associate got a vet lane.
He was,
he was given Dennis Bermudez a
little bit of a need of the back.
I don't know.
How would you ever got some good passing?
He's got good if he gets,
if he gets on top,
he has very sad time at a pro's pro does.
Um,
is it a lot?
You allowed to knee in the back,
like how's that work?
Fine.
Yeah,
the sides.
You can yes side.
You can't just not directly on the spine.
Hard to take down this guy.
It's hard.
Oh motherfucker.
So you can hit a person like right.
Get him out of his shoulder,
right Diane,
you can hit them right next to the spine
with your knees and when someone's on
the ground,
great.
Good.
You need them right next to
that 100% on him right there.
He could flip them over easy.
When I'm going to take that,
let it go.
He's going to keep scrambling.
Good.
Lucky and premium goes down.
Okay.
She got 100% [inaudible].
Damn.
You pray for those positions right there.
Bam,
pyre.
Fangs.
I say,
where do you get that?
Pretty bad ass.
Fancy dishes like,
but some referees of warn you,
if you get too close to the spine,
we can't go 12 to six on the spine.
You can't go 12 to six anywhere.
Even on the thighs.
They warn you about that.
But it's weird to that.
His mission,
because you can,
if you're on the bottom like guard.
Yes,
but it's not because it's going six to 12.
Because you're from the bottom.
This motion instead of this one.
It's so fucking stupid.
It's like if you jerk off knuckles up,
is it really jerking off?
Who does not in my book,
who's jerking off like
that and I've tried it.
It's very rare when you're
trying to live it up.
I guess you'd do it.
Damn.
Couch series.
Relentless was takedowns her.
Yeah,
but not during,
uh,
during the actual prospect climax.
How hard is Bermuda?
There's only one way.
That's why our hands are shaped this way.
Can you imagine during the climax part,
you're going like,
this matches do it.
The only way to get you something,
Tom,
you had to hit it,
smack it,
right?
You've seen the fucking be
knee pain elimination stuff,
right?
Yeah.
So people love pain.
I don't like pain at all.
No fucking touch me.
I don't understand that.
Any facet tap tattoos,
I suck at that.
You know like you meet people
that are like in the pain.
There's some people that
like to get suspended.
You receive that shit.
They put hooks in their
bag hanging like fish.
Do you think that maybe they
feel painted a different way?
Like maybe what you feel what they feel
is different releases and different
endorphins?
I've always wondered that because
you know people talk about like pain
tolerance,
like oh this guy's got a really high pain
tolerance like and she's got a really
high power.
You know,
he loves pain.
What are they feeling or we assume,
I assume that when someone
does something to you,
it feels the same as it is to me,
but it's clearly different.
There's no way.
There's no way or other ones.
Why do girls like getting spanked?
How come some girls,
that's a dominant thing.
I'll write.
Some girls love it.
That's leftover caveman,
right?
They love it.
They like to get spanked,
spank,
choke.
Thanks.
50 shades of grey hair.
That's a little hair pull.
Generally good spit a little bit.
They like it a little bit.
That's leftover kids speak,
but let's be real about this shift.
Girl spanks you.
It's going to be a fucking real problem.
[inaudible] she's asking
you to spank her up.
She starts spanking you that way.
You'd be like,
Hey,
hey.
what the fuck are you doing?
No,
no,
no.
My reaction by reaction trading.
Oh No,
no,
no.
There's not going to be any of that.
Like right away.
They're
really hot.
I'll put on some stockings and shit,
whatever they want.
It's very,
it's very important to,
you know,
nip that right on the boat
stockings and fucking shoot.
Hit the high heels on
and shit and colognes.
A hell drain is a hell of a drug.
How about the girls that liked to scratch?
Holy Shit.
Stop.
That is marking
you.
Yes.
Ah,
I think that that's like bottom.
Yeah,
that's right.
He's our fucking let everybody
know that she fucked you.
You know to mark her territory
scratching you leave marks on you.
Did you ever give Hickey's?
Oh yeah.
High School.
Everybody gave Hickey's in high school.
You come to school.
Wow.
Who's got a great idea?
If you think about it goes bro,
please give Hickey's.
It's gone though,
right?
When's the last time?
So some of the Hickey.
Yeah.
That's kind of what want will
do that shit in Rose Rose.
I'm going to get in
fucking trouble for this.
Why would I do this?
Yeah.
Why you bruised up my neck?
I guess it's embarrassing now.
Yo.
Fuck how a jury trying to spin a lot of
work trying to get them to the ground
man.
Yeah,
he's exhausted.
He's a big dude to that though.
That's
so hard to take that cow.
Jerry gets Tko.
He looks very tired here.
I'll tell you that.
You got to wonder also with a guy like
how Agiri how old is he now between the
two of them?
Don't they have like 60 2070
fights or something like that?
He's only 29 no,
no.
He's arrogant.
He's 44 Jamie,
find out how old cow Agiri
is in fighting years.
He's 66 he's,
yeah,
he's older.
He can't tell.
Let me guess before he tell me.
35 30 [inaudible] 39 okay.
Drum roll please.
35373630930 six days.
He,
there are 609 claims.
You can't tell Asians.
It's black guys.
You cannot tell.
It's like that.
Jimmy Hendrix,
what is it?
Oh you,
so between 36 and 39 I was off.
Boom.
You were in the wheel.
Whatever.
39 he'd been fighting for a long time.
A long time.
It's hard,
man.
A few of those brutal Kaos like this
guy has experienced like especially the
Melendez fight.
How many other times does he k Aod,
who wins a fight like this?
If it goes like this,
all three rounds.
A dude cow Jerry.
He wins because he's pressing coercive.
He's,
he's,
yeah,
it or is that aggressive?
Depends on the judge.
And he's can't fucked up here.
He's getting the fucking shit
up elbowed out of him here.
Well,
you know,
so,
so we didn't consider a takedown.
Bermudez was on his hip getting up
some of the fucking idiot Ras to do.
They have a Bermudez is
controlling him here.
I agree.
Munis is on top and he's
laying strikes and coward your,
you're literally can't do shit shot.
He's in the shot.
Yeah,
but it does no good.
But this is just an easy,
he's getting fucked up,
but he's going into them.
But you can control guys.
College Erie.
Is that making that happen?
Yes,
but he's stuck.
Look,
a Bermudez is controlling
that right arm with that rap.
Bermuda says rescue shelter,
aggressive,
beating the fuck out of him.
Here I,
I'm definitely giving these exchanges
right here to permutate how would series
only holding on and it
ain't work and it gets back.
Yep.
And then he's about to get fucked up.
Wait for that.
Tko Son.
See I get that you're saying that
cow would juries moving forward.
But the way Dennis was countering was
so much more powerful than what cow was.
I agree with you.
I'm saying on the first one,
devil's advocate.
That's,
that's why I brought it up.
Pushing him.
He's getting fucked up the first round.
Who you give that to
the first round couch,
even though he didn't get
the successful take down.
I see it as,
yeah,
he's pushing forward.
It's not effective and the
reason he's pushing forward,
he doesn't want nothing.
None of the standup,
but he,
even when he's pushing forward though,
he was underneath,
he was underneath the leg.
He had his arm tied up like this.
Like see how Bermuda's loves to tie that,
that wrist up on inspiring
Sanderson's all Ryan Parson,
he is just beating the
shit out of him here.
I mean there's a number
of unanswered shots.
Oh,
twister.
That'd be sick.
That's not going to happen.
What I'm trying to go,
he wants to,
what does he do?
He just wants to take the back.
He's got his bags on a
flat amount per municipal.
Awesome.
How would you beat gummy or now go
me beat him in a PR and provide,
right.
That's how that was soccer.
I do soccer.
I,
yeah,
I what I'm thinking of
how you got those screaming
at me screaming at him.
Right.
Parsons.
It's,
he's all about control and
him and Pat Carnes smart.
That's all he does spend.
Well,
especially from those positions you see
like as he's moving in for that shot,
controlling that right wrist,
he was able to land so many hard shots.
Just so much control how many hard
elbows that he land from that position.
It had to be like 10 right?
At least at least 10 hard ones.
So when you think about that,
like just the impact of that
as he goes back to his round,
he's definitely diminished
from that big time.
It was a bad scene.
Hey,
we'd have whatever man.
Go in there,
brother.
No,
no,
I'm good.
You know what?
I'll take one fucking baby.
Well,
I have a big celebration to celebrate.
It's as a celebration bitches
like Jamie can drink.
Let me ask you this,
Joe.
If you're,
if you're a cowboy Hornimann and
the fights five or five rounds,
you know what I'm saying,
Joe?
The fights five rounds,
you're not going to have a
game plan for five rounds,
right?
You're going to say that the first round,
give it hell,
man.
Then after that it's whatever.
I would assume they would try to do
that because that's where cowboys had
problems in the past.
Guys jump on him and he's taking the
fight on short doughnut cowboy given into
rhythm cause he's gonna fuck you up.
You blitz ass.
How many weeks it Olivera
have to prepare weeks.
He just fought not too long ago though.
Oh well there you go.
That could be,
that could be still five round fight.
You don't give a fuck who you is
still going on Caligiuri and Nigga,
this Bermudez is attacking now.
Can I get one of the other ones?
Yeah Dude.
How bad ass was at Jeremy's Guinness.
Melcher I liked that stuff
relating to get us your,
that's a grown ass man drink.
I'm not ready for it even
though I'm a dad now.
This is probably bad for
my low carbohydrate diet.
Fuck.
Probably not supposed to drink these.
How's that work here?
I'll have one.
Hey Bro,
can I have your drink beer?
How long is that going to last?
I have a p I have a penis
so I can trying to do it.
I'm not just going to live on days,
right.
Try to do it for 60 days.
Sadly,
with my brothers.
How many days are you,
hey,
congratulations on that day.
It's going to cluck.
Every day gets better and better.
Dude.
Hopefully better and better.
Hopefully
I can do it.
You can do it.
That's your creation.
That's,
that's kind of,
that's the most important
thing that we'll watch.
16 and pregnant.
If those fucking morons can do it,
I'll be fine.
Well,
well,
it's not hard.
Don't let those be your role model.
That's the standard.
You can read books side of it.
Got Mother-in-law.
That's,
that's huge.
That's that Latin families.
Huge.
But it's think of,
think of it.
It's only hard for two years.
Two and a half years after
that and talked to him like,
no,
listen,
that's not a long time.
Even even then,
it's awesome.
Trust me,
I can't wait.
It's love kids,
before they become all,
I want to be like Sean camp man,
just a ton of kids and
make you a better mom.
It makes you a better person.
It really does.
Yeah.
I'm open.
It chills me out.
I can't relax with the,
it shouldn't say it
makes you better person,
but it makes a lot of people better
person because they'd become way more
considerate and they start looking at the
world differently cause you kind of re
we all know intellectually what it's like.
You have a baby,
the baby comes person and there it goes,
but when you actually see it happen,
then you start to piece
it together and go,
okay,
this everything this person is really
is because of all the interactions that
he's experienced while I've been his dad
and that's what you're going to start
doing.
And then you use it just,
and you're a great guy already,
man.
It's gonna.
It's going to make you even more awesome,
I guarantee you.
Yeah,
I'm excited.
you're going to be great at this man.
You're going to be,
you're going to love it.
I know I can't wait.
I love it when you live,
we need to live your life
now all of a sudden there's someone
that you'll die for and you'll kill for.
You know,
it's different.
It's all of a sudden you're not
number one.
No more kids.
I'm rolling.
Yup.
This is worth more to you than you are.
That's it.
Now you're,
that changes your life.
Now all of a sudden you're number two.
You got a number one
that you got to protect,
you know,
and it really changes it.
It changes your,
your,
your feeling of compassion too.
He just said,
you have more compassion
for people because you see
people that are grown up and
he'd go,
oh,
somewhere online.
This fucking dude was a baby and someone
did a terrible job of raising this
fucking kid.
And now here he is,
25 and Tronc and stupid and my face.
And it puts it together to you in
a way that it never did before.
Before I would meet people and I go,
oh,
this guy's an asshole.
The the,
you know,
oh,
she's a bitch.
But now I go,
oh,
those were babies.
This is a baby that just got their
parents growing up the wrong way,
the whole deal.
And then you meet someone who's
a really cool person and you go,
oh,
well you must have,
you know,
you must have had a cool ride.
Yeah.
What was your childhood like?
You always want to know,
like,
where did you grow up?
How did you get through to my,
my girl's family being Latin man,
there's so much love and it's insane.
I feel like my,
you know,
don't get me wrong,
my parents left the shit out of me,
but you know,
yeah.
The Trombleys just different.
Yeah.
Donald Trump kind of track track,
keep love out.
Yeah.
Donald,
it's so stupid.
He wants South Carolina.
Did he?
Of course he did.
Look what he's against.
He's against nothing too.
How crazy numbers Hillary.
Oh,
100% he's like Hillary's
gonna beat Ben Sanders.
What?
Bernie Sanders,
his name just mixed.
Yeah,
no trouble.
Bernie won New Hampshire,
but New Hampshire is the,
you know,
that's like a very small
state in the New England area.
They're very liberal,
doing as liberal in general.
And he's like,
you know,
he's a radical socialist.
He's like,
he's got this socialist,
democratic socialist agenda
that a lot of people like,
hey,
let's try that.
It's better than what
we're dealing with now.
These capitalists cuts that are still
like just looking at the stock market,
just looking at the,
the financial district,
just looking at the way they're moving
numbers around and the fucking Wall
Street crash of 2008 obviously there's
a bunch of criminals are running things
and they're just extracting money from
this goofy abstract system that hardly
anybody understands.
So having a guy like him come along,
a lot of people including me go.
It's probably the best
thing that happened.
So you throw a little
mixed me up in there.
See what the fuck happened
as the Trump curve ball.
You're telling not talking about Trump.
I'm talking about Bernie Sanders.
Yeah,
Bernie Sanders.
Trump just saying it's interesting
to be super interesting.
It's got a complete wild card.
You're telling me those are the
two best America has to offer,
so I don't want to talk bullshit.
Too much going on too much
boy and off real quick.
Another doctor marrow schizos.
He's like going to this protest.
He's like,
hold on,
let me pull up real quick.
What's up girl?
That's the best.
He does it in the must.
Must like Suave Latin guy thing is like
all over the fence.
You know?
He's talking to her.
She talks about running away with it and
I'd be right back.
It's the best we need shale to run for
president because shale would fight any
other president and beat him up.
Pull the pin would be a good fight.
Oh,
would be a real president who
really could be a president.
Stan Brian's dad.
Yes.
He really could do it.
I'd vice president Tim Kennedy for reals.
It's,
it's if can enjoy that.
I see classic case of war
for real.
I'll fucking vote for that.
Heartbeat.
You know her,
honey,
anything Tim does,
I'm on board,
so she sold.
You know the real problem being
a president is nobody can do it.
That's the real problem.
It's a stupid job.
No one can do.
No one should have the job.
It shouldn't exist anymore.
It's antiquated and the only way we're
going to realize that it's just going to
be no one running.
It's going to be like 2030 years from now.
No one's going to run for president.
It's not going to make
a difference at all.
Some homeless guy and the goat,
you know,
real quick documentary.
This is one that I've
watched over and over.
It's really,
really good.
If you say it's the festival freak out.
No,
it's not.
It's not.
But it's really,
really good because especially
for conspiracy theorists type,
it's called how big oil
conquered the world.
It's how it all started back in the mid
18 hundreds how it all started with John
d Rockefeller and you always
hear about the Rockefellers.
All they own everything
on the Rothschild's.
Oh there,
there's the bankers,
they own everything.
But to actually find
out how he was raised,
John Rockefeller and how evil his dad was,
and this is all like,
you know,
public knowledge.
It's fucking amazing how the,
the birth of oil in the United States,
this documentary's called about the birth
of oil and how it came in and infected
all our lives.
And how John Rockefeller monopolize
fucking everything to find it,
dude.
It's,
it's,
it's an incredibly,
and it's free on youtube.
Dude,
I got another one for you and it's
your boy that prescription thugs.
That's good doc.
Some crazy shit.
He's called John Rockefeller.
He Dude,
he controlled big Pharma.
He controlled our educational system.
Everything.
One Dude,
the first billionaire,
one dude controlled everything.
This prescription thugs is some shit.
Yeah,
I've heard.
I can't wait.
Same Guy.
Who did,
he did trophy kids.
Have you seen trophy?
Kids have not.
That's the way he don't.
Bigger,
faster,
stronger to just really good stuff.
Yeah.
What's it called again?
A prescription thugs.
That sounds fucking scariest.
Shit.
I've seen Showbie kids and a Netflix.
Yes.
It just came out to do.
There's one,
I know I'm all over the place,
but there's one vice had a thing on
people taking their own lives and I think
there's eight states in the United States.
Fucking vice.
I don't know how this
journalist got this job.
This old bitch is like,
yeah,
I'm trying to go,
man.
They film it.
They out.
I was in bed 10 o'clock at night.
I'm gonna Watch this bitch die.
It was nuts,
man.
Whoa.
Yeah.
She's just,
she freak out.
I was in a weird space,
man.
I was in a weird space because she,
her,
her whole family's there and she has
this disease where it's not going to get
better.
She's gonna forget everyone.
There's no cure.
It's,
it's done.
So and so,
uh,
she talked to this lady gets approved,
lady comes over and she's like,
yeah,
that's my coffin there.
You guys want a coffee?
She's all happy.
And then she,
her,
her family comes.
They all hugged her and
then I'll have a safe trip.
She's like,
thanks Donka she keeps going.
Donka Donka lays down and everyone's
like c as soon she's like,
yes,
injector and done.
Wow.
Kate,
HBR.
I'm not ready for this shit man.
Chase.
Fuck my whole night up.
Check it out though.
It's the new vice is pretty
dope is a crazy fucking show.
I watched,
I don't remember what
country they were in,
but there were,
they were all wearing bulletproof vests
and they were moving from one set of
broken down rocket shelled buildings
to the next and they're moving around
somewhere in the Middle
East and I'm watching this,
I'm like,
fuck this job.
Like if you're over there.
And then one guy would come to
the camera trying to explain,
well,
the rebels are about three kilometers
away and we have to stay down because they
have been shooting like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Halls to that job,
dude,
that's like the James uh,
James Foley documentary on Hbo.
You know the Guy Jim Foley,
the guy who got caught by Isis,
he's a prisoner of war and he got a gym.
Jim Who got decapitated on they,
it's a documentary on him and
he's a frontline journalist.
It's fucking nuts,
man.
He already got caught and
got out and then went back.
And then ice is like,
Yo,
dog.
It's just too easy.
One of our best at the end of the world.
The end of the world for,
I was like end the end of civilization.
There's countries out there where it
is already the end of civilization.
It's over.
You're going to lock Liberia.
It's done.
If the world economy collapses
and everything and it's
fucking zombies come out
and all that shit.
Nothing changes in Liberia.
It's the same fucking
shit end of the world.
Have you seen the documentaries
on Liberia from vice?
Oh yeah.
I can't get enough captain button naked.
Yeah.
That's the great gender.
Enough of
the God damn world over there.
Nothing changes there.
How about when he caught people eating
human flesh on the corner and the reason
why he knew the guy was selling human
flesh because he knew what it tasted like.
Hey,
you didn't before Mark Coleman
world some crazy shit to get done watching
that shit like in Syria and Kenny,
all that stuff and then you're
in this cushy home in La.
It's like what though?
Yeah,
loans with.
He'll take,
how long would it take if
all the power went out?
Like,
how long would it take before some
people started killing people?
Six months.
It wouldn't even take that long.
You don't think six months?
No,
I don't think we'd rob all
the sub eleven's first few.
If we all ran out of food and you had
some just one asshole that you really
fucking hated and you
don't have to eat his leg.
Yes.
The more you meet a guy,
the tastier he looks.
Keep talking,
motherfucker.
Shit now,
definitely did that back in the day,
man.
I mean,
they definitely did that back in the
day to intimidate the enemy in various
cultures.
They would kill you on islands and shirts.
Yeah,
the Samoans in there.
I don't think he did Vikings cannibalize?
He goes like a thing back in the day.
How about Kevin Raymond?
That's fucking sad.
I was with him on Saturday.
I was at the Superbowl party with him
and then I looked online the next.
I was like,
fuck.
And he was all good at Superbowl party.
Yeah,
he was just coughing a lot,
which obviously was in the movie,
but the most potential a lot.
Fuck his wrestling.
I mean chuck [inaudible],
he was the best in his opinion,
the best wrestler in college history.
That's what chocolate del said.
That was his opinion and his opinion.
He was so happy and,
and I've,
I've known him for maybe we're not like
good friends but known him for 10 years
and I see him once a year.
It's one of those things you have mutual
respect because he's fucking Kevin
Randleman talking to him and then
he's talking about his queen,
his wife,
how awesome she was.
And I mean I met my girlfriend and then
he's talking about his four year old
son.
What a freak though.
Athletically they say he's like the best
athlete to come through the oil knocked
out cro cop.
Ooh Man.
If he would've caught a lot of
left guard and taken back him,
can you imagine that Kevin
Randleman if you would,
if you even got obsessed and
I've had several talks with him,
say get good at passing the guard
and mounting and taken backs.
You'll be unfucking stoppable Jack,
he was the first guy that flat flatline
cro cop in pride from across the ring.
Super Nice Guy.
Man,
speed and power.
That guy had,
he was a real nice guy.
He was fun to be around too.
His real jovial young mark.
No,
not a dick.
So not at all.
No,
he was never a dick.
Bosco from [inaudible] who was talking,
who was on my podcast this week,
he was talking about peanut at a hotel
elevator with them the day before they
fought and uh,
and he said a good luck and uh,
Kevin said good luck back
to him and Kevin said,
I'll make you a deal if you don't kick me.
I promise to keep this on the feet.
Really.
Damn,
that's nuts.
And a boss broke it like immediately he
said random and started slapping his leg
and he felt like he was saying like,
kicked me and I'll take you down.
You know,
like he was trying to
figure out what it is.
So he said yeah.
And then I fixed to the leg and go
with the front kick to the face.
Yeah.
And they took them down a lot.
But he's a great guy,
man.
It'd be good to get a CT
scan of a random men's brain.
Cause we don't have a lot of knowledge
on that on MMA fighters brains.
Huh.
That's a really good point.
I wonder if they were interested
in doing that because this,
his family should,
is it too late?
Probably.
I don't know how it works,
but there's not a lot,
you know,
MMA so young,
a lot of them don't die and he's a legend.
He has a lot of fights.
So it'd be good to get just
to see what's going on with,
with a lot of guys.
But I wonder if anybody's brought that
up because it's hard without being
disrespectful or perceiving that you
are disrespectful saying something like
that.
That's true.
Do you think that's disrespectful?
No,
I definitely don't try to be this.
I don't think you are at all
because wearing the number saying,
asking that question,
it would be hard.
Like you know a lot.
Oh you know,
some people might,
uh,
they might have a hard time with
their kid just dying or their wife,
their husband just dying.
Cause like juniors say out the guy,
literally my hero growing up as
a kid shot himself in the chest.
Right.
And the reason he shot
himself in the chest.
He was like,
you guys need to study my brain,
man,
that's so many concussions.
They just said he wasn't the same guy.
Did he kill himself?
Yeah.
Shoot himself in the chest.
Commit suicide.
When was that?
Three,
four years ago playing junior sal.
Oh,
favorite athlete of all time.
Shit,
I didn't know that.
They said from so many concussions,
like his,
his getaway was the ocean.
Like he would get in the ocean.
He,
they say he was the happiest guy ever.
Had a great family,
lived on the beach and ocean side.
And then he said all of a sudden
something kicked in and he wasn't happy
anywhere.
Anywhere.
He would fake it everywhere.
Then he'd go home,
couldn't sleep.
Super depressed.
Bummer Merman.
But again,
the NFL has been around for so long.
You need the weed.
He gave his brain right and they're like,
yeah,
CT like a motherfucker.
So I'm not saying round in has anything,
but he's one of the legends
with all these fights.
Find Pride,
UFC who we can actually see
what the brain looks like,
step in the right direction.
It's a,
it's a good combo.
Sorry.
Yeah,
it's important though.
What you're saying is a board
that's important to think
about and probably would
been a good idea.
I mean,
who knows?
We don't know.
Maybe somebody else had brought that up,
but I don't know.
I hadn't thought about it.
All I thought about it was like,
wow,
that guy was only like,
I think it was 44 44 and
you know what's crazy?
That's the first thing I thought about.
Yeah.
It wasn't that old man,
but like you said,
when I got disrespectful,
heart failure,
pneumonia and then right,
and had complications,
we went to the hospital.
Yeah.
Fuck who be,
who brought the bad news bears?
People are fucking dying.
Right?
It doesn't seem like they're
dude and music people.
They're starting to drop off.
Block stars are starting to drop off.
Yeah.
Lemmy from Motorhead.
David Bowie.
You can't party that hard
and miscellaneous guys to
like guys that weren't that
famous like Jimmy Bain and
the bass player for deal.
Like they're slowly,
boom,
cause I forgot.
It's that time.
All that,
all those years of partying in the 70s
and eighties oh it's good to get you
right now.
It's going to get you to stop drunk.
They're going to start drop.
Hey those guys in the
80s kind of worth it,
isn't it?
To live those glory years bro.
You know what's crazy?
It's,
you know that metal is huge in the
eighties hair metal and all that shit.
Guns and roses and Motley Crue and then
died a horrible vanilla ice type death
in the 90s and shit.
And in the two thousands
but guess fucking what dude.
Guess what it's been.
It's common bad.
Rose is doing tours,
tours,
Motley Crue playing a couple of
nights at the staples center.
Come on.
That's,
that's fucking,
and they couldn't do that 10 years
ago because his is beyond all that.
They've been doing that forever.
Yeah.
Cause is different.
They had,
that's a hold up dude.
Rolling stones though.
No rolling stones never went down.
They never went down to right above it.
It had metal guns and
roses when fucking down.
Now they're putting together that
finally they're putting together,
you know how big that guns and
roses reunion tour is going to be?
It's going to finally slash and axle
made up and they said let's do this.
Holy Shit that's going to be fucking eat
all that shit's coming back for them on
a podcast.
That's why I figured everybody's here.
Why not a lot of people talking to
cause the Diet but could hold it.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
Cody and Tuck Kinko if I
want it to never seen it.
I know how to like do a little camel.
You know,
I do have a weird bladder now,
but I think I trained it over
all six years of doing podcasts.
I get the bladder and they
stretched out and I must be,
it's like a old hookers,
but
it's a super pliable.
It's up jamming.
I saw a trailer for John Travolta,
his new movie.
Cause this Arnold Schwartzenegger
thing just made me think of it.
Yeah.
Oh it looks so bad.
Oh really?
Like the punisher.
I'll fuck I am wrath bro.
But do you see no,
no,
I heard he's awesome.
And the Oj show.
That's why just say John Travolta
Know Jay has a Shapiro is the shit.
They were playing the Oj show at the
comedy store yesterday and everybody was
raving about it.
I was like,
it's good,
but it's like all water.
But nothing happened.
I heard Cuba Gooding Jr is the shit.
Oh see he's my only problem.
Really?
Yeah,
he's not that good.
Everyone else is the bond.
Everyone else is spot on.
And then Cuba use in June.
It looks nothing like Oj.
Well looks nothing like him,
but his acting well.
You kind of get a good actor though.
And what good actor looks exactly like.
Oh Jay,
none.
So you got to take it another
guy and put him in prosthetics.
My boy who did.
Oh,
that would be kind of creepy.
Right?
Be fucking weird.
That would be creepy as fuck that it.
You did it.
It drifts Elba.
They couldn't get him,
cause he's too big in the movies.
He meets James Bond now,
but someone of that ilk who's that
good and then you give him some crazy
prosthetics.
He goes,
no,
he's black already.
But you let them do a,
uh,
a fucking Daniel Day Lewis,
where it's just lives like that for a
year and he puts on the prosthetic and
likes his Oj.
That would freak people to fuck out,
bro.
I'm saying you get Robert Downey
Jr does blackface as Oj Simpson.
That's boxing.
He's already done in tropic
thunder and he's so good.
He's like one of the only white guys
was ever pulled off black faces people.
What movie was funnier
than Tropic Thunder?
Name one movie funnier
than dressed down there.
I don't think there's ever been
a movie that was funny earlier,
but that was as about as funny as a movie.
Yeah,
Dude.
Come on.
[inaudible]
full retard.
Come on.
[inaudible] come on and go full week on
the greatest Internet memes of all data.
That may be one of the funniest scenes,
best acting job of all time.
He played a black guy and
come on a solid black guy.
It was fucking money.
God,
how about the scene where,
where,
Ah,
a Jack Black was tied to eat.
He told everyone time and your fucking
tree and don't let me talk you into
letting me out.
That scene where he's offering to suck.
The dude's do come on as well in the
swollen gravy and the swollen grade.
Come on,
swallow the grantee and then
that gay black guy goes,
I told you,
man,
I'm in the pissy.
I love that movie.
I love it.
I knew the Chino baby booty juice.
One thing I'll never
forget about that movie.
The impression that left
on me when I'm like,
okay,
you here,
it's good and you go to the movies.
I'm at the movie theater and watching
it in the beginning when they blow that
fucking director's head off,
you see right there,
I thought,
oh shit,
you're in some,
yes,
this is,
this is going to be an amazing,
how good was Tom Cruise as the fat agent?
Oh my God,
he's amazing.
But dancing on it in the best mood.
You know the craziest
thing about that movies,
every character it was I thought
the only movie everywhere.
Every character was a douchebag.
Yes,
and nobody.
Everybody was a Douche bag.
There was no cool people.
It was like making,
it was making fun.
Jack,
can you find that scene where
Jack Black tied to a tree
to Ben Stiller?
His character was the ultimate Douche bag.
He was asked.
He was like,
aw man,
here's your boy.
Here's your,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
What is,
this is tacchino and then who some
are Paul Harris is took Kenya.
Yeah.
Very similar.
What is the difference in a lab?
What is the tank?
Kino and little tank.
I think I'm just Tokyo and the other
one is talking or like twister.
I thought it was tree.
That's the tree.
Well fuck man.
You're just guessing.
I'm telling you.
I'm guessing it's pretty educated guesses.
I think tore it toward the keynote.
You know what I love when they say in
the corner where they go trick kilos.
Trank Quito.
We were telling you to relax.
That's a Mexican.
Well it's Portuguese too.
I'm pretty sure there's going to
be a good fight in Portuguese.
It's Elisa.
Similar sounding word,
cause I've heard guys and a
Brazilian dude's corners calling it.
You see her?
Nothing.
She's like,
Eddie made this up.
Eddie,
is he still with Mckenzie?
Is He still with Mackenzie?
Not they're both with anybody.
We both single think Cody's on page.
They're both.
Dick's lingers and Cody,
who is a murderous puncher and a dime.
We don't,
we don't have any idea what a,
how'd he say?
Tuck?
He knows who we started
trying for the tank tank.
You down the hall.
That's how I get times is
he fought MMA five and no,
but all outside of the UFC?
Yes.
What a tough first time.
And Cody seven no,
but he doesn't,
you know,
he doesn't have a ton of experience.
I mean his standup doesn't look that bad,
right?
Oh,
Cody has a ton of amateur fights.
He's winging punches on
the outside of amateur.
I was going to get counted.
He's going to be super careful.
Oh,
you never know,
man.
He might just decide,
okay,
it's time to go on a
defensive shell and hit him.
Dot.
Good luck taking Cody down.
Good.
Hard to take.
Did he wrestle in high school and Shit?
That's what I mean.
I mean the Jujitsu guy would
have kind of wrestling.
I don't know,
man.
All his greatest work has
been done with the geese,
so I don't know how
it's going to translate.
I'm not sure.
Where did Cody Russell.
It just in high school,
but he's real good.
Really,
really good.
And that team,
Alpha Male,
they said he's like sets the
standard as far as intensity.
He's a motherfucker while he's,
he's just there for looks great.
Right?
Yeah,
he's definitely got some nasty pounds.
Look at that.
He's hurt.
He's hurt any of the
gut of his back pocket.
Hey,
is that a gun in your pants?
Dude?
That's an amazing idea to
go with through the way in.
That's the hardest tramp stamp ever.
It goes right to his bundle dude,
dude.
So no one knows if he's still with page.
Oh,
let's see how much control
you didn't like it.
Stand up coach,
get them back to coach.
Should not go to the ground with it.
Hell no,
no,
no.
I don't think he'd probably like that,
but meanwhile no controls Egypt.
But I would you have liked
to have seen from him.
And that was ish.
I don't know man.
I mean that's time Kino though,
right?
But what would you like,
like when you,
when you're seeing the
guy was trying to go,
I think he's not going to be able to
take him down and I think he's going to
lose the fight if he stays on his feet.
So if he can't take
him down and you can't,
uh,
survive on your feet,
what else is left?
Jumped to guard.
I mean,
that's all you have to have.
Car pulls out
many times.
Frank Mir fantasy hit no works.
You're good on your back if
you've got fires over Bam.
Right.
But I,
I've never really seen him on his back.
He's the,
he's the destroyer on top.
He destroys people going
through them on to,
I bet he's pretty good though,
I bet is just who's
better on his back then?
Cody's is on,
his standup was not that bad.
He,
he's definitely a outgunned by Cody,
but he's moving well,
he's getting out of the way a shit.
Well,
he's landed some decent,
yeah.
Jujitsu background
standups.
Not Bad at all.
Not that bad because I
see like he's movies.
Try to choose that check
hook as he stepping back.
He's not running in a straight
line with his hands down.
You know,
he's not doing anything dumb.
Not being reckless,
that's for sure.
No,
save his time.
He's smart.
He's very smart.
Anybody that gets that good at Jujitsu,
man,
it's,
it's when you're hitting
that super mastery level
where you're beating the best
guys in the world.
Well those guys,
all they have to do is just focus on the
new thing and they start picking up the
new thing with the same sort of clarity
that they pick up as long as I only
physical issues,
especially Jitsu guys
don't there so cerebral,
it's,
they're so smart they
bring into the octagon.
I feel like there's a difference
in the way you move though.
And the problem is that
some guys who are grapplers,
they never seem to figure out how to
develop that explosive snap prompt.
I'm talking like you were saying,
the world class world
champions like Jock Caray,
Damien Maia,
right?
Like those motherfuckers when they
bring that same mindset to MMA.
Dude,
they're fucking nightmare.
Yeah.
Joc Curry right now.
Look at that colon cut.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
It's got some standard.
It's scary to have someone
with that sort of mastery.
Even you got that good at something.
Holy Shit Dry.
No,
no,
no.
Stop the fight.
Oh,
hate on that.
Stop at jetty.
I hate that shit.
Break Trauma.
See Safety,
safety.
All three
just got fucked us over.
Dude.
That fight was no Eddie.
Let's,
let's look at it again.
Joe Silva did.
I was happy with it.
I fell at Cody.
Cody,
Cody.
Cody would have won,
but like I was looking at you.
We want to see a little bit guys.
Here we go.
Once again,
we want to see Eddie.
Wow.
Oh
no,
he's fine.
Not Really Saki in the way.
That was terrible
positioning by Mario Saki.
Don't tell me.
That was a good stop it good.
Okay.
It's a little rough here.
This is what
now I'm agreeing with Eddie.
Well,
first of all,
the positioning by Mario
Yamasaki was terrible.
Like you're not supposed to do that.
You're not supposed to step in between
unless you're stopping the fight.
Who stepped in between?
They stepped out like he got in between
the action and then he let the action
gone.
I don't think you guys are
only supposed to do that.
That was a moment of indecision or he
wanted to get a better look at him and
that was the only way he could do it.
But it's a mistake to go between the
two fighters because at least in my
opinion,
it makes the fight or
that the fight stops.
So it got backs off where you could have
landed shots in that time to really,
and Mario hadn't been in his way.
I agree 100% I mean,
he dropped some,
he's hurt.
He's on top of him.
Those couple seconds.
Sometimes it's all you need to get
enough clarity to grab a leg or
just try to scramble back up
to your feet or to clinch.
So that second or so were
Mario walks in front of them.
That like interfered.
Yeah.
Change physician.
Right.
Please.
I heard what he said and then you still
know Mario fucked up whether Mario
jumped in or not.
Cody is winning that fight right there.
Maybe he got more head
trauma or not fight was over.
Maybe to understand what the fans want.
The fans want Dosha out of clothes.
Yes,
and I do not give a fuck.
You don't care about the fans?
Oh No,
not when it comes to the fat guy.
Safety.
His first fight in the UFC,
he was out on his feet.
It's all about safety.
I get it.
Speaking of head trauma,
I think Eddie's being passive aggressive,
Mario.
Fuck.
We got to save their lives.
The real loser here.
He really fucked.
Oh,
how dare you.
You know what I'm saying?
If there's a loser in the fire tomorrow,
you're out there.
No,
Mario,
I love you the heart,
by the way,
Brendan.
You know I love you.
I'm not trying to talk shit.
I know
Ian
is super valid.
Yeah,
we'd love to argue.
As long as we're clear with that.
He's always been of the mind that you
should let guys take a few more hits on
the ground rather than a few less.
That's the majority and I'm saying,
I'm saying I've been in there,
you know what I'm saying with that head
trauma and I've seen how it affects
friends and I'm just like,
man,
I wish you'd stop it a little earlier
because the odds are homeboy not going to
win that fight,
so might as well stop
the fight another day.
[inaudible] Edgar Frankie
Edgar bins claiming.
Exactly.
There have been plenty of food.
I love the exceptions though.
That's the exception in general.
There would be more of those exceptions
if there would've been more referee's
letting it go.
Like how about Weidman?
How do we,
maybe Weidman is not the
same or junior dos Santos,
maybe it's not the same and fight without
a doubt should have been stopped at
the end of the day.
You start a fund like some kind of fun.
You don't think [inaudible] fight should
have been stopped at the end of the
third mount I,
you know what?
I would be lying if I said
I didn't like the violence.
I like,
I get get any fucking smashed.
I like that's the majority.
People enjoy that because
that's what they paid to watch.
I'm saying from my point
of view as the x fighter,
it's like,
dude,
let them fight another day.
He has a long career,
man.
Let's just stop it and
that's why it's so cool when when chuck,
after he wins,
he's like a fucking fight into like,
that's why,
because it's so dangerous
until you could get shut off,
but I didn't get shut off.
You got,
I know.
That's great.
And then 20 years,
then in 20 years,
right.
Then 20 years you see these
boys and they're drooling.
They don't know where the
fuck do I know what they knew.
They know the risk.
All right.
I know,
but we can prevent some
of it is all I'm saying.
Prevention Fund.
I like sort of prevention felt like
both of your attitudes about this.
You know,
my attitude right now is I hope that
science hit some point where medical
science fix the brain,
figure out some way to
just revive the brain.
That'd be so dope.
I mean,
why can't they,
if they can do all this different stuff,
tweaking,
they can muscle tissue repair and
they can fix all kinds of stuff.
Like who knows what they could do with
like maybe one day they're going to be
able to shoot stem cells in your brain.
That's the,
that's the ticket.
Cause you do that.
We're all hell yeah.
Let's go out and we actually got a
bunch of letter you'll see is now what
happens,
what are the side effects?
It would be just like you imagine the
side effects fucking nightmares every
night.
I'll take it.
Awesome.
Maybe it's going to be like
steroids for the brain.
Like you know,
you see bodybuilders,
they're fucking ridiculously oversized.
You going to get people,
giant bull,
Mars attacks brains and the brains
and shit
continue to run the world.
And then everybody's going to say,
this fucking juicer is out there.
One in the world.
We're going to get bad.
And people are brain juice in
the elite [inaudible] attacking
another classic movies.
So great job science,
all sorts of science and
haters be going well.
Book Brain,
your mind Bitch,
cause he's on steroids
without steroids.
Carry read my mind and made me calm.
He's cheating.
You know that's like when you
see a giant bodybuilder do this.
The first thing that every guy says,
boy,
he under committed to that kick.
He backed off that kid.
He'd come in,
he caught him with a beautiful counter.
Imagine jeopardy where
they test for steroids.
Is this all
that was?
That was a big fuck up by Mario.
That's a big fuck up right there.
I mean,
look,
I don't want to die.
I don't want to do that job.
That's sort of the way harder
job than doing commentary.
Commentary.
Commentary is the,
my job doing come to is the easiest
one of all the jobs in the UFC.
Slightly just slightly harder
than Ariana's job lightly.
If it's slightly harder
than it [inaudible] go away,
they have to replace you and was like,
God placed me right now to look here.
I am doing it.
We're here.
We're here in woodland hills,
partying it up and more
people are listening to you
talk about margins and Brian
Stann breakdown the
fight just the way it is.
What the fuck
this shit
gotta be?
Juicing.
He knows Maco removed.
They put his brain to fish tank.
He's a fucking juicer.
He knows he can cook
pop quizzes.
He's got like 10 degrees.
What's the,
what's the host of jeopardy?
What's that guys?
Now it's true balance Fetzer back.
There's going to be like Dana White
doing press conferences and shit.
We got the most stringent
tests of all game areas.
That's going to be dudes
way smarter than Einstein.
Man,
that's going to happen for sure.
It is.
They already have,
they already have things like Modafinil,
which they've outlawed in the Olympics.
You can't have that in the Olympics
anymore and that started out as a smart
drug.
That was a drug that they created.
They had to say that they want,
they've made it for people
that have narcolepsy.
It made me angry.
They originally didn't,
they didn't cut.
Modafinil makes you angry.
Really.
I took it for an extended period of,
because you're so smart,
you're so smart and you get angry.
Then how don't,
here's a funny thing,
I it,
you'll like this.
They came up with it just for
performance enhancing reasons.
It was created for that,
but then because it's a prescription drug,
they had to have a reason to
prescribe it like an illness.
That's how drugs are set up.
Like you can't say,
hey,
you need a prescription
to be more awesome.
I'm going to take awesome pills and no,
you have to have something wrong with you.
I'm not awesome.
I got diagnosed as an awesome.
So then once you diagnosis unawesome,
you can take modafinil.
So you have to like say like
I'm experiencing fatigue or uh,
you know,
I drive and I need to
stay awake when I drive.
It has to be something like
that and get narcolepsy.
So they have this drug that's used to,
oh,
silicon valley silicone,
how do they say it?
Silicone.
Wait a minute.
You guys listen.
These guys that are running
these tech companies,
they're all taking modafinil.
It is the drugs.
It's just,
this is real.
Modafinil,
I'll get you this prescription.
It's um,
it was real new vision.
Have you heard about the Jack [inaudible]?
I have it.
I have prescription.
I want it.
I'll give you something.
No wonder you're so fucking smart.
I knew it was bullshit.
Pretty sure.
I just witnessed a crime.
Does know how to get
him into prescription.
What it does is it gives you,
I don't very rarely take it.
This is what I take it.
I'll take it.
If I know I'm tired and I got a,
I got to drive or if
I've got to do something,
I really want to be sharp.
I don't feel,
but I don't take it
before podcasts anymore.
I've taken it for like four or five.
Podcast would be the time to take it.
Yeah,
no,
not necessarily.
Because sometimes you
want a conversation to be,
um,
as well.
You don't want it to be too ramped up in,
I mean like you gotta know,
you gotta know like feeling dumb gas.
If you want to be at their level,
you want to be able to be casual
effortlessly as well as be amped up.
See I think modafinil is really
good if I want to be amped up,
but I don't necessarily think it would
be good if I wanted to be casual.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause it's,
it's to take it like Viagara
on the first day you're like,
I'm going to fucking dazzle this
[inaudible] shit.
[inaudible] coming to me.
I don't know what it is.
You're like breaking
down fucking molecules.
Just
it doesn't work anymore.
Cause I was just do is go into her phone.
I just googled what you
said and it's nonsense.
What is the closest thing to limitless?
You googled what?
You're the one that talking to me.
You're the one that's talking about it.
What are you talking about?
Trying to figure out what that noise was.
Hearing noises.
Whole fucking time.
We're talking.
Yeah.
I thought I heard some shit to Jamie.
Where are you feeling like wait a second.
They put acid in.
Jamie were slain the Mars tax thing.
You should have a tropic
thunder on that bitch.
Not fucking Mars Attacks Act.
Act One of the tax like top
200 so don't sleep on margin.
The tax.
Good
man.
He's hilarious.
It still holds up.
I watched it a year ago.
It's funny,
Dude.
I just watched by six months ago.
It's really funny.
Tim.
Tim Burton.
Yeah.
It's a classic.
That's a classic
dude.
When you,
when you tell him what to watch something,
I watch it Thrones.
I resisted game of Thrones for gears.
I've never seen it.
He said,
well,
I can watch it.
Of course.
Who doesn't like game?
I've never seen game of Thrones.
I'm waiting.
They should arrested two studies.
Hold on.
Is there?
Yes.
I'm not going to watch it.
I shoot.
All right man.
Get in a conversation
with someone that does
listen to her Santa Claus.
Time to fucking grow up.
Peter Pan's Santa Claus is,
that's another story there.
There's not enough evidence for,
have you seen Vikings speaking
of I supposed to be factual.
No.
Is that bad?
No,
it's fucking awesome.
The show.
Yeah.
If I can just go ahead.
It's all about Ragnar loss.
Brick thought reality.
Yes.
It's based on reality and it's vikings.
Vikings just fucking ruin everything.
It's awesome.
They just,
they were hardly the first terrorist.
That's what I heard.
Fuck yeah,
they were conquerors.
There was a bad time
when someone wasn't like,
you know,
but a few hundred years ago we
were a ship showed up at your,
you're sure you got a real fucking problem
with fucking balls of fire ready to go.
There's no technology drones.
You're going to have to battle
that shit with your hands.
Imagine living back then
you would get nothing done.
Limit
towards getting ready for the
invasion battles the same,
making arrows,
trying not to die,
trying to live past 25 dude,
come on.
You got to,
when there's like a rugby team of like,
like a thousand people here,
thousand people there,
and they just rush each other.
How the fuck do you got?
The only way you can convince the guy
to do that is you got to make sure he
believes in Jesus and you gotta make
sure he believes in God because you're
doing it for God.
Shit.
But that was back then.
So whatever,
whatever it is,
I believe with that shit,
Bro.
That's like the suicide bombers.
Now,
the only reason they can convince them
because they think they're going to
heaven.
How about that bit you had man.
Ah,
Shit.
How about,
I don't even know how it goes,
but it was something about,
uh,
one of the guys that got sent over here
to blow up America just started partying
at the Skype
phone calls.
They go,
why are you still alive?
Some shiny happy.
Why are you still alive?
Because he's supposed
to blow yourself a week.
Here's what to blow
yourself up a week ago.
No,
no,
I'll get the
Mercedes.
Good.
Why are you still alive?
That's the greatest fight ever.
Angry phone calls,
those shiny happy.
That would be a great animated,
a little series about some dudes that
would come over to the states to where
supposed to blow
themselves up comedy with.
They just started partying and they said,
fuck.
They realize it's awesome here.
You never going to see a suicide
bomber from Beverly Hills.
Like they have to come from somewhere.
That's sucks.
But like the idea of death is
like more appealing staying alive.
[inaudible]
the guys that are organizing
the shit in the Middle East,
they've got to make sure they send
them to like Minnesota or some shit.
They can't send them on
a one way ticket to la.
Never works.
They realized that doesn't work.
They kept fuck with La.
They got to send them to
Illinois or some shit like that.
Yeah.
They'll go to him with
the plants are like,
okay,
let's do it after like a week ago,
this fucking do it.
We do it for you.
Send it in.
Miami river was huge problems.
No.
Seven verse seven there's gotta be some
guy convincing dudes in the Middle East.
They're like looking for the,
you know,
like hitting just up to the dumbest
motherfuckers they hypnotize.
There's gotta be some guy looking like
to convince them to blow themselves up.
You got to throw pussy at him,
right.
Number 72 virgins or their,
their Iq Iq levels are lower than it is.
Part of your bill is like,
how did they get to 72 they must have
offered 12 at first and like there's like,
I ain't blow myself
one night.
I've talked to God final offer,
pitches.
They were all very fine.
If that was real,
if you could prove that shit killed
yourself and you've got 72 virgins for the
eternity,
I know personally that would do that shit.
You just got convince me drills.
That's a good deal.
70 rotate one every every week.
Boom.
Yeah,
but what if it all burns
out when they all die?
Because if you get it
talking about eternity,
like you might be a terminal,
but if they're really 72 virgins,
they're going to say their own swag 20
and so they got like 80 years of life
left.
If they eat vegetables,
stay alive and there'll be old ladies.
So you only want to fuck
them for the first 40 years.
50 and 60 it's like charity work.
Then your jacket mouthy
not to break their hands.
The dealership and the guy
breaks out the calculator.
It was like,
well you know if I can give you this many,
but uh,
I think,
imagine the negotiations are 72 they
decided on 72 they knew 50 wouldn't be
enough.
You're not going to get any.
It like the lottery where you take
like a little bit every month.
So listen,
I want to keep this rolling bitches at
once and then they will die and grow old.
This is what you want.
You want 100 people in the bombing sat,
was he two versions?
One for every 40 50 years?
Good.
They're on the fence and then the side,
no,
and then something bad.
The car breaks down and the fucking
transmission falls out and they're like,
or like,
and then they're saying,
they're saying a lot of them,
they're committed,
they're girls doing,
they're forcing girls to do it now.
They talked him into it.
It was part of my base.
How are you going to fuck?
What was that?
That was part of my bed.
I was like,
you're never gonna to see
female suicide bombers.
Dick is just not worth that much
or way too accessible slaves and
they turn them into the suicide.
You said on your bed,
Dick is worth like that fly or you find
after you leave a club and there's a
flyer,
it tick is worth that much
fucking great.
A suicide bomber shit.
That was a whole wall.
That was what I was obsessed.
I was obsessed with.
It was right after nine 11 nine 11
nine 11 to that was like 2001 to 2005
material.
That's when I put that
on a shiny happy jihad.
Oh Man.
That could easily,
easily been like some fucking animated
series about these guys that got talked
into blowing themselves up.
They get freaked.
Forgot about a lot of my bits.
72 virtual.
You brought
up the sky bar.
We talked about doing that.
We talked to him making a bit out of that,
but you to,
you're like,
you know what?
I don't need no crazy motherfuckers coming
after that was discussed when we were
on the man show that
was actually discussed.
Kennedy's number
number is now out of the house.
Hauntcon narrows.
Very good.
Your Shit so very strong.
Do you remember when Brunson
took down fucking your boy?
He did turn up tiny head,
kicked him to remember that he hit
you over a mirror with that switch.
Kick off to the left leg,
kept taking them down.
He's a stud.
Derek Bronson is a breakout fight.
He's getting better every time,
but he's like looking good,
knocking on the door of potential,
you know,
looking at Greg Jackson and his coat.
I'd love to figure out how's
Greg's going to do the [inaudible]
been what?
Sorry?
Is anybody been watching
Paul Daley in Beltre?
How's he been looking?
You just knocked out a dude.
He mocks out everybody
just with that left hook.
You just finished it.
This left hand is strong.
He was fun to watch a man.
I was so bummed out
when he got kicked out.
The whole thing was such a Josh Kushner.
So unnecessary man.
I don't know what horrible nasty
shit cost check was saying to him.
Josh at Dick,
he probably deserved it
was kept punching gap.
Yeah,
you definitely,
you definitely should have never ever,
ever do that.
But man,
he didn't and he didn't land.
The Punch was,
even though he should have apologized,
you know,
it's like if cooler heads prevailed,
if I was his friend,
man,
I would've pulled him aside and I said,
I would've said,
Liz,
make a public apology.
You lost your fucking mind.
Pr Josh Koscheck cause he
got inside my head so hard.
I got completely out of character.
I'm embarrassed,
I'm ashamed it'll never happen again.
I am so sorry.
I disrespect the sport.
I fully expected to be fined and
suspended for a period of time,
but I will make reparations and I'm very,
I'm very disappointed in myself.
Don't talk to and do whatever you have to.
And then they would all been under the
water right now and he would have had
some insane fights with condit
and sane fights with Lawler.
Insane fights with so many guys.
We were robbed of some insane
fights from Paul Daley.
He is one of the best 170 pounds
strikers on planetary MMA,
MMA,
his fucking lefts last hand.
His left hook is a piston.
He's one of the best in MMA.
I love when he fights.
Still so exciting.
Oh Jesus Christ.
He Fuck Dwayne?
Yes.
Our brother Dwayne.
Dude.
Dude,
he's terrifying from Martin Kampmann.
Yup.
Yeah.
Look at wrong throwing down now.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
on narrow can box up with it.
Yup.
He's stuck with,
well,
he's American top team.
He's their head Jujitsu coach and
a lot of those guys a retired,
you know what I mean?
He stuck with it.
Yeah.
You know a lot of experience.
It takes so long to get good at strike.
Oh look at this.
He gets you down and you'd be in trouble,
but you got to get Derek
Bronson down there.
Look at that.
Take down defense.
She's the show.
She's got a nasty left kick to,
he throws it from south port or he
can throw it real good off the switch.
I'm pretty sure he hit Romero
with it off the switch,
but he was doing oh shot from Brazil.
What's going to happen?
What kind of control from there?
Like you want to go down?
I felt like mine,
but he's kind of like your
home against the fence.
Oh my God.
I don't know man.
What do you call,
what do you have to do
to be defensive here?
I mean like got to push them.
You got to push them away.
How do you get the rough
for you to not stop it?
You got to
tell you that,
but,
okay.
How about cowboy and dos?
Anjos he would,
he never went and lived there.
He was fine.
He didn't move,
move jobs,
but he can't move cause he got kicked
out of kind of moved and he was trying to
move to garden.
It's over now to the point.
All right,
that's it.
That's over now.
How many punches he just
through?
It's hard to do in fighting
against that fence.
Doesn't matter what guard you're
playing against the fence.
It's fucking,
it's not going to get off the fence.
You gotta get off the fence.
No guards.
You have to work.
If you're not working,
they're going to stop it.
Derek Brunson,
he needs a break out fight.
That ain't it.
He needs a big name breakout fight.
Well that was a step towards
a breakout for agree.
I agree so many top ten's
the best wrong Carnero.
You know,
at this point his striking
never looked better.
I mean there's footwork,
Derek Bronson's legit.
Oh yeah.
He's for real bitch to be and
he's getting better and better
and better and broke his neck and died
and that was $1 million baby in the
wound.
Just had all these flashes.
It's an asterix gypsy Paul
Williams fight a boxer.
Great fighter.
You know,
lost a crazy knockout.
The Sergio Martinez,
he got hit with that left
hand from hell right here.
You got to put feet on
the hips and push people.
Forget Paul Williams
before that fight was,
he did that a little bit.
A little bit more is awesome,
but it was the same is
huge motorcycle accident.
You got hit by a car.
Some guy going through an intersection
or something like that and nailed it.
I mean that's some serious,
he's paralyzed,
right?
Yeah.
Paralyzed from the waist down.
He went flying through the air apparently.
Damn powerful.
Derek Brown's for dawn.
Dawn,
dawn,
Tom.
Oh,
we got cowboy next.
Very impressive.
We go like I would look.
If you think about Bella tour,
now,
think about that.
You've got Benson over there.
He's fighting one 70 and Benson's got
a good fight against that Russian cat.
Dude.
Who's that rush and Katie's fight.
I can't even entertain.
I came in with a chain that spell it
toward talk after what I saw in the last
two fights,
man.
Oh Yoel Romero is fucked.
What's what's going on with that?
I know they're appealing.
Can Be doing steroids.
Can you still say potty and MMA?
Hundred Percent Oh my boy does now.
No.
Yoel Romero Woodley has
a place for steroids.
There's no doubt about it,
but it doesn't matter.
We're just talking about result.
We're not talking about like,
you know he has something to say
this and this feels more facing.
Man is a very,
he's got a very good body,
but it cannot fuck with the freak show.
That's what shows free shit.
A legit.
Now think if Allen Joe ban half,
he's under investigation.
Alan Jobe,
man,
take,
you're not born talking
pound for pound bodies.
We're not talking about they got there.
We're talking about like what?
What results were achieved?
I'll have to go with Uber ream
then when he fought Brock Lesnar.
Yes.
That's the best thing to come into this.
If you're talking about Yo
was 19 got on my face to
face.
You don't like white people.
I mean we're talking about best body's
tired of I'm tired of white people
breathing.
All are here.
Wide nose having,
yeah,
but as far as like the guys that I've
seen step into the octagon where I was
like,
what in the fuck Yoel
Romero is the number one.
What in the fuck?
That's a skinny Woodley.
[inaudible] Woodley now though,
do Woodley Woodley has something to say
when we has that apple bottom out of the
bag too.
We,
I can't really comment and I see,
here's where y'all having a marrow.
Here's where Yo Romero
disappears from the pack traps.
His traps are literally
from another planet.
They start at the top of his head.
They go all the way down
the back of his neck.
The biggest fucking traps,
like when you see him,
he just looks like he could
throw you to the moon.
Let's say just as far
as better the rounds,
dude,
as far as best body,
let's say you're,
you're,
you have a product.
You want to hire a model.
I'm not hiring,
I'm not hiring him.
We're talking about fucking
still picking Woodley or Joe
van cause their fake picture.
Jesus Christ,
he's fucking jacked.
She's Christ.
Look at it like the trap to shoulder
ratio show over him when he fought last.
He's on drugs.
No,
no,
no peptides.
It's up for,
he was a freak man dude over him when he
fought lesson though was a better body.
Well over him when he fought
lesson was also a hundred pounds.
We want to retire then just
remember what I just said.
He's a hundred pounds
heavier when he weighed in,
he gets six
phone out taking pictures of his ass,
but he's a hundred pounds heavier.
That what pounds heavier you over Romero.
When you were saying he gained only
really 80 but think about the difference
between a one 85 are in a to 65
gigantic to 65 world class striking.
I mean it's only 80 pounds.
I'm exaggerating by saying
100 but not by much.
You wouldn't really be able
to tell the difference.
He was 20 pounds.
Come on son,
when he fought Brock.
I bet.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I bet that's as big as a man can get.
And it's fun to be functional.
Yeah,
he was amazing.
You guys are given white guys love babies.
I think you guys are free.
There we go.
Yeah,
I'm just saying that had sex right there.
Country,
big country,
last fight with Rochelle and that guy
has a lot of fucking Twitter followers.
A lot of Facebook live.
People love him.
So just seems like it's,
it's not capitalized on enough.
You know?
It's crazy.
I agree.
Marika loves enough.
Yeah.
I mean it seems like someone
somehow should have taken advantage.
Some company should have a scooped him
up for commercials or stuff like that,
but reality show,
well,
just a commercial like,
uh,
gave him getting him a Gig for
something that says king or something.
He was close to sign with Burger King.
I think.
I haven't talked to Roy a while.
Right.
We did the ultimate fighter together
when we did our live fire and the kid in
Vegas out there,
I get a text like 10 minutes
before the show goes,
love you brother.
You can do great tonight.
Can't wait to see it.
Like who the fuck is this?
Who is it?
See what it's Roy man,
I'm in the crowd.
I was like,
dude,
he's that dude.
Yeah.
He's such a nice guy and
his wife is very cool too.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's one of those guys that I feel like
if he had someone who understood like
how to market him better
to sponsors and stuff,
like I could see that dude doing a ton
of commercial that his wife doing as
management.
Uh,
well you need someone who knows how
to like sell you to like a motor oil
company.
I remember when you shout Ca.
Yeah.
Remember when Chuck was doing those,
uh,
what would they,
some Carter last door last,
what is the [inaudible] battery battery.
He remembered the battering wrecking ball
hits him in the face and all that kind
of shit.
Chuck was also world champion.
Yeah,
true.
I find myself like,
like Roy could be in some humor
type stuff,
you know bass,
bass,
fishing equipment,
like the boats and shit and the swamps.
I'm with you.
What?
No,
no,
no.
Come on now.
If you want to sell money to
people in the bass fishing world,
you have to have a bass fishing star.
You would have to,
they have dogs that
this guys watch the UFC.
Oh,
they definitely do.
But you know who they watch you to
fucking dance fishing show for real.
Those those guys.
There's a whole world
with those people live in.
I watched it the other day for two hours.
I watched professional bass fishing on
TV because we'll still have plenty to do.
I'm watching psychology.
No wonder can you watch making a murderer?
Yes.
Oh No.
I started at [inaudible].
How many have you seen?
Just the first one.
Ooh.
And I was like,
whoa.
I get first.
I was like,
fuck this guy.
He's guilty.
He's guilty with this is
not the guy is a dirt bag.
He's guilty.
His family doesn't want to admit it.
I see what's going on here.
And then you find out about
the other guy and you go,
oh wait,
didn't,
and you find out about how they knew
about the other guy and they ignore the
evidence.
I don't want to spoil dude.
It gets,
it gets 10 times crazier.
No,
it's a eight.
It lasted two episodes too long for me.
Is there nine?
Okay.
Spoiler alert.
No,
no,
no.
Don't listen to him.
Oh you mean the nice stop watching it?
The right part.
Cause I don't remember.
Nothing else happens.
Are we talking about right
before that were performed?
How about narcan training?
Big Brennan big country is a,
as a superstar
bass fishing bass fishing people
that I've watched it for two hours.
I was asking what to do
and really psychotic.
They catch the fish,
they weigh them and they
have like a recording,
like a digital thing that
with their way I'm on.
So they know exactly how much they went
and they throw them back in the water
like they used to keep them in there.
I don't know if they still keep them then
maybe it was just what tournaments and
I was watching.
They used to keep in what they call live.
Well,
so this tank,
this area to tank and the pool,
uh,
in the,
in the hall of the boat,
they throw the fish in there and
then they'd show him to everybody.
Then allegedly let 'em go.
But that fucking vision been tortured.
Yeah.
Hours.
And they just keep kept in the
same as I can problem with,
with fish that have mouth problems
and fucking like fucked up.
Yeah.
They get hooks and then they,
they get massive because we don't
exactly,
nobody gives a fuck.
No.
Can you imagine you're
catching squirrels with hooks?
I was going to say no one
gives a fuck about bass.
Bass
fishing contests through phones and
texting them up the hill and the parties
come and run over in the puppies.
Grabbed the hooks.
He try to eat the biggest puppy.
It makes me sad,
but it's a small basket.
You'd watch those guys catch a small bass.
That's like a year old bass,
a two year old bath.
Disney made a movie about a back pass.
I don't know who gives a fuck about
these people standing for fish writes and
shit.
It's just like,
okay,
you can pull the chairs were,
there's a,
there was an organization
called the lobster liberation or
I'm not bullshitting.
They'd break into restaurants and
seafood places and they would free the
lobsters and set them loose
back into the ocean again.
That's all I have.
Cockroaches in my garage.
If you want to get,
that's awesome.
Take it back to Madagascar or
wherever the fuck they get delirious.
Awesome.
How crazy is that?
Doubt or something like that.
You're getting arrested for a lobster.
There's people that break goldfish.
Yeah,
but then you get out right away.
Well,
they have,
that's a problem.
But it's a problem with people take those
fish like goldfish and they released
[inaudible] lake.
Well,
all kinds of fish.
Cold fish alone.
He released him in the lake and
they're an invasive species.
They fucked with the whole ecosystem.
Uh,
Asian carp,
a lot of that.
There's a lot of different fish that
somehow or another through either people
releasing them like they had them.
They like snake heads.
Like people have let snakehead fish,
they'll take it,
they'll kill every fish in a fucking
lake to say that from snake heads and
they'll come after you
make it a bite trade.
It will climb on land and bites.
You can walk across the land naked for me.
A snake had a snake.
It.
What are we talking about?
Africa and people will lose to keep
them as pets because they're cool.
And what they would do is
these fucking fish you,
they would get sick of them so they
would let them know their mom's sister
Jamie.
They're monsters.
They're dinosaurs.
Walk on land.
Well you understand,
but again,
showing big too.
They get Jesus Christ.
Wait,
wait,
I'm going to affect your Barracuda Samey.
Pull up snake head in the Congo,
walks on,
land in the video,
hold up.
Those things walk on like one.
They walked from one pond to
another pond across the grounds.
Things are awesome.
Like they come out of
the water and they walk.
They're not very popular though,
Huh?
Oh,
they're monsters.
This is a snake head.
Uh,
in Thailand.
Okay.
Here this is,
I dunno if this is a Bandanna on him.
No,
this is not it.
Jamie.
This is,
um,
we want to see the one Congo,
cause this thing,
this is what he caught.
I don't think it's going
to show it walking.
Maybe snakehead fish walking.
Are they dangerous at all?
I don't think so.
I mean not to.
They're not dangerous.
We mean they'll probably,
I need something to attack,
but the really big ones you
have to worry about the Congo.
Remember those spiders
that attacking swarms?
Yeah,
it's different.
They usually solitary in the states,
but in the Congo they
fucking swarmy spiders swarm.
They make these giant animals,
not people.
They're not people.
Yeah,
they catch like squirrels and shit.
Spiders too.
It's nice.
I've seen the ones that are
big enough to catch birds,
but I don't,
I don't know.
I love acute squirrel though.
But it's worse than fucking
spider swarming on Ya.
Yeah.
Jamie gets look at for it in
the Congo because this is not,
it's a BBC documentary and the Congo.
Maybe.
Maybe it's not exactly listed as naked.
Maybe I was saying the wrong name,
but I know snake.
It is a similar fish.
That's these vase of species from
other countries that just takes over.
It sounds trying to one up each other.
Calculus walking on the land.
Look at this.
Look at this thing.
Walking on the land.
They're walking until they find another,
another lake.
Well,
unless they're eating people.
Um,
these are little ones.
Bite the fuck out of you.
I know that.
She shame to up on that
fucking it's crazy.
Now here's,
here's where you find it.
Um,
shoe bill shoe.
Bill bird eats snakehead
fish in the Congo.
Shoe Hill bird eats a prehistoric fish.
Who's the craziest Shit
we get as a shoe heel?
Shoe Bill.
Shoe bills five feet tall and has a,
has a beak that's about
the size of my torso.
Is Zhao a tactic?
Hatch it grown out of.
It's taped back though.
It looks evil as fuck.
That's a shoe bill.
Look at that thing.
It's smaller than the ones that
that do with Tera Byrd and shit.
Yeah.
Small on a terror birds
by like a couple of feet,
but there's still five feet fucking tall.
Like you don't get a sense of
perspective it looks like in this photo.
Yeah.
But if you were standing next to it,
you'd get a sense of perspective.
You would be terrified by the thing.
Cause imagine standing next to that thing
and you're only a foot taller than it.
You'd be shitting your pants I think is
monstrous is that's the thing we saw in
that Congo.
Exactly.
That's the same as the same document.
Ostriches are fucking huge,
right?
Oh yeah.
But they don't have the creepy eyes of
these things have and they have small
faces.
They'll fuck you up though.
Don't they kick you or some shit they get,
the thing is that's a fat ass duck.
Every one of my nightmares right there,
this giant bird,
this thing walks through the swamp and
then it's going to Jack a shoe bill.
I mean a snake has ashes
that bridge my size.
Yeah,
it's a big ass.
But it's the size of me.
Am I?
I think they only UAE
like 50 or 60 pounds.
Get down with that,
but that's a five foot bird,
man.
I'd fucking run.
Is it really five foot?
Yeah.
The other big ones they
can get five foot Syrian.
Find another better.
See,
uh,
see if you find a shoe
build brand in the Congo.
That thing?
Yeah.
Look,
it's eating that fish hole.
It's a little dinosaur
dinosaur alpha main event.
Cowboy versus cowboy cowboy tog o down.
Cowboy cried.
This cowboy looks really calm.
I kind of pissing,
can't they say super relaxed cause
the shitty went through in Brazil.
Fine to him.
Just fun.
You don't get the same nerves.
Oh Wow.
What'd he go?
Chambers.
Not sure.
He grew up really poor on a farm boy.
Really powerful him.
Yeah.
He looks for super relaxed.
The whole,
the whole montage.
Before this was just them
trying to out cowboy each other.
Like who's more cowboy?
Did you see it?
A student house showed cowboy on her
and showed him on a Brazilian ranch.
That's funny.
Well,
it's a good move for the Turkey.
The two best cowboys in the world.
American and Brazilian cowboy.
There's a lot of cowboys in Brazil.
I don't feel as that.
I just shut up.
I would like to see him.
I want to see a good
fight or get a real camp,
you know?
I don't like anybody
fighting on two weeks notice.
He's dangerous.
Serone though.
Yeah,
he's super dangerous.
Oh,
here,
look at this.
Hugging people.
The guy that's going to come
on [inaudible] the fuck is
taking selfies before he
fights.
Yeah.
Happy as man.
Okay.
I'll tell you know he's going to do so.
And this is your pleasure.
Wow.
This can be fun.
Hell yeah.
I can't wait for the lax dancing.
No.
Damn.
He must take this as
his time looking at him.
He looks so no pressure on him.
Look how relaxed he is.
Pumped those hip.
Yeah,
it was,
what is the,
what is the ass?
No,
what is that?
What they call the Buddha?
Buddha.
That's it.
What's the word for no
for but and Portuguese.
Belinda.
Belinda Boone is at the dance where
they fucking put that all I know.
Is that right?
And Ha ha ha.
You've seen chicks do that,
right?
I Guy,
I'll sit down and boy,
that's her legs around him and fucking,
yeah,
I quit.
No one seen that.
I'm not doing this then that
it's like enough for me.
It's like a Jeff Glover dock yard.
Yeah,
she jumps back card there.
Works ass.
Oh my God.
That'll break your nose,
son.
Look at this.
He's just an asshole and she's sham
and in his nose in her asshole.
What UFC fight was it when you,
uh,
cloud donkey guard.
Bam.
It was like years ago.
Eight years ago.
Remember that this position
is what we call donkey guard.
This,
this girl is hurting
his face with her ass.
That's not sexy.
That's cool.
But when she was ramming,
that goes into that asshole,
that ain't for me.
Yeah.
How do you think this relationship ends?
Do you think she feels like
connected to him after this bride?
He 100.
Got It.
Say got his dick sucked down.
Do you think he's got a chance
to fuck her because of this?
Or is there some Mexico or
somewhere where it's hot?
Brazil?
No,
AC.
There's something wrong with it.
I see.
Oh,
they're singing to this
a whole performance.
I guarantee that the song is
probably not your favorite.
Yeah.
Old Man's about to blow
his fucking neck down.
They're going to fucking,
oh shit.
See how she spins?
Oh Shit.
God.
I have a problem with that.
Oh,
that's what I have a problem with.
Not For me,
but how would they stop the dance?
I'm paying the drama
religious outfit like Eric,
he's a clarifier is doing the checkout
there in Brazil now it looks more like
Pakistan
or something.
No,
no,
no.
This might be to buy.
This would definitely happy.
Definitely not happening.
Fucking Africa.
Oh look at him.
He screams.
What's up with the guys that like getting
kneed in the balls by checks ended.
They paid for,
they paid for that.
Have you ever watched it?
She sent me a funny graphic of that.
The other horrible,
I just got sent a die in
a group message about,
it's all smashed point.
It's point of view.
So it's a guy sitting there and he's
videotaping his legs open and he has two
major,
it's in little outfits run up and
started kicking him and stomping on him.
Eddie,
that thing you sent me today,
the ultimate sack fighting thing.
That's so crazy.
They did exactly what he did it twice,
twice college humor that two of
our schedules are Matt Mantra.
There must be a writer for car
that worked for the man show.
There has to be because they did
extreme sack planning when they heard us
talking about it and the
Jesus a cross trainer.
Okay.
But it is possible that someone
came up with it on their own.
It is totally possible.
You guys talked about
on and talked about it.
I've talked about on my podcast
when,
how long ago?
Like a couple of fighting,
you know we talked about
I think on mine too,
like way back in the day.
I think we're talking about different
sketches that we did that where we did,
cause we had to have Bobby Lee and
Joey Diaz and Joey Diaz kept losing.
His balls are too big.
Yeah.
So he became a trainer,
Bobby Lee one we were going to give
him some fig balls are like that big.
Bobby Lou was the master and
it would go and visit him.
He was like,
he's on an island somewhere and
teach you how to sacrifice correctly.
It's funny,
you just couldn't touch his nuts.
There were so small future of MMA.
Eventually,
eventually state by state are going to
legalize ball hitting when the balls are
in play came changes.
We had a whole fucking
made it.
I don't know if the be I,
am I giving them the benefit of the doubt.
That's what I do from now on.
I don't know man.
We know when people are bullshit
artist and rip off artists,
but it just,
it always comes to surface.
You know that thing,
the Internet,
it's kind of a,
it's going to get,
you know these guys,
it could've easily been that they came
up with on their own or it could have
been like,
these guys had great ideas.
They didn't even do it,
so fuck them and there
may have been a podcast.
There may have been a podcast where I
went through all our sketches that got,
uh,
turned down
and I talked about them.
And I think once or twice I may have said,
you know what,
if someone out there wants to run with it,
run with it and you fuck up
nobody,
you're not feeling well.
You would never get away
with it any way so far.
It'd be hard to prove.
That was never even a thought.
I'm just saying that that was our shit.
Yeah,
because if you,
12 years ago,
if you come up with an idea but
you don't do anything about,
and you talk about the idea and then
someone else does something with it,
that's so much different than you
having already done the sketch and then
someone ripping off the sketch.
True.
Completely beam wild.
This shit's about to go down.
I'm excited for this fight.
Cowboys.
I'm uh,
I'm excited to see,
how do you think going to fight at one
70?
Good man.
No weight cut.
I think it's gas can be better.
He's a motherfucker.
It's just how to,
how does Donald feel after that loss is
the x factor after getting dismantled by
dos Anjos could point.
How's he?
How's he gonna respond and
he's fighting a bigger person.
When?
When is someone usually taller than
him and ed is 55 never at 55 this guy's
taller.
Has a longer reach.
Loves to stand.
It looks good though.
[inaudible] hands.
It's all looks.
He looks way better.
Yeah.
It looks thick to hit.
Donald's a huge 55 are men.
Why think he's had issues in the past too?
This is the first time.
Is that crazy shredded?
It looks good to me,
man.
He looks really good to me.
I mean,
it's not crazy shredded.
It's healthy.
Shredded.
Yeah.
It's different.
It's like there's a level
of shredded where you go,
man,
this guy might be a little bit too lean.
LNG bond.
Good or not all the time.
Different League.
How did your mom,
how would you rate him?
No.
Alan Dumont another to another level.
We got.off five thousands on one hand.
No.
Bocky Bono occupied it all on
one hand and then prime cowboy,
like who's the leanness guy ever?
The fought in MMA,
the leanest guy ever.
What do you mean the most?
Running
a Gleason.
See Bow.
Yeah,
probably.
No,
he's come on.
He was,
we'd walk around a one 95 and
fight a 55 Anthony Anthony Johnson.
Yeah,
you got a point.
You got to a point.
That might be it.
But here we go.
Look at this.
Oh,
looking for the writing.
What you got to do to beat cal,
but you got to really turn it on early.
Man,
can we takes a while to warm up.
Cowboy is a guide that
recovers very well from a loss,
but already we're seeing,
we're already seeing a big
difference in physical strengths.
He's on on him.
I see him that early.
That's not a fluke.
There's something to say about that man.
Big Ones.
Messi.
Gas is out.
We're going to see a lot of this.
It just,
he puts him against the
fence pretty easily.
I mean Donald's,
I'm you.
So you,
so you see in Donald,
just a bigger,
taller dude.
I'm never,
this is interesting,
man.
Oh,
that's a hard one.
Why?
There's been classes,
you know,
these are hard knees to the body,
man.
You can't take too many of these.
Oh,
that looked like it hurt him.
That looked like a always Gracie.
Nene
gone from now on.
It's Gracie needs.
Oh Shit.
Another need of the body.
Oh Duh.
If Donald gets them going backwards,
homeboys fucked with Brazilian cowboys.
Football.
Telegraph.
When this,
come on.
Where's his hips are like Bruce Lee.
Okay.
Tony's haircuts.
Interesting.
Ooh.
Ooh God.
He is winging them.
Your Dad's got to drag this
guy and some deeper water.
Huh?
Ooh Dude.
He's just way bigger.
Donald's in shaping this
tits face that hurt.
He's fading a little bit.
Took a big deep breath right there.
Yeah,
he's fading a little dude.
If I'm Brazilian them
just do it bro.
Well,
you only got two rounds Max.
Yeah,
but what if he goes after him hearing
gasses himself out with a minute left?
He might not be able to make it.
Well,
you're going to get your ass whooped.
Do we really have no way.
Oh,
we really have no idea
what kind of conditioning.
Yes.
Right.
Oh,
they go cowboys.
Jiu Jitsu is very underrated,
man.
Mother fight there could be over right.
It could be over just right with that.
With that.
It can be homer.
Just don't,
don't remove your head from
the ground and inch by inch.
Set that up.
It's so hard to find out when a guy
is coming in on two weeks notice.
So hard to find out what he'd been
doing before we got there and call
Oh good control by cal hood mount.
Look at Oh
fuck.
Holy Triangle to fuck you.
Try go them enrolled them over.
That was some serious Jujitsu man.
I'm telling you is just
is underrated dude.
That was some shit.
That being said,
I don't like copy at one
70 after seeing that.
What are you talking about?
Don't know.
I don't.
Why not?
Because I think he got out muscled.
I think uh,
if he fought the topper echelon guys,
he gets stronger.
He can get stronger.
Yeah.
Man,
I think he won.
This is,
he did for sure,
but he would.
He did.
You're right.
He did get thrown around,
but I think he could fix that.
Brendan is a glass is
half empty sort of Fella
wins a beautiful fucking triangle victory.
I don't like him at one
seven now he's my boy.
He can't take them down.
He's not strong enough.
Strong shoes.
Shit so strong.
She was it.
So look at this uh,
recovery here too.
I like this man cause Alex [inaudible],
he steps right over into the
triangle that is fucking beautiful.
Instead of [inaudible] so
quick and [inaudible] happened,
that must be all clamping
lockdown of a triangle.
Like look at this super nasty look
how it gets it over the ankle.
Nice looking at that quick
and he held it and he's like,
come on son.
Stopped that Mario.
Who's that Mario?
I didn't know who it was.
That was a quick triangle.
There was no,
there was no fight.
There was no struggle.
There was a lot of good it did.
Yeah,
there's things he'd get a win too.
He just tapped it.
That's beautiful.
Cowboy such a star,
you know,
people love that dude.
He needed to.
When his happened,
he did a real nice guy.
I would just like to have seen
Oliveira with a real camp.
It's like when you see
a real talented guy,
guy like that,
it's nice to come in and step in on
two weeks notice and no loss for him.
I would like to see him in a camp who
Tyron Woodley suit Woodley on on this
show.
I've never watched them as the analyst.
He's a beast man.
He's very,
very good.
They won't let you on that show anymore.
Is that what I hear?
I don't think so.
They never asked me,
so talk a little too much shit.
Joe.
Would you want to do it again?
Fuck yeah.
You'd be great at that Shit.
I can't.
I can't fight for very much
longer with all the shit I think.
I don't know.
We'll see.
I'm going to keep trying
and that braindead yet,
but my body sucks.
Yeah,
but you're a good analyst.
You're very good at breaking
down fights to Smartsheet.
I would love to do it somewhere.
I've seen him fucking sneaky in there.
I think I have a creepy with it.
And they said no.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't know.
It's tough.
It's a tough rotation,
Joe,
to get in there
trying to get in because they should have
more than one of those fucking things.
The only have one.
What do you mean gang of these UFC
shows with a bunch of different people
running them.
Just like podcasts.
Let people figure out what they like.
You can have a hundred
of those fucking things.
Well Ian,
do you have a podcast?
No,
not really.
I mean I stopped waiting for fuck's pull
their head up their ass and get your
own shit.
Totally do a podcast.
And if you did a podcast
like just break uncle creepy.
He's having Mapix just a week of creepy.
MMM.
That's it.
You could get it ready for the alumni
of the fights and you can talk mad shit.
You can suck on your vaporizer.
You do it all on youtube.
I,
especially if you're,
if you really feel like
your body's telling you,
hey,
this is the last go round,
get ready for something new
and that's a good way to do it.
And that way you could use
the vape pen and you're like,
well you didn't do it.
You can task me.
We need to do tell me I
can't do this anymore.
I'm not doing it anymore anyway.
Yeah.
So you know,
but because other all do something,
I mean I'll,
I'll figure it out.
I don't because I'm,
I'm just saying that doing
it through Fox or something,
you got to get sanctioned if you're going
to do it through a production company
or any of those.
And it's hard.
Bunch of steps.
Yeah.
Hard.
You know,
big brown has been through the hoops.
It's hard.
I know what it is,
is I've had a lot of people promise me
they're going to help me do it and help
me figure it out.
Cause I'm kind of retarded
when the podcasts,
uh,
with podcasts and all that chef.
And then it just never happened.
And I guess I'm too lazy on my own,
so I haven't done it.
But now,
now it's getting to you.
You can't be lazy.
You got to make sure.
Well,
I mean it's now it's getting
the point where I have to,
I don't have a choice.
You gotta make it happen
and you can do it.
You got a great personality.
Talk a lot of shit.
You've been in the cage,
you've gone super fucking crazy matches,
dude.
Personality.
You got it.
Got another idea.
You want to,
yeah.
I mean if you've got
something else that you're,
you're thinking no.
What it means great personality and
outside of MMA you have great opinions on
all kinds of shit.
Like you could talk shit about everything,
you know,
and Bra and Brendan and Brian and I
and Eddie and all of us are proven.
You don't have to be an expert
and things talk about them.
We've talked about everything from
fucking genetics to rocket traveling 11
inside job or not.
I want an inside job.
Know about nine 11 inside job
and she's just don't do it.
Don't do it.
I don't know,
man.
Don't answer that.
You're already smart.
Get Eddie another beer
real quick.
Real quick.
Chemtrails?
Yes or no?
Vaccine.
A killer or an aid.
How many,
how many towers went down
on nine 11 oh my God.
I know.
He knows my brothers crazy
like you are signing.
Oh Shit.
Donald Serone very happy.
The fact that he knows the three towers
went down means that you kind of know.
She knows.
No.
Most people don't know.
They'll say to most people don't know.
Most people do not know three times where
they'll get Jamie trying to save the
show,
but turn it up.
Donald's interview.
Where'd it go in the background starts
showing towers falling that you press gel
like underneath the table.
I turned to shit.
Puts Chem gels on in the background.
That's a plant.
That's a southwest.
Right?
Then
Kelly's such a fucking beast.
That's a strong,
strong,
he's supposed to pay.
Who you supposed to fight?
The dirty bird to me and to
means test positive to this day.
Denies you to get anything wrong
and said he took us up on that.
Has anybody ever said,
okay fuck.
I was trying to get a joke.
I regret it.
Here's what I was going to say.
They use side of people tell us that
everything be all that shit that you're
buying and fucking GNC.
Everything is suspect.
They have a list on the EU side
of page where you should go.
I've read it buddy that's thinking about
competing in anything where they get
tested.
Go to that list.
It's insane.
If you're buying like Tesoro
testosterone boosters from GNC,
yeah,
you idiot.
But Dude,
I've been taking someone's all my life,
I've been tested all my life but he
never been tested under the of like
guidelines.
NCAA.
I got tested the other day.
I mean like a motherfucker.
The only thing I haven't taken on and
stuff and I was doing Danna Danieli below
Billy's podcasts
and then outlet on it by the way.
They called me and like,
Hey,
where are you in la?
Like,
Whoa,
we went by your house.
You're not there.
I'm like,
yeah man,
La went by your gym.
You're not there.
I'm like,
yes,
I'm in La.
Here's my address.
Meet me here or so after you have
to drop whatever you're doing,
what have you had like tickets
to the most awesome show.
Like you're going to go to a play or
something like that with your lady you're
at,
how long does it take to do this?
They had,
once they contact you and
has to be within an hour,
so they drove.
I was literally parking.
That's so annoying.
And they,
I know it's so,
why don't you dig holes?
Meet me at like six o'clock in
the morning when I'm waking up.
If you don't show,
if you tell him if you
don't make it happen,
positive test or you get three straps
that having a cowboy cowboy was in fucking
Vegas for the UFC.
They showed up at his ranch.
She's like,
where are you at?
Is I'm in Vegas.
You have to tell us how
you see for the UFC.
I'm in Vegas.
And they gave him like
a failure to notify,
you know,
fuck off,
fuck off and bunch of squares,
man.
I got one of those for
not filling out my app.
Am I gonna get in trouble for it?
I'm talking about this.
Um,
I don't care.
but for not filling out
my whereabouts in time.
And they sent me a letter and I was like,
Dad,
look,
cause like it's like the fucking principal
sent me a letter not figuring out,
well,
you know it alls with good intentions.
They're trying to catch more people.
I think it's good,
but a lot of people,
which
is pretty fucking funny.
It's a lot of people will find the same.
If it was up to you with what,
uh,
would you legalize a pds
because it's up to you.
That's a slippery slope.
Tough fucking slope.
They illegal.
I mean it was legal and pride.
Look what happened.
What's going to happen?
Well,
pride would happen.
It's tough man.
Think Joe,
it won't be,
it won't be mainstream if you do that.
I think there's a better name.
I,
here's the problem.
What we're trying to do is stop progress.
The reason why steroids are awesome,
it's because they work really
good at changing your body,
making you perform better.
Ultimately we,
we're watching fighting.
What are we trying to say?
We try to see people
perform at their best,
so we're keeping them from the
knowledge that we're currently aware of.
What do we currently aware of
when it comes to performing hands?
Drugs.
If you use them,
your body will work better.
Your body will be stronger.
It'll move quickly.
You have more endurance.
You'll be able to perform tasks with much
more veracity and intensity for longer
periods of time,
so how can they can't do it because the,
because using that knowledge
right now is forbidden,
but it's going to come a point in time,
whether it's a year from
now or 20 years from now,
30 years from now,
where they're going to have some
undeniable shit is everybody's taking that
people would just normally taking
because it keeps you from getting sick.
It changes the way your body works.
Your body,
like a regular person's
body looks like Yoel Romero,
his body,
we're all going to take it,
but then,
but then all athletes
would be taking it then.
Then it's going to get real,
super weird.
It's like,
well what happened all those years when
you couldn't take it or you had a high
that you were taking it
because now they're going to
have stuff that makes you,
there's not going to be people anymore.
We're going to come a time when 30 or
40 years where genetic engineering has
reached a point where we're,
we're engineering human bad.
I want to be around.
You got to have a designer.
Why it's going to be awesome.
I'm going to be the Hawk fuck off.
I'm going to jump over.
You're going to be 110 we're all going
to be 110 but you're going to be 110 with
the science that comes
from surviving till then.
They say that if you can live,
if you can live today,
if you're like a 30 year old guy today
and you could live to be 50 you could
probably live to be 200 fuck off.
For reals.
Yes,
I've heard all day.
They're talking about within our lifetime,
some ground breaking life,
changing shit in life
extension and how long you can,
how long have you live and
how healthy you can be.
That guy,
that doctor Peter Welling,
whenever his name is,
the Regena Cain doctor,
they're that close to some new thing.
They're going to do it with college
and I don't know how it works,
but apparently the breakthrough,
if they can prove what they believe they
can prove and then do what they think
they can do,
they're gonna be able
to regenerate college.
And people like what makes someone an
old person is your college and sort of
falls apart.
Your face consult droopy,
you lose the elasticity.
Well they going to be a little regenerate
chicken glass half full with this
fucking Guy Joe.
How full or am I a real list you don't
have to pull is half full is actually
meaning.
Gotcha.
Okay,
I was joking.
Gotcha.
But you,
I actually said it wrong.
I meant to say they did empty,
but
that is what you're doing
is trying to help you.
Brendan isn't,
you're going to,
you're going to have to accept science.
Brian did Chubb,
I'm not saying that,
I'm not saying
if you were a kid and you got polio,
you know,
back in the day it was over and then
they had to come up with the vaccines and
then all of a sudden no polio.
I mean the all,
there's the thing about all the different
things that they figured out today.
He used to break your leg three,
400 years ago.
You're fucked now.
You break your leg,
they fucking screw some plates in that
big stitch y'all up and you're good to
go.
Yep.
They mean uncle creepys had
how many fucking surgeries.
Think about that.
All this stuff that you had done to you.
If you live 500 years ago,
you'd be dead man.
I'd be,
fuck yeah,
it'd be dead and I would be too.
And you'd be all fucked up and
when you would be fucked up,
cause you've ever heard of nobody.
I don't know about the hernia surgery.
Could to be alive.
Yeah,
but you'd be fine.
But you'd have like a
big holes where you're,
I mean,
they've figured it out,
her use her screaming and yelling and
I wouldn't be screaming and yelling and
you don't know 17 id,
you might,
you would definitely be screaming,
yelling,
don't hate me running Zombie hordes.
But my point is that they,
these guys are going to keep innovating.
Every new invention opens a
door for other new inventions.
Every new technology opens the door for
a whole branch of new technologies that
would come from it.
And so they're,
they're on their way to figuring
out how to regenerate tissue.
The stem cell shit that
they're doing today,
you know,
I mean,
they're doing some,
really,
it's at boss ruin was telling me
about how they shot stem cells in them
intravenously.
If that's the they with me.
Oh really brilliant.
Intervenient stem cell
and then spot injection.
Where did they get the stem cells?
Are you sure it wasn't PRP?
I was both know,
but I,
I've had both of them that the stem cells
is stem cells and they are doing stem
cells.
Now.
The one that I did with in Vegas was
from a woman's placenta from young women
that gets a Syrian sections.
He took the placenta and
they converted stem cells.
Yeah.
What did it,
what did it feel like when
they shot at intravenously?
I didn't feel anything.
Nothing.
I was sitting there and you know,
we got it done and kind of work.
Did you feel like amazing?
Well I mean it's all,
it's all here,
but my,
my shoulder's healed up the shore.
I'm still smaller than this one.
It just keeps coming out of socket.
No,
no,
no.
I had torn all,
all four of the parts,
you know,
and now it's this thing just pop like I
thought I felt the pop it down here and
like the muscle tendon had
nothing to do with the,
Oh will.
I tore down here a little bit when I
tore my shoulder and now this is kind of
where it popped so chore again.
So there's issues with the whole chain.
Yeah,
just the tool chain that
I've been fighting with one
arm for one hand at least
for a couple of years doing work though.
If one arm or punch him
people with this thing sucks.
Yeah.
God Damn,
you can't make a fist to fist.
No,
no.
The one finger.
That's incredible.
Good fire at that point that,
that operated on it.
You better get on that.
Cool.
Oh yeah.
I've had my hand up or broken twice.
Three operations and then a one bad
Murcia infection that was far as the scary
shit.
Huh?
Having mercy.
Cause you know,
I ended up in Brazil with a blood
infection and I don't think,
I don't know if it's mercy or not,
but it was in my blood.
Oh my God.
This infectious still remember when I
went to fight Lineker the first time and
I'd be made Wayne's,
I walked into the happen,
I walked in the back and I took one
bite of fruit and then just walk and uh,
and uh,
you know Isabella grow the role.
Yeah.
The girl that runs the shows down there,
uh,
probably met know about fees,
but she,
she was just like,
oh everyone get definitely get out.
Everyone went out and they
just write it right there.
Hooked me up with diabetes.
And so did the,
what kind of blood infection was it?
They say,
I don't,
I didn't ask.
How about Danny's me?
Ooh,
Ooh God.
Nobody knew Danny.
He did a,
the last Ebi Ebi five.
He looked good at to have a good,
but he didn't train at all for that.
Nobody knew.
No,
he wasn't going to do it.
He was,
he had Murcia inside
his needs training camp.
I didn't want him to
tell people who it was,
but I put it the picture of
his knee up on my Instagram.
But I'm seeing her fight at
Jamie's from a few months ago.
He was,
he was right in the middle
of Ebi five training camp.
And I gave him,
I said,
you know what,
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna pull you.
And he goes,
you're not like,
let's wait until two weeks before the
show and we'll see where we're at.
And that two week mark,
that's when he started,
he was able to roll light.
So we're like,
you want to go for it?
You want it.
There was so many times where
it was 100% that he was out,
but I wouldn't,
I just said,
let's wait.
Let's see what happens.
Those fucking pictures of his knee,
but no one knew the fuck that was.
No,
I didn't say who it was.
I put the pictures up on Instagram
because I wanted to alert people to the
dangers of staph infection.
Cause a lot of Jujitsu places,
they don't tell people about staff.
And so you get like a,
a bump on your knee and you don't know
what the fuck it is and then it gets
worse and then you don't,
you ignore it and then it gets
to the point where it's systemic.
If you think you have a pimple or a
spider bite and you keep itching something
and it keeps getting bigger,
bigger and bigger,
you might have staff,
you might have mercy if you'd think there
was a spider bite on you on your leg
or your arm or a pimple
that just got infected,
run to the,
that's what I,
Debbie could a tired,
I thought it was a
spider bite in my armpit.
I was wrestling and uh,
I sent a picture of my coach
is a big ass thing and I go,
hey man,
I think a spider bite.
And he goes,
have you been to fucking Africa lately?
What spider would do that?
That staff,
it was like huge to white
bubbles and my armpit.
Where'd you go?
Africa.
Where
the first time I had it was in my knee.
You fucking,
a decade ago.
You're right.
When Marissa first came out and
Mike Gaiman hat and he goes,
Hey,
get to the hospital.
That's Danny's me.
That was,
that was like three weeks before Ebi.
What a Badass.
He did him.
That's fine.
I just had to put that up there.
That's
Danny pro.
Coppos Nice.
Such a nice guy.
Look at that guy in the
hospital for a week.
He was in the hospital for a week.
They had a suction machine
on his knee all day,
everyday and machine.
It's sucked shit
out of the men.
His knee.
That's a bummer.
Yeah.
I think Joe Briggs went
down from my broken arm.
Yeah.
He went down immediately,
grabbed his arm.
When he went down,
he tried to block in the knee with his,
he blocked the form ruthless Kamozi knees.
I think he might've broken
arm the man good for him.
Kenny's Vac can you from the
first time Kennedy's back?
Yeah.
That whole situation.
I'm,
I'm glad he didn't completely lose his
job because it's not like Kenny doesn't
know a lot about MMA,
but you got to give credit
where credit's deserved.
Yeah,
you can't do that and now he will
know and they'll never do it again.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a failure.
I'm a fan of a guy
getting a second chance.
Four five,
six.
Oh my God.
Six card,
full power.
Many times boys hit,
uh,
Ken shamrock fits in the side of the face.
I just see,
I think first of all,
Ken needs a fucking diamond MMA cop.
You know,
he needs one of them.
Compression cuffs.
I wish we had gotten them.
And you know,
when,
when they say they say wrestlers,
no matter what the strategy is.
Like,
if a restaurant wants to stand standing,
you know his strategy is the standard
bag that people say that when,
when the chaos sets in,
wrestlers revert to the wrestling and in
the chaos they going to show what they
know they're going to shoot.
Right.
I swear I think Ken reverts
to pro wrestling or something.
It just,
how many times I get the shit,
the soccer rabo fi he goes down,
he's complaining,
he's always there.
There's always some kind of complaint at
the end that's like wrestling and shit
to me and know what they
do in pro wrestling.
Wow.
That's like he's
reverting to that showman.
Yeah he's reverting to that showman ism.
Cause Cause I've seen guys get kicked
in the nuts horribly and they didn't.
You know what I'm saying?
What about that deliberately
stopped but not the delay was
did he get hit in the nuts and
he's like this is my way out.
I'm not making that happen.
But that's an option.
I didn't think that at all.
And
I thought well add to see the replay to
see that he got kicked in the nuts cause
Jimmy Smith's seemed to be incredulous.
At first he was saying that it was a
shot to the head and then maybe can have
gotten knocked out.
Maybe in thought he got hit
in the nuts or something.
But when they showed it again they
went one step before you see it.
It's clear.
Definitely it goes right to the
nuts and the way he's adjusting it.
That sounds to me like you
didn't have a good cup.
You know if you have a tie steel cup or
if you have a real good like a diamond
and make compression shorts cup,
it wouldn't affect you that bad cause
it wasn't like Melvin Manhoef was neat.
I mean you know what I'm saying
and and exactly.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm just saying I've seen horse
nut shots where guys are like,
Damn Bro.
I'm like hold up,
hold up five minutes.
He's 52 50 those nuts hang low.
Might've been real bad.
I'm not saying actually I'm under the cup.
They were hanging on the outside
the ball and there's a five second delay.
Really.
He's always is a way that was an odd,
no,
that's not odd.
But if you don't think that was on,
I believe you guys,
you guys are the second why
is the delay is automatic.
Yeah.
Why is that?
I don't know.
The brains and the main,
when a guy gets hit in the
balls and there's a break,
it's the hit in the
balls and he goes boom.
In the break there's
never a hit in the balls.
You know what I'm saying?
Watch it again to see that in
heaven when you watch it again.
Let's take a look at it
again cause this is kind of,
it's kind of a crazy delay as long.
Yeah.
We never see that you,
you get hit in the balls.
The guy goes,
okay,
Eddie has good point.
We never seen a 50 year
old get hit in the nuts.
Boom and they're exchanging
and hoists hit.
I'm good on the Chin though.
The one that Shannon
was good to take downs.
Good Hammer fist is good.
Oh wait a minute.
Now from that angle.
Maybe he was hoping his calls this.
He was definitely,
he was holding his ball,
but that's a legit knocked down
and the need of the faces legit.
The knee is before.
See,
this is what you're talking about.
This seems kind of acted out.
Wait a minute,
Paul shine,
but watch this right to the chin.
Watch how long it takes.
Okay,
we need to see the whole thing.
Show the need of the chin.
He did take them down.
Now that I see it did look like he
was complaining about the balls.
Once the fight got to the ground.
Go way back Jamie.
I'm starting to look.
It's going to be over.
You're going to try and sell it.
Watch it here.
Watching her.
But why would he think it was over?
Just cause it got taken down here.
We're going to watch the whole fight.
Here it goes.
Okay,
where's the ball shot?
Right there.
Boom.
That was it.
And they have long balls and
that's the one on the chin.
The right knee holding
his balls as he hurt.
Right.
He's holding his well from the face shot.
Well,
he definitely got dropped face
hitting the depth of nuts and face,
but he did yell and say,
you hit me in the balls.
There should be a rematch then.
Oh No,
we got to it.
I like sad and Kimball enough controversy
in this to have an immediate rematch.
Let's run it back a go fund me this for
everybody donates a dollar to make sure
we're never does this again.
I'll text rates show tonight after this.
And Ken was a he.
He sort of recovered his composure
against 50 year olds fighting you.
You guys have something against that.
What's wrong with it?
As long as they're both 50 I
don't have a problem with it.
I don't enjoy it the same age where you
know you're not dealing with 55 year
olds out there,
but yeah,
but 55 was the shit.
I'm not watching.
I want to see Chuck Norris
at 55 fight and rumble.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't see 55 year olds fight,
man.
I'm not going to go up a t and why not?
It's very reasonable.
Very reasonable.
Especially true legends.
I can remember him as the legends.
I don't like seeing six
year old fights either.
No,
me neither,
bro.
What am I doing?
Taekwondo Kid's head kicking each other.
I don't see that that counts.
I don't let my,
I run a kids program at a Yamas.
Yeah.
I don't let them spark like I don't want
to see Larry Bird's part of the body to
the body.
Kind of touch out of that and play
like Taika is and was touched.
But Tyrone Woodley.
What a strong beard game.
No respect for that bit again.
Oregon's,
he's in a weird spot,
Huh?
What lives in a weird spot in the know?
He deserves a title shot sort of,
but no one wants to out shined him.
Oh my God.
Daily.
So now everyone's demand in one
or boy and the way the UFC works.
Yeah,
but I think weirdly still in
the title shot is he will,
if it's going to go Rory,
and it might not,
I'm not saying it is,
but let's say they do Rory first.
Wonderboy Woodley would
have to get the title shot.
Yes.
Or Don.
Don.
Don Don.
Don Connor wins quick against
Osan Joseph and says Robby.
Laura,
if could any fucking Pete trumps
trumps then that's the fight.
We're all fucked because that's the fight.
If he beats though,
Sign Joseph challenges
lower th the world ends.
Yeah.
No one watches anything.
Everything goes down.
Every show on television says we're
just going to take the night off.
There's no need for
anything other than this.
And we would throw some children's shows
on Nickelodeon and have to have it on
the moon.
Richard Branson,
motherfuckers,
every channel,
whenever he runs on Gilligan's island,
if he,
if so,
if he beat Dos Anjos and then he beats
Robbie Lawler's either greatest fighter
of all time.
If he beats those [inaudible] he's in
the running to be the greatest hour.
Of course he's in the running,
you know,
look,
I say the greatest ever.
A little bit too liberally.
I'll,
I'll be honest.
I know I do,
but it's tough to find a guy who's
even close to as exciting in what he's
attempting to accomplishment.
[inaudible] attempt to accomplish.
It's easy when you go back like
after the dust has settled and say,
wow,
you know,
you gotta look at Fader or like
fate or was the greatest ever?
Yes.
He was one of the greatest
ever at that time for sure.
I think Anderson move,
if I look at like movements
and what he's doing,
I think I kind of give the edge to
Anderson but I can see the argument.
But if Connor can beat dos
Anjos and he's starches him,
I don't see any argument,
especially where the level
of the games since ever been,
especially since we have already seen
fate or go down and get knocked the fuck
out a few times.
Same.
They've been gone.
We've already seen them go down.
We haven't seen Conor go down,
so you got to give the
edge to Connor so far.
Sort of.
But we haven't seen Conor fight the
kind of guys that fade or fought in its
prime,
walked down cro,
cop,
remember that?
You know the random in one of
the random one dimensional guy,
a lot of one dimensional guy that's common
is fighting dub trust of the best and
they're all good at everything.
It was just five months.
It was just a different time.
It's just not their fault.
I'm just saying if Connor
were to win three belts,
he's by far the best hands down
Mackenzie dern versus
Paige vanzant right there.
It's a guy who really didn't believe
we're looking at Cody Garbrandt and what's
the guy's name?
Tacchino.
Oh,
Gusto Mendez.
He's just doesn't have the stand up to
stand with a vicious nasty boxer for a
long time.
Yeah.
Garb.
Ranking crack.
Yes.
He's got really good timing.
He's,
he's real confident with
his striking and he's just,
he just outshone.
What do you guys think
of Anderson Silva Bisbee.
Is that next week?
Yup.
Who's in town?
I'm out of town,
unfortunately son.
I'll be here.
How dare you have another.
So wish I didn't,
what day is that?
Saturday.
Yeah.
That's an interesting fight though at
this point and Anderson's life because
he's a happen though.
It depends what Anderson campaigns on
how much Bisbing can get in his head.
Bisbing talks mad shit.
He's already been mocking
them about my background.
I don't know.
Look,
you understand that a hard time
pulling the trigger against Nick Diaz.
I think Bisbing beats him.
Do even a decision.
Wow.
And he started crying after he broke
down crying after and then with all this
shit that's gone on,
I mean you're the,
you know what the x factors here.
Fucking Brisbane's left eye and against
South Palsy gets fucking kicks his right
eye.
It's just right.
I'm sorry.
And get South Palsy eats fucking
left kicks in the left hand.
It could.
That could be a factor for sure factor.
You know another factor it
could be is fighting in England.
He's never lost an English.
So he's an animal in England.
They fucking little love him.
There's very few places where he goes,
where he gets that kind of rhino applause.
When he goes to America,
he gets booed all time.
You know Pete,
don't give him a hard time.
No.
But in England,
man,
I've,
I've called his fights in Manchester.
Whole leash shit to shit.
When he gets out there,
man,
they go fucking bananas.
It's a good fight on bond.
Man knows the law and he's like,
you gotta give that guy his props
because my big bang is fucking,
he is lasting dude.
He's fought everybody.
He's only lost a few guys.
Most are p and he's like,
he doesn't lose his enthusiasm.
It keeps getting better and better.
Little by little,
each fight and his,
his mental toughness.
Unbelievable.
I've never trained with
a new one like him.
When he fights,
he says the bathroom away way.
When he drills,
he's going full speed drilling.
Boom.
Just nonstop,
not moving nonstop.
Crazy card.
It's red.
His cardio is resting.
Heart rate's 34 beats a minute too.
He's like a hummingbird.
I've never seen anything like
incredible wearing guys out.
Just just grilling.
So what do you think it is that it kept
him from beating like all the best guys?
There's just something this,
that it factor.
He got,
you don't have any knockout power.
He's good at everything,
but he's not great road
told me he hits hard.
He said he holds the pad for me cause I
all anybody to tell you this guy doesn't
hit hard.
That's his coach said that
they stopped the fight.
They based it off.
Well yeah the guys he stopped.
He stopped like Lee from like a barrage
of suddenly stopped a fucking Jorge
Rivera.
Jorge,
you're talking about like
Miller striped tail power?
No,
no.
It's just not,
there's just something there.
Not that kind of fighter.
Different kinds of great
meant middleweight domains
don't want to fight that
guy.
He's the best.
He's lost some of the best.
He's an animal as one of the reasons why
it was so impressively Rockhold handled
them.
Ooh Jeez.
One arm GTN ever in the UFC.
I think what set it up that huge,
that head kick.
It's well that his left side is very
powerful and it's so long that you have to
kind of stay in his kicking
range in order to try to close
the distance,
get to punching range and
that left kick is so powerful.
You want to hold that you all pads for
Rockhold when he's throwing that left
kick.
If I'm answering.
Sorry.
Oh Man.
That's what I'm South Pole and
I'm fucking attacking that ride.
I talked to Javier Mendez about
holding pads for Rockhold.
Oh my God.
You were see videos of
him kicking the pads.
He's terrifying his,
it was giving you a fine Luke
lukewarm kicking the type ads to it.
He,
he has so much length and torque.
You know,
like I think the scariest guy
I ever saw kicked the pads.
His manhood man to this day.
Is that a curious guy?
Well,
Pedro Huizar hits back.
I've seen him hit a bag really hard,
but man who is way faster,
more explosive,
but like,
why would you check Rockwell down?
Give me some volume,
fucking power in that leg.
So
he walks you down,
slams that fucking thing
and over and over again.
Third Man,
he kicks very hard.
I got the watch,
Pedro,
Peter [inaudible] and Marco,
who was Jesus.
What does that Rockwell at the Mayweather.
Jim Next,
is that what that said and put that up.
Let me see that.
And Mark Goes,
Jim and the gun and the Gal fucking
over a decade ago and just seeing these
fucking monsters.
I was like a little kid.
They were just geniuses.
How genius is the viral aspect of these
youtube videos where one will show you
the next one in like
the little play thing.
Like it starts spinning.
Like,
why don't you stick around?
Cool.
Check this out.
They have it queued up for you.
It's brilliant.
Rules rock all this fighting
with a barefoot here.
Smart.
Do you ever go and number two we just had,
I don't have nothing to watch,
but I'm gonna go on
Youtube and find something.
Do you ever do that?
He said there's just fucking time.
He's in Mayweather's gym.
I go with their suggestions.
I go to my homepage and they have all the
shits suggested and unluck let's watch
some of the shit.
Very entertaining.
Rockhold showing some
fairly decent boxing.
Oh,
those guys get so much power out of their
shoes to their shoes are so flat and
strong crib.
Yeah,
it definitely helps.
It's not smart to go with shoes all at
ou because I don't ever want to go with
what you got to fight.
You've got to go.
I agree.
Same thing cause side
control with wrestling shoes,
man.
My dry weight,
500 pounds on a guy.
You take the shoes off.
It's a little different.
That's why I was asking
that pressure's gone.
Josh Barnett Fart Huron and showed
up with those wrestling shoes.
Tights and demonstrate same thing.
There's always a cons till
you can get caught up.
It's a lot easier to pull that foot out.
How gangster is he then that
he did it with Dean lister?
Yup.
Nope,
that's Barnett though.
He was like,
dude,
this is what got me to the party.
Check this shit out.
Submitted both of them.
Not only that,
he's dressing like an old carny wrestler.
He had like old
rustling,
not even a speedo.
He had like a high waisted single.
He's single hand.
Can you believe?
Can you believe he got
submitted by Rothwell?
I'm going to to get get submitted.
It doesn't mean it doesn't
diminish him at all.
That's one of the best of all time.
I love that guy.
Especially submission artists.
I can't remember.
Right.
I don't remember shot in,
I don't
remember exactly what the transition was,
but that is apparently Rothwell's shit.
Yeah.
If Rothwell gets a hold of your neck
from that 10 finger gay teen position,
he just tucks that bitch and tight
and chokes the fuck out of you.
I'm saying if you gave
me a hundred justice,
Wilson minimum would not be in the,
I would say the same.
Do you know the grip is using?
What does the grippy sees?
I don't know.
It didn't.
And you have him and you
just have to get a sense.
It's underlined.
Yeah.
Is He,
um,
he's calling it a Gogo choke.
Right?
So what that means to me is that he's
sticking something in your neck because
he's doing it like a Google Plata
where it goes like into your,
your wind pipe.
So I'm thinking he's holding his knock
holes in some way that he's driving and
not to whoever goes to the side with it.
He's wanting to Hickson's black belts.
They called Hixon up the night before.
Apparently told crones or like really?
Oh daisy,
really?
Crohn's has crazy guillotines but this
is not exactly like guilty and it's like
a form of a gal at
something like the form,
but it's fucking know
what they're saying is.
Yeah,
the fits.
The knuckles are here.
You can kind of see it.
The knuckles are going deep into the
neck as opposed to the regular gay team
where you're cutting off the windpipe
or cutting off rather the blood on the
[inaudible] same thing.
Well I liked the trachea smash.
I like Roth Rollover.
Junior dos Santos.
I keep picking against them.
I got to stop that tracheal smashes.
Nasty
time.
So as soon as you,
if it's good or the tribe,
it's immediate.
You know it's got a nasty one of those.
Amal Easton,
he's nasty one of those.
Oh he was.
He demonstrated it on me,
man.
I couldn't tap quick enough.
It's one of those,
there's certain guys,
man,
I don't want your riot a strangle me,
but I would like to know
what's going on with that.
Cause he's one of those motherfuckers,
he and Benevidez is another one,
gets a hold of your neck man.
Remember when Benevidez fought Tim
Elliot and he had to tap with his feet?
Dude,
some shit,
son Benevidez has got some jokes,
he's got some skull.
There's a lot going on with that
and that a lot of in different ways,
you know,
just because you're good at
one way doesn't mean they're
going to be good at it
this way.
He's big.
He as either,
I remember when I found them and
just like you're a giant gorilla,
ruin your a gorilla.
He's a gorilla gorilla.
He's allergic slugging.
You're sitting next to him.
Hey Buddy,
look at this.
Look at this picture of Benevidez
with like a almost like a mouth guard,
which I love that.
That's what I,
that's the most nasty
can dive in a little bit.
And then on top of that,
he's just fucking [inaudible]
motion to tap with his feet.
Both hands trapped.
Can't even say tap cause
he's eating humiliating.
Some Oblique,
humiliating fashion you
got to have with your feet.
He was like,
he tapped so harbor this feeling.
It wasn't even like I've no
nothing to do that image.
Like,
Oh that guy knows what he's doing.
No beginner and one of them professions
like nicest guys of all time,
fetus fuckers the salt of the earth.
He is an awesome,
oh is there a video?
It actually shows it.
Oh yeah.
Benefit is a monster man.
His grappling is so strong.
Oh really?
Underrated because you always see him
like moving well and punching and quirky
kicks and stuff.
He's seen him just being an overall
fighter but is his ground game.
Elliot was a wrestler.
Elliott's a tough guy.
Yeah.
When you got Elliot to the ground and I
saw him just to immediately advancing,
just clamping down.
I was like,
Ooh,
this is a high level
fucking position for him.
Love it.
But he's another guy
where you just got us.
This was as he mounted,
he hit it.
I mean,
you know how bad ass that is.
You never see that in him.
And he eats good sweet and they joined
some turn them over and just classic
shit.
You see it in class or for sure
should in class all the time,
but it doesn't quite make it over
to the UFC high level company.
Benevidez has the Misha Tate Syndrome
where if there was no Rhonda,
there's no Dj.
He's the motherfucker,
but just that during
the time they're there,
your second best sucks man.
Well also the second fight they had,
he tried to,
are we out of time?
So what's going on Jamie?
What happens?
Let's get it going
on three hours.
It was a big issue with
the youtube or Youstream,
but now we're on youtube.
They use,
we were having any
problems with your streets.
Now we've been on youtube for a while
because we were having problems with both
feeds on Ustream and youtube is so good.
It's like it's,
it's the best way to do it because
you can in the middle of it,
you can rewind it,
you can pause it,
you can do shit to it.
Couldn't really do that with Ustream,
so we decided to just keep doing,
I'm on youtube,
but Benevidez like the second fight with
mighty mouse was like a pivotal moment
because he decided to like
try to get flat floor.
Yup.
He just decided like his,
his benefit or his,
his pro on his corner is the power.
He's like,
I'm just going to dig my heels
in and fuck this dude up.
Repeat again.
How dare you?
So if you drink,
come with it.
Drank drunk.
He's the only three in three days,
but I'm,
it could use another,
I'm not gonna lie to you guys.
Kennan.
They in their gang of anyone want another?
No,
I'm good man.
Thank you.
You're on that crazy diet.
Yeah.
I probably shouldn't even drank this one.
I'm on for the new little brown.
A little for a little brown little brown.
I made a little brown,
big brown brownish shit
through at least half Mexican.
So wait,
what?
What are,
what is he,
did you see Brown Big Brown?
Yeah,
he's not black.
Kimble had to find that out the hard way.
Kim is black.
It's a hilarious story.
They were,
uh,
they,
there was somebody who
was saying racist shit.
They thought,
and uh,
that,
that story of a Kimbo thinking,
you're black,
you're black.
It's like,
dude,
I'm not black.
What are you?
So that's what we love about.
What did he say?
What is the cause?
That's why I love Brian.
You know what the fuck is?
I love Kim Bowman.
He's one of my favorite
pieces of great guy.
I just,
I wish him success and I,
me too.
I love him.
You should have him on your show.
Jumped out,
would fall in love with the deal.
Anyway,
I loved
that.
And once you talked to Emily,
I damn man,
just a good family dude.
I just taken advantage of it.
I understand.
But if he's going to fight on TV,
he's got to be in better shape.
You just got to be in
better shape than that.
At the end of the day,
there's no excuse either one
of them have been in that piss.
Poor shape is one thing.
If they don't have the Cardia,
where's the bottle
opener up in this bitch?
You know,
I think he just thought he's
just going to knock that out.
So he said,
fuck it.
Let's go back to the Miami days.
We can't do that.
Yeah,
it doesn't work anymore.
You get embarrassed.
You want another beer?
No,
no,
I'm good.
We're just looking for the bottle opener.
What the hell do we do it?
How'd you open these eddy?
We had a bottle opener.
I swear we used it.
Okay.
What were we just talking about?
That'd be an epic podcast and Kimbo.
Yeah Man,
look,
I love Kimbo.
I think his story is awesome.
But dude,
I just feel like at this point in time
when you got guys like we'll Brooks when
you got guys like,
you know,
now we just got over Benson Henderson.
You got guys like Paul Daley.
You got um,
um,
Michael Page,
bad mother fucker.
You got some good town over there.
So the Russians,
yeah.
All the Russian guy draw though.
Man,
he's old.
I don't,
and he's all not,
not as a headliner folks.
You don't need that.
He was in the headliner,
Louise,
the Co headlining.
That's a service that's called main of
it's a circus act is you don't need that.
You could,
you could get away without that.
If you want to have that,
have that on before
you have a legit fight.
So you have that fight.
Unless there's like these crazy numbers
would have proof of one up fights.
17 million people are better numbers.
I bet you belters numbers were
better than cal poly card probably.
You know what?
Good thing I have no problem with Gracie.
Shamrock fucking four
I have no problem with.
I have no problem with head.
He probably wants to get back
in with the class as I went in.
The waste
can be wearing that shirt.
Lunch.
You guys switched.
He can't fit in that
shirt for first of all.
That shit's tight on you.
Fucking,
you just love me Dad.
Why would you hire daddy?
Hi.
He pushed me.
I'm just saying Kimbo was fun to watch.
Be.
Wait a minute.
You're defending killers but not a
voice and you're worrying about voice.
But the voices 50 listen carefully.
Probably healthier than let him go.
You know,
I kind like his chances versus Kimbo.
How about that?
I thought would just
go hoist versus Kimbo.
Now you're fucking,
oh my God.
It's like a 50 year old guy
and the best fight of all time.
That's the fight.
That's the fun.
He's already beat.
Ken shamrock do it in like Oklahoma on
an Indian reservation for both of them
can get their supplements.
Just juice to the gills.
That'd be some on fucking my tablet.
Why Not Bella?
Tori,
Tori.
You're welcome.
Yeah,
you're welcome.
Get back in there.
He got out versus Ken shamrock.
Zack,
what I was going to say,
they would just keep the data show go and
I think Donald's can send has to do is
dance around for the first 30 seconds.
Donna's out of gas.
Hey,
you know how you know fighting's not
for you because when you have a heart
attack after the fight,
he almost died.
Isn't that a sign of his courage though,
that he was able to push through
when his cardio is completely failed?
You're still,
do you want her to get one?
Her Stupidity?
I don't know.
Rude.
We'll do anything for a paycheck.
You guys to say Shit.
I said that his body was filled mashed
potatoes and then you say something and
I'm like,
well you said it's racist
Meatloaf,
fried chicken,
Dada,
you eat horrible.
I loved Donald Serone
Macdonald and magnate Neil Mag.
Do you love him
dude?
Hector Neil,
Maggie's awesome.
I like,
Hey,
let's be real about that.
Hector's 37 38 he's coming off of a
suspension for quite a long time for
steroids.
Right?
How long has this suspension?
I think it was a long time.
Been a while,
but it's more than a year.
Oh yeah.
So what do you think about that fight?
When?
When they first told me
that Neil fight fighting,
I told him,
I said,
I don't like it cause Neil
doesn't use his range.
She's fucking,
who's that?
Who's that?
God,
I don't know.
That was on fight pass,
I guess.
Oh my God.
What a bloody war.
These two chicks had who call my Twitter.
They said this was fight of the night.
I heard,
wow,
Jesus Christ.
Oh look at that guy.
That guy had some kung food.
That is the thickest torso.
So I've ever seen in my life.
Boom.
Wow.
That guy looks good.
Holy Shit.
He's African.
Who has tried to them Goosey?
God Damn.
Holy Shit.
That guy looks like
people are just getting fucked up tonight.
Who was that white boy?
He got hands.
Oh my goodness.
Sake.
Sean Strickland.
Oh,
he knocked out Alex Garcia,
Garcia Garcia the tank,
and he kissed the ground.
He's gonna get staff from good.
Let's get that.
Yeah,
he has got Stephanie Lipson,
Merce on that bottom.
Chris Kamozi performances at night.
Donald's fight,
fight,
and then those chicos garments bonuses.
That's so weird to me.
I feel like I'm watching some fucking
hunger game shit performance post 50 grand
fatality,
extra money for maiming career ender.
Do you know why they comp
performance of the night?
And that's the mission of the night
anymore because sometimes they'd have no
submissions and what's,
I'm trying to,
it sounds too violent.
Knock out of the night.
Sounds like it's promoting violence.
Oh,
who said that?
I can't say that.
You just make that up.
Eddie and spirit like we
promoting like the most violent knockout.
So let's just call it performance.
Well they definitely tend to shy
away from blood on these shows.
I was kind of shocked that they showed
that one in the replay because that would
those two gals,
cause that was,
is that,
is that sexist?
Is there any truth to Fox choir?
Fucking say gals.
I've uh,
I've
been scared to say bitches.
Just scared to ask.
Like you've say,
those bitches can find if the free
Tito's leave though and Dana leaves,
look this thing,
this ship is sinking.
This thing is not entirely like
actually my friend Ashley Ashley,
Evan Smith.
Jesus Christ.
She looks awesome.
No,
no.
That's the girl getting the girl,
her friend.
His,
your friends.
The one that was getting ready to,
we got an ass kicker.
Ashley.
Evan Smith got whooped
by that girl like that.
What's his girl's name?
Split decision right now.
Oh,
Maureen minnows.
That Myron Renaud his Rogers.
What happened?
Why is he showing US weight?
Does the rest,
there's a six cause controversy going on.
What happened there?
Oh,
29,
28 Reno for me.
Oh,
they're just talking about the decision.
I guess it was a decision.
And who want 29 28 Reno DC.
Sounds like the other girl one.
It sounds like Ashley Smith one cause I
mean they're showing like score Gannon
and something really something happened.
Should I get her ass kicked?
Judge One judge score 30 27 I dunno.
We don't know.
How can we comment on a fight?
We didn't even know.
I love it.
That's why we do these things.
It's one click and see
what happened there.
Get to the bottom
right to the money generator.
This is the money General Ashley,
Evan Smith One.
Okay.
So they're saying it's a
bad decision or something.
Yes.
Oh that's what it is.
I like Ashley.
I haven't done it for a long time.
She's a nice girl.
She's a girl that beat Fallon Fox.
She's the one girl that beat that.
A transgender MMA fighter
that used to be a dude.
That's right.
And she's,
she's BFF with uh,
Carla.
Is She?
Oh that's cool.
Hang on it,
I got to just fucking
deal with all of them.
Cause now you know,
Carla's at my gym.
How's she doing?
She didn't.
Good.
When does she get him back in there?
I don't know yet.
I mean she's trained in hard down though.
She decided to take some time off
and like really work on her game.
Yeah,
her striking and just,
yeah,
just eat,
just revamp everything
and get her head straight.
And you know,
she got her fucking ass kicked.
Well she fought a murderer and Polish
murderer and she went into it mentally
flat.
I mean I,
I'm there every day with her,
so I,
I saw weeks in advance.
I was like,
oh,
she's fucked.
Do you see just this flat because of the
pressure or do you think she was flat
because of over training or what do
you think Yolanda is a fucking murderer
mixture of all of it.
You can get in with them.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we're sitting backstage and we could
hear you want to warming up fucking
right next.
Sorry.
And
Carlos sitting there,
we go.
And I just looked at it.
I was like,
fuck,
come here.
Let's start.
Let's warm up.
That's what I'm about.
That's where up.
That's what I'm up by.
You want to,
let's just fucking screaming in there the
whole time for like two hours doing it
there.
The fuck with [inaudible] bars?
Probably not even hitting pads really
has someone smack and things and she's
just yelling.
She just had this [inaudible].
It was very,
you know,
it was fucking like my
grandpa said back in the,
in,
in the world war,
whatever war he was in,
sit in the Japanese were hitting the
trees with their swords and middle of the
night,
all night long,
whack,
and just screaming in the jungle,
trying to keep you awake.
Yeah.
Brian,
I think everyone when they saw you on it,
just fucking merch girls was like,
I'm gonna take some time off.
Work on my stand.
The Julian fight was the worst.
Good luck not doing a pen.
Yeah.
Uh,
Jessica [inaudible],
Jessica Pinay and that's another
girl I've known for a long time.
She merged her,
she gave her a nose job.
Fullstory smashed her whole face,
smashed her face.
She's so scary with her striking match.
She's a mother fucker,
but she breaks her hands all the time.
She's got uncle creepy did still wins.
Yeah.
Oh,
she guts it out.
Yeah.
She says she's fucking,
he got to the point where she was fucking
with Carla and then with all the noise
I walked out to that fight fucking
staring at her and was like,
fuck you don't get head kicks in that.
Oh yeah,
I'm looking at her cause my,
you know my,
my basically little sister is about to
fight you and then she put your fucking,
if you loved her,
why'd you let her fight her?
If you really loved her and
you see you on a kick boxer,
pull her aside and the
last two year Vandana done,
do a little fishing.
Them Wonderland cruises.
It goes through the
killer whales in Alaska.
Let's just get the fuck out of it.
We don't need to be doing this baby
because she didn't take me out.
Shit.
Chung,
we take them as friends.
I had the sibling rivalry maybe
marked now that was fucking that.
It broke my heart.
She was a champ.
She had to defend her title.
There's no way around it,
you know,
unless she vacates the title and says,
look,
I'm going to take some time off.
You know,
we'll do that in a glory.
Valtellina he had a concussion.
He said,
I'm going to vacate the title.
I'm going to walk away.
I'm going to,
you know the rest of my
fucking brain up dude.
Good luck being Carla.
Yeah.
Well that division is just,
how about cologic a day?
Yeah.
There's a good argument.
That clause.
You get dairy.
He won the first fight.
I thought she had a lot
of people just close.
It's very close.
I bet you this next one isn't.
I think so.
Yup.
Because he called me a
hate or glass happened.
I just think Yolanda is
going to fuck her world.
I feel the same way.
Well to different it could.
She could or we could see.
We don't know until they get after it
because I'm just saying what my educated,
yeah,
I agree.
She looked great.
Coach is a beast,
man.
Girl.
That's town game too.
And I'm still like a
little Thiago Alvarez.
The last girl that fought,
uh,
you,
ANA is Valerie.
She took when she took her down,
I was like,
oh,
you're to kind of sucks.
Okay.
Valerie was tough as fuck.
She's tough as fuck.
She,
she always looks the
same after every fight.
So fucked up swollen eye.
That girl's tough.
You want to get them there in Amsterdam
and goes with the dude's just does work
teams.
It's Christ that and she's
tiny one got his style is to,
they're like,
hey,
those white pose,
let's likes it makes us up.
That's her story that she makes it up.
Oh yeah.
She got all the money and she's like,
fuck this,
uh,
interest your game up.
Kanye shoes.
No,
she's not that famous.
This,
this.
The fuck is the cornea shifts.
Don't remember me and Jamie stayed up
all night and we looked at that form all
nine or we didn't get them.
You know,
there's a really big fight at one 79 yeah,
I'd like to hear this.
He said all kinds of,
just mind fucking him.
Okay.
Oh,
here.
This,
yeah.
Turn it up.
Can we rewind it?
Just a pit.
You can't rewind it.
Why can't we rewind?
It was just a montage of his shit talking.
Isn't this direct TV?
We could rewind it.
What do we cave people?
You don't think you see people
sitting there watching a commercial?
I'm like,
you know,
you don't have to do this.
Let's pause this bitch and
go get something to eat.
I agree though.
Fuck.
Are we doing fucking Harris crank it.
I'd say about 26 2016 at 12 at the
end of 2015 and means the end of the
[inaudible].
They are all dead in the water.
It's doing what?
I have my eye and at one
35 that is in a nice seat.
I'm all stuck in the mode in there will
be killed like I big dent and then it's
on to the [inaudible] still in the mode.
That vision.
How?
By being wrong,
the wrong yet
this motherfucker,
God damn shit.
Nothing's ever the same.
It's always different.
Religious people going crazy,
crazy,
mad at him.
I keep trying to go to the place that
are the guy that makes his suits.
I work out with him,
but it's a little too explain it.
August.
Yeah.
He makes us suits for the UFC.
On those monkey suits that you
see me wearing now and all.
David,
I guess he makes us feel great suits.
They fit great and I don't
have to bring clothes.
That's what I like.
I can dress normal.
I just show up and change
happen in your locker room now.
I used to have to bring my own clothes.
That's why I always wore
the same exact shit.
Black shirt,
jeans and black shoes.
That's it.
That's all I wore.
I,
I've even seen all that.
The chain dragging that I do.
I'll put like one of those anchor
harnesses on and put a hundred,
200 pounds of chains and
drag it for like a mile.
Yeah,
it would give me a suit or five.
That all fits my little
short troll body perfectly.
See,
it's hard to find suits.
Luckily I used to work in the fashion
industry so I know what the fuck.
Imagine being Yoel Romero.
Oh God.
Shit.
Right to try to find a suit for one
of those guys are in Dan [inaudible].
Remember him
around and bald?
Yeah.
Remember Dan Bobas
Bill.
Look up fucking brick.
Shithouse man,
like I was gigantic suits.
Suits aren't for everyone.
They're not for you.
Are they?
Oh,
I love a suit.
A suit.
I love the suit to how many seats you got?
Couple for you to buy yourself a suit
when your kid turns one probably or
another.
Watch push Michigan matching suits.
I had to have like a three
or four suits when I,
when I commentated for
King of the cage and,
and pride.
There's builders,
there's Boba shop
kicking the cane.
Forgot about that guy.
Remember when Mark Kurtz admitted him?
Both uh,
um,
excuse me,
a Chin and the eyeball
to
eyeball and forcing him
there until he tapped.
She was nasty.
I remember that fight.
King of the car.
Look at those before Mark Kerr,
the fucking smashing machine.
That's back when mark was the specimen
before he even became a smashing machine.
Yeah,
man.
He was the specimen first dude.
He might not.
He might have one.
The best bodies mash made for white guys,
Brazilians columnists,
smashing machine.
When he went to Brazil and he
went to Brazil before the UFC,
who called him a specimen.
Then I thought that was his two pictures.
Why people call them that
resilience Commons bashing machine.
The Brazilians call them and machine
thought best white man body fucking neck.
Good Lord.
First of all,
is he totally white?
Cause I would say yes.
I think so.
First team all body right
now he's got my pig.
Yeah,
definitely.
The round his ass of all time.
Is that real?
When he was at his best,
he was fucking terrifying.
But the thing is no one can sustain that
level of Jews for more than a few years
and I and other intervenous drugs,
whatever else he was doing.
Butter bean right there.
That's povish.
That's,
yeah,
that's buttery.
Oh that is a smashing machine is
best body and worst body ever an MMA.
This smashing machine
was a crazy documentary.
If you haven't seen it
folks pause this podcast.
I've never seen a watch it.
You've never seen the smashing
machine and I love me.
Some does shake of show goods.
They caught him right
when he was falling apart.
They,
they went to him to film a documentary.
When occur was on top of
the world smashing people.
And what they found is a guy who was just
about to lose it like right when they
came along and started filming
it and he didn't give a fuck.
He was,
he was like shooting up in front of them.
He was doing drugs in front
of them within any gay too.
Not that it matters,
but wasn't he getting,
that's never been shown.
I don't know if that's true or not true,
but he wasn't a weird relationship with
some woman and then yeah he was shooting
up like like actual painkillers.
Pharmaceutical.
Damn Dude.
It is it on everywhere.
It's on everything.
Smashing machines and everything
is probably on iTunes too.
It's really good.
How do you think this guy like I like
Woodley feels like sit on the outside.
No one that they want Wonderboy to fight
for the title and knowing the reality
is if he doesn't secure that fight with
Robbie Lawler before UFC 200 and Connor
knocks out though San Joe's,
fuck you're a couple of weeks,
he's in third place,
he's in third place and he deserves it.
Well,
he's in second place
because like look wise,
public wise,
he's not in first place,
but like the UFC does,
ohm won.
Right?
So they think he's going to
fight for the title next.
If he does fight for the title next,
that's all well and good.
Unless Connor smashes dose on Joseph,
then all bets are off.
Everything's off.
Who would you put your money on?
Connor or Tyrone.
That would be crazy.
Right?
Well what good Connor due to that guy,
he's so fast that it
would be so hard to hit.
Yeah.
Well Tyron is a beast and he's
really good at closing the distance.
He's always had the car.
He might be able to take
Connor down at will maybe,
and you don't understand how long,
75 longer
take them down a wheel.
Right.
He can,
he can hit outside double or even
if he grabbed that really wide leg,
you know,
it's just getting,
getting in there is because Conor
is so fast and moved so fluidly,
but if he,
if he got ahold of them fucking he would
throw him on his head and hold them
there for a long time.
Yeah.
Damn.
Holly Holm and Misha Tate's come.
Come with,
that's an interesting fight,
Huh?
We should take it to,
to a dog fight and she's not
going to charge to smart.
Yeah.
She's going to turn into a
totally different kind of fight.
Me.
She hasn't fought for every cat.
Zingano.
What the fuck?
She had a hard time.
Um,
the uh,
before the Rhonda fight,
that crazy war that she had with um,
uh,
she knocked down Ameesha before that.
No,
no.
She knocked out Meesha that she hurt her
knee and then she had that Amanda Nunez
fight fight was chaos and the first round
she got hurt bad in the first round.
Bad.
And after that fight you
took a long time to recover.
Like she had a bunch of issues,
like mental issues after that fight.
Well,
not just that they're there
was for sure huge thing.
Yeah.
But I mean physical,
mental from,
from head trauma,
from getting rattled.
You know,
she had to take some time off.
She's taking a lot of time on the beach.
A fun of wow.
What's fought Ronda and jumped
at her and got caught on fire.
And did she fight after that?
No,
I don't.
Not that I know of,
but I mean she's,
she's,
she's so good,
but you know,
fight off,
you know,
what are they doing?
Showing us racing cars top now
what are you doing Talladega?
Is this still the UFC on Fox?
There was a nod ended.
They only do it for
the first half an hour.
Then they go to regular sports.
This is a crazy fucking
thing to do with your life.
Have you ever tried
riding one of those cars?
Have you ever been in a NASCAR?
I haven't and I don't give a fuck.
Anything with horsepower is fun.
But 300 it's 300 and he's
still going off that,
huh?
Yeah.
That's always got brewed up
a new movie coming out with
Gods of Egypt or something like that.
When everybody found out
his body wasn't really like,
it wasn't that show.
We were like,
Hey,
you robbed the CGI,
the CGI.
You are yoked,
Yo.
He ain't shit.
These cars must be so fun to drive.
Yeah,
I bet.
They're really fun.
Oh my God.
Could you imagine?
You can't get in Nascar though.
They go around the track power at times.
It just does nothing for me.
Have you ever been to an event?
No,
it's fine.
Let me guess.
Cars like this.
Fuck the cars.
You just walk around in
field or lock around.
My family has always been a UN
auditable dealership forever.
It used to,
so we would always get tickets to racist
and stuff and it's just entertaining as
fuck.
You got like 100,000 people show up to
people love it and they're die hard fan.
So I'm missing something.
Formula One is the shit.
Oh,
that's the best shit on the
plants while the war moto GP,
everyone's MotoGP.
You want to see a good documentary?
Um,
watch the documentary on art
and is called [inaudible].
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
He's a Brazilian,
a formula one driver in like the Hay Day.
He was a bad mother fucker.
Just a wild,
crazy reckless dude.
Yeah,
he took some mad chances.
It is a great already.
Jamie,
how about speaking of a
liver,
that one sketch that the Asian Nascar
driver who I promoted the hiring or
promoting Asian and mass card drivers
cause they would wreck in a people really
want to watch rex famous Asian guy
that they know they're going to look.
What happens when you fucking lose
control your car cause you didn't fuck up
rice to man.
Damn for sure.
[inaudible] we can't get Patrick.
Oh it's a chick.
Of course.
That's what happens.
Well watch that again.
Watch what she did.
Watch were cargos flying through the air.
Man,
watch this.
Go for it.
Before that though,
before when she gets clipped,
it just gives you an
idea of how fast they go.
Look,
he catches the corner and they get
our cars airborne sideways Sun.
I like when they yell at
each other concrete man.
She recovered what a rubbery finished,
dead last.
How often do they practice?
Like a dude demeaning hoovering
out of bad spots like that.
I mean that's how much
your training right?
Should that be part of their training?
But I'm sure it is.
I'm sure.
Let's say their fucking life.
Well,
they have to turn things so
you don't hit things head on,
you know like in that sense she,
she was,
she recovered perfectly.
But like when you're flying
through the air sideways like that,
you really can't control it.
When that happens.
Like if you're too close to a wall
and just going to hit kick it down,
shit's out of it.
You can increase your make.
You can gas
isn't the air blows.
That was though.
I mean I'm just saying that cause I slid
out in the rain in my old built Subaru.
Well that's the same thing
so that I can just fucking,
hi.
No you fucking head north 70
you can't do anything there.
She's going a hundred miles an hour faster
or 150,000 I grew up driving in snow
and Sun Chevrolet on the bottom coil.
The top Chevrolet on the bottom.
What does that tell you?
Nothing.
Ford right there in the middle.
Chevy wins.
Do the Toyota is the shit.
The Eric depends what era we're in here.
Daytona and Toyota's winning.
How isn't what it is kind of
crazy and it's bull shade.
Japan won best whiskey in the world
last year and also apparently the best
fucking NASCAR,
but they're not well don't
put them in Asian dry.
One of the most incredible
cars ever built right now.
The Nissan Gtr motherfuck they
have the new one that's out.
Well they have a new batch.
The new one that Nis,
mo.
Yeah.
Nissan GTR.
It's 600 doors.
Power issues.
What issues?
It's too fast.
No,
no,
no.
With no was the old ones
with the launch button.
How fast?
The first generation,
the first generation there
was just too much power.
They had to beef up the,
the transmission launch control.
Blow the trainee out.
If they did it more in a couple of times.
Yeah.
But the new ones that Nyssma
one who they say that you,
you're turns like defy physics.
Yeah.
Cause it's,
it's all wheel drive.
It's insanely bounce at 600 horsepowers
massive downforce on this huge wing and
you know,
it's way faster than that.
The new viper ACR viper just went.
Have you seen that thing?
Oh my God.
I watched five videos on it yesterday.
I watched five different videos
where they were driving on.
Jamie pulled that up.
You want to see the most
gangster carbide old viper?
Fuck that.
No.
This is the new one.
The new one is broken.
Every single track record,
every single track they've
racist thing on for time.
It's broken the record on how do
you understand how insane that is?
When does that stop?
How did they,
when does it go?
Zero to 60 oh zero to 60 in one second.
When does that happen?
Well,
it's there zero 60 this is just over to,
you can buy a Tesla car.
That is each everywhere it goes.
It's just be the fucking team America
song that's faster than a motorcycle.
Just swallowing people.
The handling of this
thing is fucking bananas.
It's more than 600 horsepower.
I think it's like 650 horsepower.
That was always the issue,
right?
Yeah.
The handling is off the charts
and it has the most downforce.
If any production car,
look at that hood.
Look at the louvers in the hood
and events and for what it is.
They're usually not that
expensive for the super car.
Take hard and if you
watch the videos on it,
it seems just glorious.
God,
they look fucking sweet dude.
Guys are driving these
things and they're just,
that's the only thing that
keeps you on the road,
Bro.
Yeah man.
That's your
style for looks.
I love the wing.
That thing is so fast.
He's put your groceries
in it and push it around.
Fuck.
They say it's the most,
the fastest American race car ever for
sure that you could just go to a store
and buy and the only cars that beat it
cost over a million dollars like like
this boot got here.
She had that for eight or
nine 18 oh I love that.
That's a pretty nice car.
Monster car,
but this thing is like hot on
its heels and it costs $160,000.
We're talking about something that loses
track time by like a 10th of a second.
Gosh,
that's the different logos.
Make me want to make this thing.
Look at that.
That is the coolest looking car.
That is,
that appeal so strong to
the 14 year old boy in me,
me to bed.
It's like seeing a hot chick.
Can they get it without the stripe?
No strikes.
Tictail tribes be a man.
Fuck a stylish sake.
I feel like I want to,
I want to get rid of my
Porsche and get one of those.
Hey,
look,
in the sake of blues,
don't get ready to push.
I hate,
I'm not going to just get both.
I like the way you think.
If anything,
I got to get a warehouse.
I've got to build more
wells in Africa first,
so I don't feel bad about it.
We'll just donate to Justin
dead and then we'll definitely,
I'm calling them tomorrow.
I was going to call him anyway.
I got to throw some more money in there.
I throw money in there every year.
He's trying to hype this.
You want to help them?
We had a hype as Kimbo fight for him.
Yeah,
well I'll definitely do that,
but I think I would like to
just get a bunch of people that,
oh,
is this the new,
the new rappers?
Bad Ass.
This is the new one.
Oh,
this is
the all aluminum one.
Why is people get talked about cars.
Do you know that really get mad?
Yeah,
they go good fucking money.
You want to talk some shit bro.
Guy got mad because I was saying that
a Mustang is a great bargain at $35,000
and he's like do $35,000
not fucking cheap.
A lot of us out here in the real world,
that rubric.
Well whenever you do sir,
don't ever watch those motor trend videos
because they'll bum you out every week
cause I can't afford most of those cars.
So you definitely can't
afford those cars either.
If you're complaining about
$35,000 Mustang and I get it,
you know,
if you only make like 50 grand a year,
that's a lot of money.
But you got to look at
what a Mustang is like.
Realistically,
don't put yourself into it and
how much money people make.
You look at a Mustang for 35 grand.
That is a steel steel.
The new jeep grand scheme of things
like on the price scale Mustang actually
look good.
This is the first generation
and mess things had been fine.
Like finally you've,
since I grew up with my dad
having a 65 four and a half,
they're 65 convertible with the boss
throw to putting their fucking car.
People at Ford mustangs
were so ugly until now.
They were pretty sixties they were
pretty goofy looking until like the most
recent Shelby gt,
500 items found in lever of the new ones.
Those are pretty sweet,
but the new ones are off the charts.
Cool.
Looking off the charts
for so all that noise.
I'm trying to hit that viper.
The viper is a monster.
Fiber's a monster but can't put a
baby seat and the vibe and you know,
got a base in my Porsche.
It's but my girls,
this SUV,
let me do my thing.
Let me fly.
Yeah and there's no AC,
no radio.
There's the NYSSMA.
Look at that thing.
Look at this fucking rocket ship.
Chapman.
Who's with the eyes compared to that vibe?
I think it's so ugly.
Oh it was definitely doesn't look as
good that Viper Shits on everything we've
seen.
What this looks like.
So with the GTR it looks like
is a spaceship with the viper.
It looks like it's sex.
Yes.
It looks like hot tits.
It looks like a girl with a 13 inch
waist and tits as big as the sun.
I want to drive.
That makes you want to drive.
That's why I wanted to drive a big
ridiculous bulb has asked that didn't no
shorts in the world.
Clown tins.
Ttrs fucking foxy petty but just fast.
It's funny you said that.
Forget about camel toe.
Moose knuckle Japanese girls are fit.
That's what it looks like.
Pussy.
The way her daisy dukes are
wedged up in her vagina.
It's elephant armpit
snuggles generally.
Is that a turn on for guys when
they see a motorcycle per show?
He puts his definitely.
There I
am.
I see John put on Instagram or something.
I saw like there's a
thing that you could add.
Girls just going to
call fake moose knuckle.
Yes.
No,
sure.
That's fake.
But why?
Why is it fake?
Why is that a joke?
Well,
because people try
anything to get an edge.
They'll try.
Dudes will load up their
parents with have sock.
I mean that.
That's how it can't be my friend.
If you do that,
if you put a sock in your bank,
can't do that,
man.
I'll be right back.
How do we get the sum up?
Make the knuckles
fake.
Wedgies fake asses for sure.
Wedgie genes now.
Yes.
So they write up in that household.
So it looks like your acids.
Imagine smell on the crack of those
things after a long day in Mexican food.
It's tough.
Yeah,
there's Wedgie jeans.
Why not an asshole?
Don't press up Wedgie g that s oh,
I see somebody custom makes your
ass look highlights the ass shit.
That looks like shit.
How dare you.
How Eddie?
Well,
those are flashing negative.
No offense show negative either.
Ashlyn's pants.
Brendan's girl,
the girls pulling up their jeans nowadays.
Brendan's girl sat for like two years now.
I like the low cut.
I'm still with the low cut.
You're pulling jeans up your
ass and you fucking up the,
I don't know,
Dude.
Don't get angry at
the ball the way they're
going to end up on the floor.
It's fine,
bro.
Chill.
Nothing beats yoga pants still though.
Just chill.
Grow site on his fucking trends
or full components apart.
Any girl that wears anything other
than yoga pants is that asshole?
Yeah.
Good point.
Do you,
you'd know that you could
wear them everywhere.
We'll take it.
We'll accept know how the hear you.
Please just continue to
wear those everywhere called
leggings are just going to
call him.
Ted.
Do you do yoga?
You do yoga
and working out state of mind.
It's a form of meditation.
You have your daytime workout gear and
then you have your nighttime workout gear
and girls do.
Now I like to be like
sleek and move to the air.
Easy air dynamic.
Thanks.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It took so long to figure out yoga pants,
Lala,
Lulu pants,
whatever.
They aren't.
Keep going.
La La,
la,
La Lou,
Lou parents and how funny is that shit?
Those are huge scam.
They're making a fucking
killing Jesus Christ.
They know how to jam those bitches in.
They look good.
They straighten out all
the cellulite and shit.
You can't even see none
of that packet and tight.
And if the,
if the cloth is just thick enough,
he can hide a lot of flaws.
They may be a Downer here,
but they'll honey dick yet
cause it's like sausage.
You released that.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Get sloppy.
So thin.
You know what I'm saying?
With holes in them.
So
there's a little velcro.
You just go like that band.
You don't ever have to take them off.
Lou Lou Lou mall.
Yeah.
There's something about
those fucking yoga pants,
man.
It's amazing how dumb they were in the
60s and the 70s never figured out any of
this shit until the dukes
of Hazzard came along.
Then everyone figured out cutoff jeans.
Now daisy overnight cut the jeans off.
As soon as they figured out that,
oh you could basically just have your
vagina a slight tug away cause all you
have to do if you want to fuck
his girl was wearing daisy dukes.
She bends over you.
I those,
those jeans are pretty tight.
There's the moon.
It's not that easy.
The giants with underwear.
Yes.
Jean unbuttoned that button one button
dunk and you push that pitch oversight.
See,
but then dirty ones,
Eddie,
but she's hurt.
You see daisy Duke had the right thing.
See the girls today?
They were daisy dukes,
but they're so tight.
You came and get them off.
Daisy dukes were not
that were falling off.
Looking at CCC.
CCC
told you those things are kind of loose.
One pop of that brass button and
that cooters flying into the breeze.
Right through action.
Do you see Jessica Simpson and the remake?
She has something to say
to Sheila had no ass.
How it really help Eddie,
you're so negative.
Oh,
she does?
Yeah,
she got her.
You got the car too.
Fast forward.
That's just a Samson way,
dude.
Her assets,
Jessica's
love.
She was young right there.
What's that?
Is that Jessica Simpson's Pam.
Whoa.
Oh Shit.
Whatever that is,
and she's a good time.
She was a good kid.
Okay.
See just Google Jessica
Simpson's and ass please.
Yes.
She was just very top of all
time as my grandmother would say.
She has a lovely figure.
Yes.
Your grandma's right.
Wow.
I missed that one.
I never lovely.
Never knew that.
Real big neck naked in pregnant.
Yeah.
Get a good bullshit.
Let's just click on any
one that's hard to tell.
Is that she was so fine.
That's her tell.
That's a Jessica Simpson.
I really can't tell that you really am.
Logos are low left.
I'm very impressed with
to choose a banger.
Low left.
Looks very good.
That could be the angle.
Her and her prime man.
She top 10 for,
what about the pregnant ones?
Oh,
that's pretty good.
Okay.
Get stressed.
That bitch out Jamie.
That seems like an angel to that is her.
Is that,
oh,
she does answer bro.
That's that swimsuit model,
but that's not her.
That's not her.
That's the one from [inaudible] recording
everything that's good in the world.
So is the pregnant girl.
I'm talking
Sarah.
That's a very,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have any
problems with that booty.
That's a good booty.
All right.
How about right there at
the blue pants that were,
well,
who's got the best ass ever?
Is that ever been established via Greer?
Dude?
Oh,
what can Eddie,
we get a high five for this.
People know bad.
She used to be the booty girl before the
Instagram days before she was doing a
poster.
She crushed it.
She still is.
She has an Instagram.
She's 42 now,
but still dime piece 30 42 oh good Lord.
Okay.
She wins.
She just wants,
you weren't ready for that.
Wow.
You boys weren't ready.
It's insane.
Isn't it amazing that like the
shape is worth so much more.
She lives in La to like having a big
ag about having shape like that to your
fake asses.
It's weird.
No fake ass is that will not accept
fake gas will really not at all.
Very
fake asses.
Like I gotta take this wing off.
I don't care for protecting me.
That shit don't make me look good.
I'm not sick.
I don't want like the implants.
But when they put the
fat like the cellulite,
have you done what I saw?
What they look like?
It looks horrible.
Nah,
it does.
The ASCE has to be natural to all mine.
Look,
you've been out of the game too long ago.
It's really simple.
You to stick with you boys.
Let it checks.
That's it.
It's like to backup quarterback's.
I'm at a play that's not a full gas.
That's all right.
You're out of your mind.
All you have to do squats,
tits you have,
you have to fake it sometimes
cause there's nothing you can do,
but acid you can build.
You just squat.
Now you can just tell that
it's your new lifestyle squat
and I say carbs and I skate.
Skate,
skate it.
You should have a tee shirt that you sell.
Itches.
It says Eddie Bravo mouth open.
He's a blazing
and squat.
Squatting is hard,
but once a week
it is,
but you can change it.
You can improve upon.
You can tighten it,
you can tighten it and
you could make it rounder.
You take any chick,
any flat ass Chicco who skipped PE class
wed ditching notes and it never went.
You take a 23
whatever.
You take her at 25 she,
she realized she fucked up
by fucking skipping PE class.
She really,
she really likes shat
all the nerdy chicks.
We're playing soccer now
that out of the kids.
But if they go to fucking Colorado,
find the Olympic squat team,
go do some squats for fucking two years.
I don't make a big difference.
Trust me.
Right.
But it ain't [inaudible] Guerra.
You gotta be kidding.
Inject some steroids to the ass,
right into the ass,
right at the boat.
Checks every day.
And then squat,
squat,
squat swatch about two,
three years.
There's,
you're going to see a big dip and she's
going to have a dick that she could drop
on your forehead while
she rides your face.
It's called surgery done in Brazil.
It's in the water man.
They have to walk up and
touch Garson right now.
She's in this new short film that
just showed up online the other day.
That's a pencil.
Anderson.
Yeah,
she's playing a character or something,
but oh,
this is that new film.
It's supposed to be like really strange.
They,
they did a piece,
it,
it was it one of those um,
online,
um,
things that a piece on it,
like a lot of it is like her wearing no
makeup and it's pretty like gritty and
real.
Whoa.
Damn.
Yeah.
It's a hard world man.
It's interesting what these girls
become like cause they go from being the
hottest thing in the world where everybody
wants to fuck them to being like,
you know,
an older lady,
Lydia,
dude,
it's,
everybody goes to it.
But women,
especially women especially man tame it.
It's a motherfucker.
Especially like Pamela Anderson for sure.
Carmen,
Electra,
all these beautiful actresses.
I remember when I moved from
Orange County to Hollywood,
I thought,
what am I going to bring?
And I brought a couple porno mags.
I was 21 and I didn't know who Pam is.
I didn't know who she was.
It was 1991.
She was on the cover of playboy and
like I'm bringing this motherfucking one
because I don't know who that girl was.
I never looked her name up.
It turns out she was Pamela Anderson.
Oh look at this.
She's like walking on the beach,
Venice hot young girls in their little
skimpy things and they've gotten very
little makeup,
had a great life.
How old is she?
She had a great life.
I a look at the big sigh.
She's looking at it and she's drinking
juices and Shit to look young just is
bumming me out.
Jamie.
Whoa.
Incense sense and trying
to get her mind right now.
Mass Day.
She's still got good hair.
She's a pretty girl.
But
when that's your whole
world like never had kids.
No cats.
She has,
she has two songs I like show.
I like when they show a spike
and we need to and shit.
Tommy Lee,
I like,
I like it when they show her smoking weed.
She was like sitting down like it's over.
She was like crumpled dude.
That was how bummer.
Did you know what,
what?
I met Pam Anderson once.
Her brother's an old
friend of mine and we were,
we were doing some work together whenever,
when I went,
she lived in Malibu at the
height of Pamela Anderson.
You know,
she was different.
She was dating.
It was after Tom.
I,
but she was dating Marcus Shankin Berg.
He was a supermodel six foot five and
me and her brother were in the back
smoking weed and he comes back and goes,
hey,
do you mind if I have a couple
of folks to that weight?
So we're sitting back and I'll
never forget thinking this guy,
I would never have my girl
around this motherfucker.
I was so blown away.
I'm like,
holy,
she's a giant piece dude.
Six foot five.
He Alan's you Bob.
It'd be scared of this easy.
Let's say Alan can fight.
Marcus Shanken Berg
intimidated when he busted his ass
gay.
His picture that anybody's ever taken.
This guy's intimidating.
No,
no.
He's too gay looking.
One of the gates.
That dude up poses
to death.
Do you know that he's
done [inaudible] come on.
Handsome guy.
No doubt about it.
Foot five.
He looks too like he's a handsome fellow.
It just got to stop with the [inaudible].
Think about this.
He got Pamela Anderson Enterprise.
Welcome to the club,
the club.
You also probably got a lot of things
that she was carrying along with it for
the,
come on.
Tell me.
They said,
here's who is there you go.
How old is she?
50 something now.
Now she's probably like close to 50
you seen Cindy Crawford hot as fuck.
Yeah.
Let's see what it looks like right now.
Her in person at a party
less than a year ago.
She's beautiful.
I saw her six months ago
off Santa Monica and I,
it's the,
I can't remember last
time I looked at it girl,
I was like,
oh my kid ourself usually Kippy off.
She's not self destructive,
you know?
And she's been smaller.
Treasury has been smart about that.
They'll skim cream.
Christie,
Christie Brinkley,
60 fucking two years old.
Like,
I mean that's a far shot.
We need to listen to me,
man.
I met her.
I was talking.
I've seen her first.
It was a dark part.
Nah,
she's a dynamo.
He said outside.
I saw daytime,
daytime Santa Monica.
Fuck you talking about bitch.
Who was in light?
Light,
light.
Look at that one right there.
How dare you do Cheese 50 Eddie?
Well,
what?
You know what Christie
Brinkley's just as hot.
She's a decade older.
How about that?
Here's a picture.
I used to have a picture
of Cindy Crawford,
a poster of Cindy Crawford up in my room.
That was like my inspiration.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
like,
I'm like,
that's why
you me just wanting to fuck her.
That's like,
it's like he wanted,
it's going to work out.
One day.
I fuck her.
One day I will one day
I say,
no,
that's the girl broke my toes.
That's the one.
Well that's,
that's one thing.
But you look at a Christie Brinkley,
they took a picture of a recently,
she was 62 in New York and she looks
like she's a really hot 34 year old.
She must found that,
that shit your time.
Now that technology,
um,
she's a dynamo.
She probably doing every trick
in the book the right way.
He puts it in her fucking skin cream.
Good.
Something to look into
that her skin creams,
picture telling everybody.
This is how I stay young.
I put some Papaya juice on my face and
she's not going to tell those young
boomer shorts.
She sells the shit.
Cindy Crawford has skin cream.
It was just a picture of her recent.
She's 62 that's not a good
picture is a better picture of it.
Treating me.
Good ones there.
That's her picture of her
and our 62nd birthday.
No,
that's too much sugar.
She's old as fuck.
There's a really,
really recent picture.
It's like Christie Brinkley honor 62nd
birthday and she's like in a car and
you'll look at her,
you'll go,
why?
How is that possible?
I mean,
there's a lot of them.
Either way,
they all look good.
You're not going to find
one where she looks bad,
which is a really crazy,
yeah,
but that's her.
You know,
I'm 62 years.
Damn.
She's hot as fuck.
Look,
60 fucking two,
man.
Holy Shit.
She must work out all day or not.
Or something.
Could be jeans.
It could be cubic gather.
She's the right doc.
Crazy.
Dot.
Yeah.
Who
knows?
What do you think it is?
He would call this back exercise veganism.
Is It v?
Does that happen?
Maybe.
Maybe some others.
Maybe there's something to veganism.
Um,
I don't know.
I've never seen anyone like looks
really good and it'll like late age.
That's a,
that's saying that that's
the only way to do it.
They think nobody.
I think the thing that like a healthy
balanced diet is certainly the way to stay
at least in reasonably good condition.
But then you gotta like find the right
amount of amino acids and the right
amount of vitamins.
What's it depend on the person.
What the hell he was Leo each body was he?
No,
no.
He no,
he no,
he hit me.
He grabbed me.
He had his own farm.
He had his own,
like he made his own cheese.
He lives in his nineties
and he was healthy.
He was doing harm bars to 93 I don't know.
I haven't heard of conspiracy about
them doing that weekend at Bernie's with
him.
No matter what.
Come on man.
I was like,
Damn Bro.
I'm on Dario Dario.
Gotcha.
Sorry.
Great.
He ain't really no did he was,
he died in his nineties which
is way above the average.
The average age of
Americans at 75 healing.
He lived 20 years past the
average and he was still like,
you know,
you see him in interviews,
he's old.
It's kind of the physical exertion of it
looked like his brain was still intact
and you know,
there's something to that
Gracie Diet when he uh,
well it's,
it's certainly always smart to watch what
you're eating and making sure you get
a lot of healthy foods and he wasn't into
anything processed and he bullshit in
the Gracie Diet.
Yeah,
no alcohol.
The Gracie diet is really interesting
because the idea behind it is that you
make different enzymes
for different things.
Like you would never eat
meat with like water.
We don't make certain foods,
certain foods.
And apparently it makes a lot of sense.
I don't know who came up with it though.
You know who the,
who is the originator of that diet?
Was it Carlos who maybe it was Carlos.
Carlos was super into like a spiritual
channeling and all sorts of astrology
follow it.
Yeah.
There's something to that because Henry
Henry's offsite every single night for
dinner,
they're doing something right
on that big ass boulevard site.
That's interesting.
You know,
like there's no law and flax
seed and all sorts of stuff.
Well those videos of these to make
about how to make juices and all these
different things.
Energy Sandwich.
Yeah.
Well,
eating healthy,
he's fucking super important.
You mean you,
that's that stupid old
cliche that everybody hates.
But you are what you eat.
You are literally what you eat.
Your body body's made out of all the
nutrients that you put in and all the food
that you take in.
If you eat shitty food,
your body has shitty
materials to work with.
It's really that simple.
If you're not healthy and uh,
you're,
you're eating shitty food,
the first thing you should do
is stop eating shitty food.
It tastes so good though.
Done that mother fucker dude.
And two weeks into no shit.
I've had no shit at all.
Feel good.
Chit Chat.
You,
your face look skinnier.
Getting soft.
Do you feel like it?
Yeah,
I'm losing weight.
I lost eight pounds.
What do you weigh now?
One 94 [inaudible] 98 no.
[inaudible] 94 for real.
How dare you
not lost eight pounds.
I lost four pounds a week.
What was the most you've way recently?
I got two oh five when I hurt my back or
got up to like two oh five maybe even a
little heavier than that.
I got pretty fat though.
I had a good belly,
a good like a side belly and worse.
I felt gross.
I would catch myself in the mirror.
I go ill no more eating for you.
You fuck.
You know,
it got to a well when,
when my back was really hurting,
it was really tough to work out.
Um,
there was definitely some,
some time to pack on the weight,
but as soon as I started
working out again,
your body's got muscle memory.
If you know torture,
it was shitty food.
But this diet's different man,
because the idea behind it is that your
body starts going into fat burning mode
instead of glucose burning mode.
And if you can do that,
what happens is what's weird,
this is the,
one of the weirdest parts
about it is in between meals.
I don't get really that hungry.
I don't get the same kind of hungry.
Like when you're on glucose,
like your body crashes,
your sugar gets low and yeah,
and that crash,
you get fucking starving.
You get desperado following that
take you to get there though.
It took a while in the workout,
the workout,
the workout sucked some fat dicks for
like the first week I told you who's been
doing that diet for literally
three or four years is Tebow.
He shredded,
hey,
swears by egg,
won't Kingsbury's on
Kyle Kingsbury was raving about it
and he's one of the guys that got me
convinced that this is
definitely the way to go.
People,
I don't know.
I barely as super shredded.
He's a smart motherfucker,
man.
That guy,
great guy.
Kingsburg can easily do his own podcast
and I hope he does he ever get ahold of
you Jamie?
Yeah.
You guys working it out?
He made the ring card girl,
right?
Yeah,
Natasha.
They have a baby.
Beautiful,
something acute doing the damn thing.
He's an awesome dude.
He couldn't have been a nicer guy and
he knows a lot about like health and
nutrition and other bills.
He knows a lot about a lot of shit.
Very,
he's a smart dude.
I thought little ketone
meter and everything.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He,
um,
he did it with me,
but it didn't work then.
You know what he,
he's up there for top 10
most shredded UFC fighters.
He was Jack.
Well,
he's only been on that ketogenic diet,
I think for this past year.
Some,
you know,
some whatever,
every months,
but he's always been super healthy.
Always real good athlete.
He just got it.
May that Asu.
That's right.
Get into MMA way,
way late.
Way late.
I think 26 that what he said,
Jamie,
I remember after you like around
the same time as I got a 24 yeah.
Well,
you know in salsa.
Interesting about him.
I don't want to talk about it.
I want to discuss it and want him with on.
Beautiful.
What's interesting about
him as he's anti vaccine,
let's move on.
Let's move on.
All right,
please move on.
Let's go.
Vaccines.
Move on.
My kid just got back scenes,
all of them.
Not all of them.
Yeah.
Be careful.
You get the Hep B one.
You definitely want to get your kid
vaccinated a hundred percent they want to
get rid of as many different doctors
that prescribed me what they believe are
more conservative protocols.
And there's a lot of doctors,
again,
doctors who are leaning towards that
because they feel like it gives your baby
time to recover from the vaccines.
And it's not questioning
the efficacy of vaccines.
It's saying that there might be
some debate as to how many stack,
like how many put together
they just gave them.
There is a,
there's a possibility that if you crunch
them in together that there could be
problems because there's too much.
I don't want it.
There's a,
there's a vaccine court.
Okay.
And if you,
if you Google it,
find out how much money has been paid
off by people that took vaccines and got
injured or ill kids.
Babies had had issues because of vaccines.
Shit definitely has existed and,
but there's also,
it's also you have to deal with
how many numbers of people.
You're talking about 300 million people
and you know how many of those people
are addicted are allergic to walnuts.
You know how many of those people,
uh,
you know,
if they get around cats die option,
but that is the exception also.
Like biodiversity is a real thing.
They give the same medicine that
they give you and you'd be fine.
They could give me and
I could get deathly ill.
That is a,
that's a natural fact
of being a human being.
And that's something that there,
that people don't exactly factor in
when they start talking about vaccines.
Everybody thinks that it's either some
crazy government conspiracy to make
everybody retarded or it's
something that you have to do our,
we're all going to die.
Well,
what about,
what about the CDC study?
Uh,
from 2004 that they had to do a study,
the CDC to make sure that uh,
the MMR vaccine didn't,
there wasn't a autism links and there
was three doctors that were in charge of
that study.
So when this,
uh,
the results showed initially that there
were no links to autism with the MMR
vaccine,
but years later,
and it's,
it's happening right now.
One of the doctors,
Dr. William Thompson,
he still works for the CDC.
This is not a conspiracy theory.
He said,
we were told to to put all links to autism
from the MMR vaccine into the garbage
word for word,
verbatim into the garbage.
So this is actually happening right now.
So the studies find that Dr. William S.
Thompson Mmr vaccine to video.
Now this is real,
dude.
This is not a free youtube videos,
right?
We all know what I'm saying is watch.
Yes,
you're saying he said that.
So He's,
there's a video,
there's math videos and Madeline,
how about
you know,
insurance circumcision.
They asked me today,
you're going to circumcise your baby.
I said,
yeah,
I don't remember.
Have the anteater day.
You know what I'm saying?
$400 to babies Dix.
When you cut them like that,
first of all,
sometimes kids lose their Dick.
Sometimes.
Again,
infections,
like it's,
it's dangerous.
It doesn't always happen.
You circumstance.
Yeah,
but I didn't have a choice,
but if I had to choose today,
I would say,
no,
I'm on the fence as your
kid circumcised or not.
We have like three days on site.
Don't do it.
It's,
it's fucking
mutilation.
It like it's a cultural thing and
people liked the way it looks better.
You know whatever,
man.
You're mutilating your kids Dick.
The idea behind is barbaric.
It's archaic.
It's unnecessary surgery.
It's trauma.
You're cutting the kids.
Do you have an answer then?
No.
If he decides when he gets older to
get circumcised is not hard to do.
People who have done it like deep into
their thirties you can do whatever you
want,
but try telling me it's
under snappy champ.
That's not true.
It's bullshit.
God gave you that hood for a reason.
Congressmen,
a CDC whistleblower and an
autism tempest in a trashcan.
That's Forbes,
Huh?
Hmm.
I found a site that
didn't seem like a legit,
once I tried to find something
what everybody would.
Eddie rather was saying,
let's just pretend that you
forgot to write it down.
Talk about something
else and he gets back.
We got frost can be changed.
Go deep into the rich quick,
shut down.
If we go to page page,
he theory rabbit hole.
We're going to need to show booties the
whole please or maybe like feet porn.
Bring up a throat.
Zillow,
we should get out of here
early in the morning.
Let's wrap this motherfucker up.
This was the most non fight
oriented podcast ever know.
We covered some fight.
We barely covered the cowboy fight.
True.
Finally kid coming to
Deborah and Irvine live.
Oh Hey look at that plug.
Boom.
What?
Where are you going?
Remember in Vine devore and Irvine?
Yes.
Did you guys doing in Denver?
Uh,
March 18th the night club.
What we'll play comedy works comedy works,
Beautiful Tech Center.
Nice.
And then when the Irvine Improv,
March 16th,
nice fighter and the kid.com k.com.
[inaudible] Dot Com uh,
Eddie Bravo on Twitter.
Uncle creaky.
Uncle Creepy
freaky.
Now with the shoulder problem
helping open a craft therapy place.
We're going to have cryotherapy
and hyperbaric chambers go late
March,
March 15th in Lake Forest,
California.
It's a therapy Kraus alignment.
But uh,
yeah,
no shit out of that.
Yeah,
definitely.
You need to,
you need to have your own pocket and
wants to listen to me talk too much.
I like it.
All right,
that's it.
Goodnight everybody.
Oh,
Jamie Vernon.
Shout out to Jamie Vernon on Twitter,
the basketball.
Powerful young James.
Don't get me and Jamie some Yeezys.
Uh,
we'll be back tomorrow
with a action Bronson.
Oh,
Shit.
What's actually,
yeah.